GONNA START OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER SIX- CAN WE
STOP I CALL THE ROLL. TING HERE
RANDALL BLOOM ROW HERE COOPER
FONG HERE MCCARTY OBERNOLTE WE
WON'T. THANK YOU I'M GOING TO
START OFF BY GOING THROUGH-
AGAIN SOME OF THE PROTOCOLS FOR
THE HEARING- AS YOU KNOW THIS
IS OUR SECOND ASSEMBLY HEARING
IN THE ERROR- PHYSICAL
DISTANCING WE'RE GONNA BE
UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY AGAIN AS
WELL AS A TESTIMONY FROM THE
PANELISTS REMOTELY- THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE DONE VIA
TELEPHONE WILL BE- PUBLICIZING
THAT PHONE NUMBER ON THE TV
SCREEN AS WELL BOBBY READING IT
OFF IN A SECOND I DON'T WANT TO
JUST AGAIN TO. JUST SAY THANK
YOU AGAIN TO SPEAKER STAFF
ASSEMBLY RULE STAFF ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS IN THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER AS WELL AS MY STAFF
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR REALLY WORKING
EXTRAORDINARILY HARD IN PUTTING
LAST WEEK'S COMMITTEE HEARING
BUT ALSO THIS WEEK'S COMMITTEE
HEARING ON A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF HOURS WENT INTO MAKING SURE
THE TECHNOLOGY WORKED. AS WELL
AS WE COULD- HAVE AS MUCH
PUBLIC COMMENT AND TESTIMONY
REMOTE TESTIMONY AS POSSIBLE-
JUST IN TERMS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH TWO WE
HAVE A- PHYSICALLY DISTANT
OBVIOUSLY IN PERSON HEARING- WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE ELEVEN
MEMBERS AGAIN SEE SEE THAT THE
LOVE MEMBERS ARE SPACED OUT
APPROPRIATELY. WE ALSO HAVE
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL IN
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND IF YOU'RE
HERE TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT WE DO START THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD IF YOU COULD.
RAISE YOUR HAND AND THEN MOVE
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE-
WE HAD APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING- DURING THAT TIME.
AND YEP WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL GET
TO WHERE WE DO PUBLIC
COMMONSENSE THAT'S STILL COMING
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA GIVE IT TO BE
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND THEY WANT TO MAKE IT IF YOU
COULD EXIT THE HEARING ROOM-
ALL OUR PANELISTS AGAIN ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY TODAY- WE
HAVE STAFF HERE IN FROM THE
FROM THE ROOM TO STAFF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY TO ENSURE
THAT. THEY GET IN AND OUT AGAIN
JUST AS EVERYONE'S INDULGENCE
DURING THIS- DURING THIS PERIOD
WE MAY HAVE SOME TECHNOLOGICAL
GLITCHES AND- IF YOU COULD JUST
BE PATIENT WE REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AGAIN. WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO HAVE A GREAT NUMBER
OF PANELISTS TODAY TO REALLY.
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IN TERMS OF
REMOTE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS FOUR EIGHT FIVE
THREE T. TO- SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT RIGHT THERE ON THE TV
SCREEN WE'LL JUST LEAVE THAT UP
RIGHT NOW- AGAIN YOU CAN CALL
IT ANYTIME SO IF YOU CALL IN
NOW YOU BE ABLE TO HEAR. THE
BUDGET HEARING ON THE PHONE- IF
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO THAT YOU
pCAN CALL IN LATER AND YOU CAN
JUST WATCH THE LIVE STREAM ON
THE PHONE WERE ASKING EVERY
PERSON- WILL BE GIVING THEM ONE
MINUTE BECAUSE WE ANTICIPATE A
LARGE NUMBER OF CALLS. WHAT
ALSO URGE IS IF THERE ARE. MORE
THAN ONE OF YOU REPRESENTING
THE SAME ORGANIZATION IF WE DO
JUST ASK THAT ONE PERSON. SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATION
WE KNOW THAT THERE COULD BE AN
ORGANIZATION- THAT IS ORGANIZED
MAYBE TWENTY OR FORTY PEOPLE-
TO TESTIFY WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
THAT ORGANIZATION TO ONLY HAVE
ONE. IF I NOTICE MORE THAN ONE
PERSON TESTIFYING SAYING THE
SAME THING ON BEHALF OF THAT
SAME ORGANIZATION ALL I GOT THE
PRODUCT OF JUST TO. MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER SO IF YOU
COULD JUST DO THAT- I HAVE A
STACK OF PAPER YOU CAN KIND OF
SEE IT ON TV HERE I'M A LIFT
UP. THIS IS THE AMOUNT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT CAME IN IN
ADVANCE SO WE ANTICIPATE AGAIN
MORE PUBLIC COMMENT. COMING IN
SO REALLY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT- YOU SO YOU YOU KNOW IF YOU
IF YOU- BROUGHT IN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO THE SIR COLIN BUT YOU
CAN DEFINITELY FEEL FREE TO-
BUT AGAIN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ALL THE EMAILS THAT CAME IN. AS
OF LAST WEEK. IF YOU HAVING
ISSUES WE KNOW THAT THEIR
ISSUES IN THE PAST WITH THE
CALL IN NUMBER PLEASE CALL. THE
COMMITTEE STAFF NUMBER NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO.
NINE NINE IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY.
PROBLEMS CALLING IN ALSO WE DO
HAVE THE EMAIL WHICH CLEARLY
SOME PEOPLE ALREADY HAVE BUT
ITS BUDGET SUB SIX. BUDGET S.
U. B. SIX AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV
THAT'S ALSO ON THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE IF YOU
JUST. GOOGLE CA ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
TRACK DOWN OUR WEBSITE. THE
FEEL FREE TO USE THAT EMAIL
SUBMIT ANY. COMMENTS SO WITH
THAT- WE GET ORDER START THE
HEARING. MEMBERS CAN MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS AGAIN WE ONLY
HAVE ONE PANEL TODAY BUT
THEY'RE HERE TO DISCUSS THE-
COVERT NINETEEN AND ALL THE
VARIOUS IMPACTS ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. AS FOR AS
WELL AS WHAT COULD COME WHAT
CAN COME OUT OF THE ECONOMY
WHAT CAN WE ANTICIPATE AND WHAT
SHOULD WE REALLY EXPECT AFTER
COVERT NINETEEN ALSO WAS A
MEMBER QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
CONCLUDED I'LL TAKE. THIS YEAH
SO WHERE THE PANEL THAT WOULD
HAVE MEMBER QUESTIONS AND THEN
WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT-
WITH THAT I DID HAVE A COUPLE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE
FROM OUR HEARING FROM LAST WEEK
IF FINANCE IS. AVAILABLE. I'M
SORRY. AFTER THAT ON THE- BY
IDA BUT ARE THEY ARE THEY ARE
AVAILABLE. OKAY SORRY SO JUST
JUST TO HAVE TO FALL QUESTIONS
AGAIN- WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
WE HAVE WE HAVE QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE NUMBER OF TASKS
THAT- WE NEEDED TO FOR THE
STATE TO CONSIDER RE OPENING.
THANK GOVERNOR. THE NUMBER OF
TESTS BEING SIXTY THOUSAND TO
EIGHTY THOUSAND TESTS A DAY
WHICH IS. A GOOD NUMBER I KNOW
WE'RE ON TARGET TO HIT THE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND TEST BY
MAY FIRST. DO WE HAVE A SENSE
ON WHEN WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO HIT
THE SIXTY THOUSAND TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND TESTS TODAY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS MARK A MAGE
WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THANKS FOR
HAVING US BACK AGAIN- AS- YOU
NOTED. I SECRETARY GALLEY AND-
THE GOVERNOR- LATE LAST WEEK
SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC THAT OUR
OUR INTENT IS TO GET TO SIXTY
TO EIGHTY. THOUSAND PLUS WE ARE
NOW WORKING ON. AND THE
GERMINATION AROUND POTENTIAL
TIME LINE AS TO WHEN WE HOPE TO
DO THAT- AS YOU ALLUDED
EARLIER- WE DO INTEND TO HIT
THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MARK
BY THE END OF THE MONTH. I AND
WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO GET TO
SIXTY TO EIGHTY THOUSAND
WITHIN- THE EXISTING SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE JUST WANTING
TO MAKE SURE THAT- THE LIMITING
FACTOR IS AROUND- SWABS ENVIRO
MEDIA AND FREE AGENTS- ARE-
DON'T HINDER US FROM GETTING TO
SIXTY TO EIGHTY SO THAT. WE'RE
TRYING TO GET I'VE GOT A BETTER
SENSE FROM THE SUPPLY CHAIN. AS
TO WHEN- WE MIGHT. BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE THINGS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A- TENTATIVE
DATE AROUND- WHEN WE MIGHT BE
ABLE. TO EXTRACT THAT SIXTY TO
EIGHTY. OKAY SO SECURE WE'VE
BEEN IS PAID AND OUNCE BUT HOW.
SO RATHER THAN. I'LL BE A PART
OF OUR OUR AS WE LOOK TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES WITHIN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN WE CERTAINLY
WILL KEEP THE PUBLIC AND YOU
ARE PRIZED AROUND AND AWAY AND
OUR TARGET GOAL IS TO HAVE AT
IT EIGHT THOUSAND OKAY GREAT.
AND THEN- A PRE APPRECIATE YOU
FORDING THE LINK ON THE MODEL-
I NOTICED THE LINK THAT YOU
FORWARDED WAS PRIMARILY- CODE I
GUESS- I GUESS MAYBE THEY'RE
UNDER THERE PLENTY OF. A TECH
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW TO USE THAT
CODE IS THERE SOME- FORMAT OF
THE MODEL THAT'S MORE- UT I
WOULD SAY USER FRIENDLY. YEAH
SO WE'RE TALKING TO HOPKINS
TENDER STAND IF THEY INTEND TO
MAKE SOMETHING MORE USER
FRIENDLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT-
DAISY- HAVE MADE ALL OF THE
UNDERLYING PIECES OF THE- OF
THE MODEL PUBLIC AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WERE REFERRING TO AT AT
THE LAST HEARING. I WILL GET
BACK TO YOU IF THEY DO INTEND
TO DO THAT- BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY OWN- AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM- SO WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. IN SHORT
ORDER OKAY GREAT THANK YOU THE
ENGINE JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON OUR
A GL BC LETTER REGARDING THE
WEBSITE AND- I THINK THAT THE
LETTER WAS FAIRLY SPECIFIC BUT
JUST ABOVE THE- LEVEL WAS. A
WEBSITE THAT WOULD TRACK SUPPLY
DEMAND TO PEE PEE ACROSS THE
STATE. ALSO HAVE EACH MAJOR
TYPE OF EQUIPMENT AND
DESTINATIONS OF EACH ARE GOING
SIP SHIPMENT CATEGORIZED BY
CITY COUNTY. CATEGORY OF USERS
INCLUDING HEALTH FACILITIES
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS AS WELL
AS THE PERCENT OF ORDER FILLED.
BY COUNTY OR HEALTH CARE
JURISDICTION THE PRIORITY ORDER
FOR DISTRIBUTION WITHIN ITS
JURISDICTION- CAN I GET A SENSE
OF WHEN THAT WEBSITE. IS GOING
TO GO LIVE. YEAH HI GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN TINA CURRY. THE
SERVICES WE ARE WORKING ON THAT
RIGHT NOW WE EXPECT THAT TO BE
LIVE TODAY- HOPEFULLY ANYTIME
AND WE'LL BE SURE TO SHARED
ONLY WHEN IT. THAT'S GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I
HAD. MR OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE FOR
THIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE HEARING- I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO BE VERY POIGNANT
FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA BE EXAMINING NOT ONLY THE
IMPACTS ON THE CLIFORNIA STATE
ECONOMY OF THIS TERRIBLE CRISIS
BUT ALSO THE IMPACTS ON OUR
STATE REVENUES AND OUR STATE
BUDGET FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR- AND I DON'T EXPECT THE
NEWS WILL BE GOOD BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT. WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS BY IMPOSING A
STATE OR MORTAR THAT THEY MUST
MAKE DO WITH LESS AND SO MUST
WE THIS NEXT BUDGET YEAR IS
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THE NUMBER
ONE THING THAT I AM HOPING TO
TAKE AWAY FROM TODAY IS A SENSE
OF WHERE WE ARE WITH RESPECT TO
OUR STATE BUDGETARY RESERVES
THROUGH AND NO SMALL PART THE
DILIGENCE OF THIS COMMITTEE
WE'VE SUCCEEDED IN. SOCKING
AWAY NEARLY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS OF BUDGET RESERVES AND
MY QUESTION IS GOING TO BE HOW
MUCH OF THOSE RESERVES ARE
GOING TO NEED THIS YEAR HOW
QUICKLY IS OUR STATE ECONOMY
GOING TO REBOUND AND HOW MUCH
OF THOSE STATE RESERVES ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO SAY FOR FUTURE
YEARS- IN THE EVENT THAT THIS
LEADS TO A DEPRESSION SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THE
HEARING MISTER CHARLIE OF MY
TIME. THAT WAS FORCED BY STIR
MISTER DOCTOR REGULAR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I JUST
NEED TO MAKE SURE MY WIFE'S
SIDE WERE MASKED TODAY AND- I
THINK SHE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
MANY OF US WERE TAKING
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS. BUT I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR CONVENING SUB SIX AS
WE WILL DISCUSS CRITICAL
SUBJECTS DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. I'LL GET
RIGHT TO THE HEART OF THE TOPIC
IF I CAN WHICH IS RECOVERY AND
REBUILDING. AS THE CHAIR OF SUB
ONE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
FEEL THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ADVOCATING FOR A STRONG HEALTH
CARE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND OUR CORE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. ALL OF WHICH ARE
RESPONDING RIGHT NOW DURING OUR
CO THAT NINETEEN DISEASE CRISIS
AND OUR SEVERE UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ECONOMIC RECESSION CRISES THAT
ARE AFFECTING SO MANY
CALIFORNIAN FAMILIES. OBSERVING
AND APPROPRIATELY FORTIFYING OR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IS AN
ABSOLUTE IMPERATIVE IN OUR
OVERALL STATE RESPONSE AND OUR
CORE SAFETY NETS THAT WE
DEVELOP. IF WE TAKE STEPS BACK
IN HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WE
ARE DEEPENING AND WIDENING THE
SUFFERING. FOR OUR FAMILIES
THAT WE ARE FACING RIGHT NOW.
I'D LIKE TO MENTION A FEW AREAS
OF I CAN MISTER CHAIR THAT WE
MAY TAKE BUDGET ACTIONS
ULTIMATELY TO SERVE THE PURPOSE
OF A FAMILY FIRST RESPONSE
RIGHT NOW. FIRST WE ARE
LEARNING LESSONS THROUGH THIS
CRISIS ABOUT HOW TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES ON A VERY BASIC
LEVEL ABOUT VERY BASIC NEEDS. I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER HOW WE FURTHER EXPAND
AND EXTEND FLEXIBILITY IS AN
OPEN UP ACCESS POINTS FOR
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME. SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO ASSIST CALIFORNIANS IN
MEETING BASIC DAILY NEEDS. THIS
COULD MEAN ADOPTING THE CONTENT
OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
DEPARTMENTAL GUIDANCE INTO
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH. WE STARTED THIS YEAR
WITH A VERY STRONG PUSH TO
COMBAT THE VERY DIFFICULT AND
PAINFUL PLIGHT OF HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WITHOUT
ACTIONS TO CONTINUE WHAT WE'VE
DONE AS A STATE OVER THE PAST
FEW WEEKS AND IMPROVE UPON THEM
WE MOVE IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND AGAINST A GENUINE FAMILY
FIRST RECOVERY EFFORT. WE WANT
TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED FED AND
SUPPORTED THROUGH THIS CRISIS
THIS IS OUR PRIORITY. SECOND MY
VIEW IS THAT SUPPORTING
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY ARE ONE
AND THE SAME. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
WE APPLY EMPLOYEES LOW WAGE
WORKERS WE STIMULATE OUR
ECONOMY WHEN WE ADD FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO BECOME
C. N. A.'S IN NURSING HOMES WE
REDUCE UNEMPLOYMENT WE
STIMULATE OUR ECONOMY AND WE
PROTECT PROTECT SENIORS ALL AT
THE SAME TIME. WHEN WE
PERMANENTLY INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
TELEHEALTH WE REBUILD OUR
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE WE MAKE
HEALTH CARE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
CALIFORNIANS AND WE STIMULATE
OUR ECONOMY. WHEN WE
PERMANENTLY EXPAND HEALTHCARE
ACCESS FOR OLDER ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE PERMANENTLY IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OUTCOMES OF OUR
FAMILIES SO THEY DON'T FALL
DESTITUTE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TO SEE A DOCTOR.
AND WHEN WE EXPAND CAL E. I. T.
C. TO INCLUDE IMMIGRANTS TAX
FILERS WE HELP OUR ENTIRE WORK
FORCE. ALL THOSE WHO CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR ECONOMIES RECEIVE TAX
CREDITS. THAT THEY THEN PUT
RIGHT BACK INTO OUR CON. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SAFETY NET
ESPECIALLY NOW OUR INVESTMENTS
IN OUR ECONOMY. LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING SO MANY LETTERS OF
CORRESPONDENCE RELATED TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES NEEDS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY EACH DAY.
AND I WANT THE PUBLIC TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE RECEIVING THOSE
LETTERS LISTENING TO YOUR
STORIES AND CONSIDERING ALL OF
YOUR PROPOSALS THAT YOUR
THOUGHTFULLY PUTTING BEFORE US.
THE UNDERPINNING OF ALL OF
THESE IS A FAMILY FIRST
APPROACH. WHICH I URGE US TO
MAKE CENTRALTO OUR RECOVERY
WORK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR REBEL ANYBODY
ELSE WANT TO MAKE A- OPENING
COMMENT. SO AGAIN I THINK OUR
OUR VICE CHAIR PUT IT VERY VERY
WELL THIS COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED ALL FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS USUALLY
WITH THE PROTECT PARTICULAR
DISASTER IT IMPACTS A VERY
SELECT NUMBER OF PEOPLE SO WE
HAD GET TO FOCUS- WE GET TO
DIRECT RESOURCES ITH EVERY
CALIFORNIA BEING IMPACTED BY
THIS TO DISASTER A BIGGER
PRESENTS A VERY VERY LARGE
CHALLENGE WE NOW HAVE OVER
TWENTY SIX AMERICANS TWENTY SIX
MILLION AMERICANS WHO APPLIED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT IN OVER THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT- WHILE
WE UNDERSTAND EVERYBODY IS
HURTING JUST THE STAFF OF.
COMMENTS AND EMAILS WE'VE
GOTTEN WE KNOW THAT THERE IS NO
SECTOR OF THE STATE THAT HAS
BEEN LEFT REALLY AREN'T TOUCHED
BY THIS PANDEMIC TODAY WE HAVE
A GREAT PANEL- WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO CAN GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT
THE FUTURE HOLDS- DURING KOBE
NINETEEN AS WELL AS AFTER A BIT
ALSO TALK FROM THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PERSPECTIVES ABOUT HOW THINGS
ARE GOING WHETHER IT'S A SMALL
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE WHETHER
IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL WORKER
PERSPECTIVE- WHETHER IT'S- YOU
KNOW JUST ONE PARTICULAR
BUSINESS. WE ALSO HAVE-
PRESENTATIONS FROM OUR LA- AS
WELL AS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET POLICY CENTER SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY. HAVE SOME.
POTENTIAL BUDGET CENTERED IDEAS
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE ON LIKE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THAT
WE CANNOT DEFICIT SPENT- WE
CANNOT BORROW- WE HAVE TO PASS
A BALANCED BUDGET ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH AND WE WILL PASS A
BUDGET- BALANCED BUDGET ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH. BUT THAT PRESENTS A
CHALLENGE IN LIMITS OUR ABILITY
TO DO ALL THE HELP THAT
EVERYONE IS ASKING US TO DO. SO
REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
MEMBERS FOR COMING UP
SACRAMENTO TODAY ND WE WILL
START WITH- PROFESSOR NICHOLS
BURKE WITH THE UCLA ANDERSON
FORECAST. PROFESSOR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
BE HERE THIS MORNING I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BEGIN WAS JUST TAKING
A FEW MINUTES TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW OF WHERE WE SEE THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY GOING AND
NOT JUST TODAY AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS THE RECESSION BUT-
ALSO AS WE MOVE INTO THE FUTURE
AND INTO THE RECOVERY. SO LET
ME. LET ME JUST BEGIN BY SAYING
FIRST OF ALL AS YOU ALL KNOW
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST HAND
DAMAGE IN HUMAN HISTORY A WE'VE
BEEN HAVING PANDEMICS KIND OF
ALL THROUGHOUT. IT IS THE
FIRST. ENDEMIC IN OUR LIFETIME.
AND IT IS THE FIRST ONE SINCE
WE HAVE BEGUN TO COLLECT A RICH
SET OF ECONOMIC DATA OR WHICH
WITH WHICH TO ANALYZE. AB
RECESSIONS. AND SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT THIS IS A
DIFFERENT RECESSION FROM ALL OF
THOSE THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN
THE POST WORLD WAR TWO ERA. ALL
OF THE OTHER RECESSIONS WERE
REDUCTION IN DEMAND BECAUSE-
OVER BUILDING OF A BUILDING OF
HOMES. HAVE COMPUTERS OF FENCE
THE MILITARY L. AND-
AUTOMOBILES AND SO ON. IN THIS
CASE THE REDUCTION IN DEMAND IN
OUR ECONOMY IS ONE THAT'S BEEN
MANDATED BY THE IN EXTREME
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN THAT
MAKES THE TRAJECTORY OF THIS
RECESSION A BIT DIFFERENT. IT
ALSO MEANS THAT ALL THE
FORECASTS THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT
THIS RECESSION AND RECOVERY I
BASED ON LESS DATA THAN
FORECAST THAT FOR EXAMPLE- WE
AND OTHERS PUT OUT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE DURING THAT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
DURING THAT PROCESS IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE USED
IN EACH AND EVERY FORECAST. SO
ARE IS EXPLICITLY ARE. THAT BUT
IN THE SUMMER IN THE EARLY PART
OF THE SUMMER WILL BE ON THE
BACK END OF THIS PANDEMIC CURB
WILL BEGIN. THE OPENING UP OF
THE ECONOMY WHICH WILL CONTINUE
THROUGH THE SUMMER. AND THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE DON'T HAVE
A RETURN OF THE PANDEMIC. OR WE
HAVE- WIDESPREAD VACCINATION
AGAINST THAT. SO THOSE MAYBE
HERO BECAUSE SOME SENSE BUT
THEY ARE ASSUMPTIONS THEY'RE
NOT A FORECAST. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE TOO
OPTIMISTIC OUR ECONOMIC
FORECAST IS TOO OPTIMISTIC SO
THAT'S SOMETHING TO KEEP OUR
EYES ON. SO WHAT DO WE SEE IS
HAPPENING IN IN THE ECONOMY NOW
WE LOOK AT THIS ON AN AGGREGATE
BASIS ON A QUARTERLY BASIS. N.
S. SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR
THE US IS A 10% DECLINE IN GDP
FROM PEAK TO TROUGH. NOW YOU'LL
HEAR NUMBERS ABOUT 3035%
DECLINE IN THE SECOND QUARTER
THOSE ARE ANNUALIZED RATES. BUT
THE ACTUAL DECLINE WILL BE
ABOUT 10% MAYBE A LITTLE
HIGHER. IMPORTANTLYTHE DECLINE
IN. EMPLOYMENT WILL BE LARGER
THAN THAT THE ALMOST TWELVE
PERCENT. IN THE REASON FOR THAT
IS THAT THIS RECESSION IS
SKEWED TOWARDS. THE SERVICE
SECTOR IN SKEWED TOWARDS LOWER
SKILLED LOWER WAGE THAT-COMMUNITIES. AND THAT MEANS
THAT EMPLOYMENT THE CLIENTS ARE
GOING TO BE GREATER THAN GDP
DECLINE IN FOR CALIFORNIA WE'RE
EXPECTING THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
TO GO UP TO ON A QUARTERLY
AVERAGE BASIS TO GO UP TO ABOUT
SIXTEEN ANDA HALF PERCENT NOW
CLEARLY IT'S HARD RIGHT NOW BUT
AS THE ECONOMY BEGINS TO OPEN
UP SOME OF THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY FURLOUGHED WILL BE
HIRED BACK. BUT IMPORTANTLY.
FIRMS IN RECESSIONS IN THIS IS
ONE PLACE WHERE WE CAN TAKE THE
DATA FROM THE PAST FIRMS IN
RECESSIONS TRY TO MAKE IT TO
THE OTHER SIDE TO WIN DEMAND
STARTS GROWING TO GET IN SOME
OF THEM DON'T MAKE IT IN SO OUR
EXPECTATION IS. THAT THE- AS
THE RESTRICTIONS ON FIRMS
OPENING ARTISTE N. FIRMS DO
OPEN AND HIGHER BACK FOR LET
HIM PLEASE. THE NUMBER THOSE
FIRMS AND NOT GOING TO MAKE IT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO INTO
BANKRUPTCY AND THEY'RE GONNA
LAY OFF THOSE EMPLOYEES. AND SO
WE SEE A FURTHER CONTRACTION
INTO THE THIRD QUARTER OF THIS
YEAR. AND IN THE- UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE WILL PEAK OF SIXTY ABOUT
SIXTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT. AT
THE END OF THE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR IN THE FOURTH QUARTER
BECAUSE UNEMPLOYMENT TYPICALLY
KEEPS GOING UP. EVEN AFTER
RECESSION IS OVER WITH. AND
THEN WE'LL BEGIN RECOVERY AND
THE RECOVERY. THAT WE THINK IS
GOING TO BE MORE RAPID AND- THE
IN THE LAST RECESSION JUST
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
WAY IN WHICH DEMAND HAS BEEN
RESTRICTED. BUT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE AN EXTRAORDINARILY RAPID
RECOVERY THERE TAKE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE RETURN
TO TWENTY NINETEEN EMPLOYMENT
LEVELS. SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
A AS SOMEONE DIFFICULT. TIME
ZEROING IN. ON WHAT SECTOR ARE
MOST. AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
RETAIL WHICH WE DO NOT EXPECT
TO FULLY RECOVER BECAUSE RETAIL
WAS CONTRACTING. EVEN IN THE
EXPANDING ECONOMY IN THIS BRICK
AND MORTAR RETAIL. A CITIZEN
ACCESS THE THEY'LL BE A AN
ACCESS NUMBER OF. THE OTHER
STAB WAS WAS THERE AND- RETAIL
WORKERS YOU'RE NOT GONNA FIND
REEMPLOYMENT IN THE SAME
INDUSTRY. LEISURE AND
HOSPITALITY WHICH INCLUDES
TOURISM AND TOURISM IS A SECTOR
THAT IS GOING TO BE HERE FOR
QUITE A WHILE- BUT OTHER
ASPECTS OF LEADER OF
HOSPITALITY WE EXPECT TO
RECOVER IN THE NEXT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. AND OF OR RATHER THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THAT THE BEGINS
THE BEGINNING A TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN OTHER SERVICES. WHICH
INCLUDES PERSONAL SERVICES THAT
SHOULD- AT RISK THE COVER QUITE
RAPIDLY IN AND FINALLY
CONSTRUCTION. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE EXPECT AND THEN WE GET
FROM THE DATA WHAT PASSED FOR
SESSIONS IS A SAVINGS RATES ARE
GOING UP. AND THAT MEANS THAT
CONSUMPTION IS GOING DOWN. THE
HOUSEHOLDS WOOD FRAME REBUILD
THEIR BALANCE SHEETS AND
THEY'LL TRY AND SAVE MORE
BECAUSE THEY ARE UNCERTAIN
ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BUSINESSES WILL DO THE SAME AND
NOT INVEST AS MUCH. IN IN THAT
LEADS TO A SLOWER RECOVERY. THE
SO IS THERE ANY GOOD NEWS IN
THIS WELL. SOME SORT OF. THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT THIS WILL BE
A MORE RAPID RECOVERY THAT WE
SAW IN THE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT- 200-082-0009 RECESSION.
THE FIRST AND SECOND THE
RECOVERY IS GOING TO. BE SKEWED
TOWARDS TECHNOLOGY AND- YOU
KNOW AS THE WORLD RETREAT FROM
GLOBALIZATION AS SUPPLY CHAINS
ARE BROUGHT BACK INTO THE US
THAT'S GOING TO DEMAND.
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS THE
MORE REMOTE WORKING DEMANDS
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS THESE
THAT THINGS A CALIFORNIA DOES
WELL. AND THESE TEND TO BE HIGH
WAGE SECTORS THEY ALSO TEND TO
BE SECTORS THAT.
DISPROPORTIONATELY CONTRIBUTE
TO STATE REVENUES SO THAT MEANS
THAT. IN THE RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA IN THOSE SECTORS IS
WELL POSITIONED BUT IT IS NOT
WELL POSITIONED IN RETAIL
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY AND
LOGISTICS IN SO OUR WORRIES
JUST TO CONCLUDE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT YOU ALL WANT TO GET
THE QUESTIONS IN THE OTHER
PANELISTS. ARE EVER TURN OF THE
PANDEMIC IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SOMETHING A YOU KNOW FOLLOWING
A KNOCK ON IN THE FINANCIAL
SECTOR BECAUSE IS A LOT OF.
LIQUIDITY CHASING YIELD RIGHT
NOW. AND THE WAY IN WHICH THE
WORLD ECONOMY DE COUPLES IN IN
PARTICULAR HOW THAT AFFECTS OUR
PORTS IN THE JOYSTICKS. SO LET
ME STOP THERE AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
<c.red>ERE THE- THANK YOU PROFESSOR</c>
NEXT WE HAVE- RODNEY PHONE TO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. RODNEY. THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TODAY ALL MY
NAME'S RODNEY FONG CEO OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OR 80% OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES. AND I
WANT TO TRY TO SPEND MY TIME
HERE NOT TELLING YOU ABOUT THE-
DIFFICULTIES LOW'S ON THE
GROUND THE GIVE YOU POSSIBLY
SOME SOLUTIONS ARE SOME IDEAS.
ON WHAT WE CAN WORK FROM. HOME
CLEARLY THIS IS A DIFFICULT
TIME ALL EVERYONE I TRY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
NEW SOLUTIONS. IT'S NEVER BEEN
MORE CURRENT NOW I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA TO SHOWING THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES THE BACKBONE
CALIFORNIA. REALLY SEEING I
THINK A DEMONSTRATION OF HOW
FRAGILE BUSINESSES ARE SMALL
MEDIUM AND LARGE. SEE HOW
QUICKLY THEY THEY COLLAPSE
QUITE FRANKLY. I'M GOING TO
MENTION SOMETHING THAT PROBABLY
DOESN'T FALL INTO THE ECONOMIC
PEACE BUT AT THE CHAMBER WE
REALLY FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT. AND
THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE AND THE
SPEED IN WHICH OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS
REGAINING THE CONFIDENCE TO.
RECAP IS BACK UP. 32% OF OUR
WORKFORCE OUR PARENTS. AND OUR
WORKING PARENTS. JACKSON HEARD
AND THAT WE GET OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS BACK ONLINE. BECAUSE
CONFIDENCE IN THE PARENTS TO
CERTAIN KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL.
AND IT GOES PARENTS CAN FEEL
COMFORTABLE GETTING BACK TO
WORK. AS YOU ARE SPEAKERS SPOKE
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
REMOTE WORKING BECOME A HUGE
PLAY. IN A CALIFORNIA'S GROWTH
THROUGH TECHNOLOGY BUT THAT
OTHER SOURCES. DON'T BE
SURPRISED IF YOU SEE PEOPLE
WORKING FROM HOME TWO THREE
DAYS A WEEK. GOING INTO AN
OFFICE FOR IN PERSON MEETINGS
ABOUT A TWO THREE DAYS A WEEK.
THAT SHEDS IMPORTANCE ON THE
OTHER PIECE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS INCREASED BROADBAND
SERVICE. IN INTERNET SERVICE
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA. AN
EQUITABLE LEVEL. SECOND YOU SO
TO MENTION IS. SORT OF THE BALL.
TO YOU KNOW THERE'S GONNA BE A
NEED FOR SPEED TO GET. THE
SPEED OF BUSINESS ISTO GET
BACK OPEN WHEN IT'S SAFE AND WE
GET THE ALL CLEAR TO DO THAT.
I'M WAITING FOR THE STATE TO
COME UP WITH LAWS AND
REGULATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
INTERACT IN BUSINESSESHOW WE
INTERACT IN RESTAURANTS. MAYBE
TO SLOW ON HONESTLY. I THINK WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT A LONG
WINTER HERE- CERTIFIED HEALTHY
PLACE. STANDARD OR BUSINESSES
CAN TAKE THEIR BEST PRACTICE
INSURE THEM. ONE TWO YEAR
POTENTIALLY AGREE TO SOME NEW
STANDARDIZATION. ONE IN
PARTICULAR BRICK AND MORTAR
BUSINESS SEEMS LIKE RESTAURANTS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY SURVIVE WITH SPREADING
OUT. AND HAVING FEWER SEATS. IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
RESTAURANTS EVEN WITH A FULL
HOUSE TO BREAK EVEN. YOU NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY REINVENT
GENERATED THAT. ADAPT.
THEMSELVES YES IT IS. ABOUT
ADDING TO. AS MEMORIES REST ARE
GONNA HAVE DO SO OTHER SIT IN
RESTAURANTS OUT ALL IS GOOD TO
BE A BIG. TRAPS HAVING REACHED
INSIDE RUSTON AND SO ESSENTIAL.
I'M GOOD JUST GO TO BE CRITICS.
WE NEED TO ADAPT SMALL. ME
BEGIN I NEED TO BEGIN THINKING
ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY LEAD
INTO TO A SINGLE STORE. WILL WE
BE APPOINTMENT ONLY FOR A
BOUTIQUE BUSINESS. BENEFACTORS
WANT TO EXAMINE HOW THEY SHIFT
THEIR SCHEDULES MAYBE BECOMING
TWENTY FOUR OUR WORKSTATIONS
STARTING OUT GETTING A LONGER
SHIPS SHORTER SHIPS. NOT QUITE
SURE WHAT TO BE ABLE TO. CREATE
TOGETHER IN THAT IT OPENED A
BARN. AND IT IS JUST IMPORTANT
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
IN CALIFORNIA TO DO THEIR BEST
TO GET THEIR GUIDELINES WE GET
RESOURCE IN CERTAIN GET BACK IN
BUSINESS EVEN STARTING NOW
BEGINNING TO THINK ABOUT AND
LETTING OUR ENTREPRENEURS
REALLY BEGIN TO THINK BOUT HOW
WHEN THEY GET THE GREEN LIGHT.
ARE THEY GOING TO CHANGE AND
THAT THEIR BUSINESS IS FURTHER
AHEAD WE CAN GET BY THOSE
RESOURCES FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDARD VOLUNTARY OR BY LAW.
IT WOULD BE GREAT SO I KNOW WE
CAN DO IT ON THE LAST THING I
WANT A CURRENT OR ZONE IS TO
TRACK THE TECHNOLOGY OF.
CONTACT TRACING TECHNO. WE SEE
IN OTHER CITIES AROUND THE
WORLD WHERE MAYBE THEY'RE A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF US. THEY'RE
USING THEIR PHONES TRACK WITH
AROUND AND IT'S COMPLETELY
PRIVATE. THEY THEY'RE THEY'RE
FINDING OUT ON THEIR EXPOSURE
RATE. AND A LOT OF THAT DEPENDS
ON THE VOLUNTEER EFFORTS OF
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES TO
SHARE THAT. SO AND THAT IS THE
END OF MY CONCEPT IS TO GROW TO
QUESTIONS OR YOU CAN EMAIL ME.
AT OUR PHONE AS EXCERPTED
RAKAN. I KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IS A GREAT POSITION.
I OPPORTUNITY REESE. AND AGAIN
FOCUS ON PUBLIC SCHOOLS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THAT WILL HELP OUR
SMALL BUSINESS GET BACK ONLINE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU RODNEY. NEXT WE'RE HONORED
TO HAVE A DAVID- ILHAM FROM
HILMAR CHEESE COMPANY. YES GOOD
MORNING HAND GERMAN CHANGE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE- THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
DAVID ALL AMONG THE CEO HILMAR
CHEESE COMPANY. LOCATED IN HELL
MARK CALIFORNIA. BUT SHE'S
COMPANY WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY TWELVE FORMER
FAMILIES AND CONTINUES TO BE
HELD BY THE SAME GEHRY FARMERS
TODAY. WE PRODUCE NATURAL
AMERICAN CHEESE. STYLE SUCH AS
CHEDDAR MONTEREY JACK COLBY FOR
RETAIL AND FOOD SERVICE
CUSTOMERS AND OUR HALLMARK
GREETING ITS DIVISION
MANUFACTURES. OUT WAY PROTEIN
AND LACTOSE FOR USE AN INFANT
FORMULA PROTEIN BARS AND
BEVERAGES. TO MANUFACTURING
SITES ONE IN A MORE CALIFORNIA
SECOND IN DALHART TEXAS. OUR
PRODUCTS ARE SOLD BOTH
DOMESTICALLY AND AROUND THE
GLOBE WE ARE SUPPLIED BY. ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED INDEPENDENT DAIRY
FARM FAMILIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WAS ASKED TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT OUR
EXPERIENCE IN OPERATING IN THIS
CHALLENGING TIME. TODAY IN THIS
PROGRAM NINETEEN ENVIRONMENT WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND A LOT
OF EFFORT ENSURING WE CAN
EXECUTE OUR BUSINESS IN A SAFE
WAY OUR ACTIVITY IS CENTERED.
AROUND KEEPING PEOPLE HEALTHY
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME CARRYING
OUT OUR SPECIAL RESPONSIBILITY
OF PRODUCING FOOD TO FEED
CALIFORNIANS AND THE WORLD. WE
MUST CONTINUE THIS CRITICAL
WORK AGRICULTURE AND FOOD
PRODUCTION IS THE BACKBONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY THIS
CRISIS REMINDS US ALL THAT WHAT
WE DO IN AGRICULTURE IS
ESSENTIAL. EMPTY SHELVES AT THE
GROCERY STORE HAVE PUNCTUATED
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE FOOD
SUPPLY AND A GREAT ASSET IT IS
TO CALIFORNIA. WE ARE PART OF
AN EXTENSIVE SO I CHAINED
INVOLVING GEHRY FARMERS
PROCESSORS ACTED CHEN
CONVERTERS RETAILERS AND FOOD
SERVICE OPERATORS THIS TERRY SO
I CHIANG AND CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DIRECT AND INDIRECT
JOBS. EACH OF THESE
STAKEHOLDERS HAS BEEN IMPACTED
DIFFERENT WAYS JERRY FARMERS
AND OUR OWNERS HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD AS THEY SEE THEIR INCOME
FALL WELL BELOW THE COST OF
PRODUCTION. OUR RETAIL
CUSTOMERS BUSINESSES UP OVERALL
ARE RIDDLED WITH VOLATILITY AND
THE CHALLENGES OF OPERATING IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT. FOOD SERVICE
DEMAND HAS FALLEN OFF A CLIFF
AND THE VALUE OF THE CHEESE WE
SELL HAS DROPPED OVER 40% IN
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. IN THE
END EVERY LINK IN THE CHAIN
WILL SUFFER. WE EXPECT THE
RECOVERYTO BE SLOW AND
ELONGATED AS THE AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE SHELTER IN PLACE
TO LAST WELL INTO THE FUTURE.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE WHAT
ARE THE PRIORITIES I THINK
THERE ARE TWO KEYS TO MOVING
FORWARD IS. RESTORING
CONFIDENCE AND SUPPORTING
ECONOMIC GROWTH. FIRST WE MUST
RESTORE CONFIDENCE. WE ALL WANT
TO RETURN TO WHAT WE DID BEFORE
WE NEED TO FIND NEW AND SEE
SAFE WAYS TO DO SO. THE MORE WE
CAN AGGRESSIVELY SUPPORT ANSWER
ABOUT INCENTIVIZE AND ADOPT NEW
SAFE WAYS THAT ALLOW US TO EAT
OUT SHOP GO TO SCHOOL AND GO TO
THE MOVIES AGAIN. THE QUICKER
WE GET BACK ON TRACK. THIS
ACTIVITY DRIVES DEMAND AND
DEMAND GETS PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. SECOND SUPPORT AND DO NOT
HINDER ECONOMIC GROWTH IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO NOT
INHIBIT THE RECOVERY. WE MUST
USE OUR ABILITIES TO STIMULATE
SO I SEE IT OUR ECONOMY IS LIKE
A FLEET OF SHIPS. SOME SHIPS
HAVE CERTAINLY S
THE BOTTOM OF THE SEA RIGHT
NOW AND THE REMAINING ARE
PARTIALLY SUBMERGED NOW'S NOT
THE TIME TO THROW ON MORE WAIT
TIME TO SURVIVING SHIPS. IT'S
TIME TO REDUCE WEIGHT AND
INCREASED BUOYANCY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF EVERYONE. AT HELL
MARCHES COMPANY ARE RALLYING
CRY THE PAST FEW MONTHS HAS
BEEN TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS.
I ENCOURAGE STATE TO TAKE UP
THE SAME CHALLENGE FIND A WAY%
TO DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME
SAVING LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH EQUAL
ENTHUSIASM. WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND WE ALL WANT TO
LOOK BACK IN THE FUTURE ON
THESE TOUGH TIMES. THESE TOUGH
DAYS WITH PRIDE IN KNOWLEDGE
THAT WE DID OUR BEST THANKS
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY I TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OUR DAIRY
PRODUCERS. WILL ALL DONE AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB OF CARRYING
OUT THEIR SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO REDUCE FOOD
FOR THE WORLD. DURING A TIME OF
GREAT UNCERTAINTY WITHOUT THEIR
INGENUITY DEDICATION AND HARD
WORK OUR SHIP COULD NOT FLOAT
AND WE COULD NOT KEEP PEOPLE
FED AT THIS TIME. THANKS AND-
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER SHADE SO
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO-
SARRUD CHINA RAHMAN WITH ONE
FAIR WAGE. HEY AT THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS SERGEANT
I'M AND I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UC BERKELEY COLEMAN SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC POLICY AND I LEAD A
NATIONAL EFFORT OF SERVICE
RECORDS CALLED WHEN YOUR WAGE.
I'M AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THAT MILLIONS OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN LAID OFF
OR ARE FACING EVER USED HOURS
OR DIFFICULT SITUATIONS RIGHT
NOW OF COURSE MY EXPERTISE IS
LARGELY IN THE SERVICE SECTOR
BUT I'D WANNA LEFT UP THAT IT
IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS.
ACROSS THE BOARD SO OF THE
MILLIONS OF WORKERS THAT HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE MILLION RESTAURANT WORKERS
IN PARTICULAR HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS AND MANY ARE TELLING US
THAT THEY ARE HAVING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY ACCESSING BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE OF COURSE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO MAKE
UP A VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE. OF
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA I'M THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN AND WHILE IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DOING MORE THAN OTHER STATES
RUN DOCUMENTED WORKERS IT
CERTAINLY IS NOT ENOUGH FOR
PEOPLE FACING A RENT- ISSUES OF
ADDICTION- AND JUST BASICALLY
TRYING TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES.
I'M THIS ALSO IS A PROBLEM FOR
CALIFORNIA WHEN LOW WAGE
WORKERS I. DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
INCOME DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE A CREASE COSTS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
CREATES A LACK OF CONSUMPTION
EVEN AS WE RE OPEN. I IT WILL
BE A SLOW RECOVERY FOR THE
SERVICE SECTOR- AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS WILL FACE MANY DEATHS.
AND IT WILL BE A SERIOUS
SITUATION WHICH THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONSUME IN THE WAYS.
THAT THEY WERE BEFORE NOT TO
MENTION INCREASED HEALTH CARE
COSTS. THAT COME FROM A VERY
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THESE
WORKERS NOT HAVING ACCESS TO.
ANY KIND OF HEALTHCARE. WE ALSO
ECHO OTHER COMMENTS OF RODNEYAND OTHERS ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES SUFFERING IN THIS
MOMENT. PARTICULARLY IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY ALTHOUGH I
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR- THAT
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY MIGHT
COME BACK IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A MUCH
HARDER HIT. HARDER HIT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE RESTAURANT
SECTOR. AND OTHERS AND WAS
MEANT AS WAS MENTIONED MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES MAY NOT RE
OPEN AT ALL. I'M SO I HAVE FIVE
MAIN CLEAR KIND OF HIGHWAYS
THAT WE BELIEVE. ARE IMPORTANT
TO CONSIDER WITH REGARD TO LOW
WAGE WORKERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE I WOULD
AGREE THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. THE FIRST IS TO
SUPPORT THE HIGH ROAD TO
PROFITABILITY THERE HAVE BEEN
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO LIVABLE WAGES. AND
GREATER EQUITY FOR WORKERS
THEY'VE BEEN COMMITTING TO IT
THEY'VE BEEN COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING. THE ILLS THAT FACED
OUR INDUSTRIES THE SERVICE
SECTOR PRIOR TO RUN A VIRUS-
REAL RECHE RACIAL INEQUALITY
GENDER INEQUALITY. A LACK OF
ACCESS TO MORE ABILITY FOR
WORKERS OF COLOR TO THE HIGHEST
PAYING POSITIONS. IN THE
RESTAURANT AND SERVICE SECTORS.
I'M AND SO WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT HOW COULD YOU ENCOURAGE AND
SUPPORT HIGH ROAD. MODELS EVEN
POST CRISIS AND SO ONE EXAMPLE
OF THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CALLED HIGH
ROAD KITCHENS. IN WHICH WE HAVE
SECURED A COMBINATION OF PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE DOLLARS WAGE
SUBSIDIES AND PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY. TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO SMALL BUSINESS
RESTAURANTS THAT CONNECTS TO
EQUITY STANDARDS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE INCREASING EQUITY
FOR. A IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN INCREASING BACK OF
HOUSE FRONT OF HOUSE EQUITY IN
A RESTAURANT. PROVIDE THESE
DOLLARS TO RESTAURANTS TO
ACTUALLY READ. OUR WORKERS AND
REPURPOSE THEMSELVES COMMUNITY
KITCHENS. EATING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN NEED INCLUDING OTHER
ON IT WAIT SERVICE WORKERS. I
WE LAUNCH THE PROGRAM LAST WEEK
WE'RE GROWING IT TO ABOUT
THIRTY RESTAURANTS OVER THE
NEXT. WEEK OR SO AND CAN EXPAND
IT MUCH BROADER IT ALLOWS FOR
SELVES OF IT CREATES A MODEL OF
SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. BECAUSE WE CREATED
A SITUATION IN WHICH THESE
RESTAURANTS ARE ABLE TO GET A
COMBINATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE DOLLARS. TURN INTO A
COMMUNITY KITCHEN BUT ALSO.
ACCEPT HATE ORDERS SO THAT.
CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE TO SUBSIDIZE
REVEALS AYE AND ALLOWS FOR SOME
SELF SUFFICIENCY AFTER AN
INITIAL INVESTMENT ABOUT TWENTY
OR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
RESTAURANT THAT'S COMING FROM A
COMBINATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. RESOURCES SO THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE HAVE
CREATIVELY LOOK THAT PROMOTING
THE HIGH ROAD TO PROFITABILITY
IN A WAY THAT ALSO RE EMPLOYS
PEOPLE. A SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESS AND SAVES MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES- AND FEEDS LOTS OF
PEOPLE IN NEED. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ENCOURAGES GREATER
EQUITY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
I'M SO SUPPORTS WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS AT THE SAME TIME I
JUST WANT TO SAY ONE MORE WORD
OF THAT. PROGRAM WHICH IS THAT-
WE HAVE WE ARE ANNOUNCING TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT THEY CAN
AND- A DOCTOR RESTAURANT SAVE
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANT
BY ENROLLING THEM IN THIS
PROGRAM ALLOWING THEM ACCESS TO
THE COMBINATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE DOLLARS. I'M THAT ALLOW
THEIR RESTAURANT TO BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT OVER TIME. WE'RE
ALSO TALKING TO EMERGENCY
MANAGERS IN VARIOUS COUNTIES
ABOUT MOVING PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS TO THESE RESTAURANTS.
OR MEALS SO THERE IS A WAY IN
WHICH WE CAN PUT TOGETHER
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO THE HIGH ROAD TO
PROFITABILITY THAT'S ONE. THE
SECOND IS THAT WE'RE SEEING A
LOT OF POTENTIAL IN THE IDEA OF
COOPERATIVE DEVELOPMENT BOTH
WORKER AND CONSUMER
COOPERATIVES. WHERE THE FUTURE
WE'VE GOT MILLIONS OF LAID OFF
WORKERS WITH LOTS OF SKILLS I
WOULD AGREE THAT THERE LOW WAGE
BUT NOT THAT THEY'RE LOW LOS.
THESE ARE HIGH SKILL WORKERS
WITH LOW WAGES THAT HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF. THEY CAN COME
TOGETHER IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF COOPERATIVES HEARING
COOPERATIVES CARE COOPERATIVES
DOMESTIC WORK COOPERATIVES.
THAT ALLOW FOR WORKERS TO COME
TOGETHER AND PROVIDE SERVICES
AS WE BEGIN TO REOPEN. BECAUSE
NOT ALL BUSINESSES WILL COME
BACK NOT ALL WORKERS WILL GET
THEIR JOBS BACK. BUT THE
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THESE
WORKERS AND COMING TOGETHER AND
ACTUALLY STARTING THEIR OWN
SERVICES AND BUSINESSES. DOES
EXIST THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE THAT CAN SUPPORT THESE
WORKERS- IN PROVIDING IN
SETTING UP THESE COOPERATIVES
WE COULD ALSO LOOK AT.
BUSINESSES THAT CHOOSE NOT TO
REOPEN SELLING THEIR BUSINESSES
TO THEIR WORKERS. I'M THERE'S
PLENTY OF CONVERSION THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST
COOPERATIVE CONVERSION AND
COULD CONTINUE TO HAPPEN THAT'S
NUMBER TWO. NUMBER THREE ARE
THROUGH THE WORK WITH THE HIGH
ROAD KITCHENS WE LOOKED AT
WHICH WHICH HELPS YOU DOLLARS
AND WORK SHARE MODELS AND- SOME
OF THESE DOLLARS ARE LIMITED TO
EMPLOYERS THAT. ARE ARE STILL
OPEN AND ARE GREEN TO KEEP
THEIR WORKERS WELL THERE'S
PLENTY OF BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
ALREADY LAID OFF THEIR WORKERS.
AND WE LOVE TO SEE WORK SHARE.
ANOTHER WAGE SUBSIDY PROGRAMS
EXPANDED BEYOND BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE ALREADY LAID EVERYBODY
THAT OF OUR THAT STILL HAVE
PEOPLE TO INCLUDE BUSINESSES
AND ALREADY LAID EVERYBODY OFF
SO THAT THEY CAN GET SOME
SUBSIDIES AND SUPPORT. TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK ON TO HIRE PEOPLE
BACK. TO MORE THINGS I'M- I
THINK THIS MOMENT HAS MADE IT
VERY CLEAR WHY UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE IS SO CRITICAL. IT'S
A BURDEN ON SMALL BUSINESS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO WORKERS AND IT'S A
TERRIFYING MOMENT RIGHT NOW FOR
LOTS OF WORKERS. THAT ARE
LOSING THEIR ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN TIED TO
THEIR LAWYER. UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE WOULD REDUCE THE
STATE'S COSTS IT WOULD REDUCE
THE STATE'S BURDEN OF LOTS OF
UNINSURED PEOPLE. TURNING TO
THE PUBLIC SYSTEM. AND NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE AND
FURTHERING THE CRISIS EVEN AS
WE COME OUT OF IT. IT WOULD
ALSO SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AND WE ALSO NEED TO BE
HEALTHY. IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS
THE UNIVERSE HEALTHCARE WOULD.
ALLOW THE STATE'S ECONOMY TO
ACTUALLY BE SAVE LOTS OF
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND LASTLY WE
DO KNOW THE STATE IS GOING TO
LOOK NEED TO LOOK AT INCREASED
REVENUE. I'M SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST IS A BALLOT
MEASURE THAT IS ON THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT. THAT WOULD BRING
REVENUE INTO THE STATE IT WOULD
SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
SERVICES. IT WOULD HAVE LARGE
COMPANIES THAT ARE BENEFITING
FROM THE CRISIS TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE. I'M AND IT WOULD
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS RODNEY
MENTION IS IMPORTANT THING KEEP
OUR SCHOOLS OPEN. SO THEY'RE
OURS ABOUT THEIR SCHOOLS
AFFECTING ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT ARE SLATED TO
BE CLOSED. NEXT MONTH. I WE
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
LOOK AT THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
HAVING AN EDUCATION. MANY
HEARING TOMORROW ON IT WOULD BE
A REALLY BIG MISTAKE TO CLOSE
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW WHEN WE KNOW
THAT MORE FISCAL DISTANCING FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE NECESSARY IN
THE FALL. WE NEED TO KEEP
SCHOOLS OPEN. I'M NOT AVOID
PERMANENT CLOSURES. AT THE
MOMENT. AND THEN LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO PROTECTIVE
MEASURES ONE. OR WORKERS AS FOR
BOTH ESSENTIAL WORKERS NOW AND
FOR WORKERS COMING BACK. WE
MUST HAVE PP WE MUST HAVE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WE MUST
HAVE EXPANDED PAID LEAVE. AND
WORKERS NEED A VOICE ON THE JOB
WITH REGARD TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY IF WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WORK PLACES ARE SAFE. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THA EVERY
WORKPLACE HAS A HEALTH AND
SAFETY COMMITTEE IN WHICH
WORKERS ARE ALL TO SEE. ABOUT
IS THAT IS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
AND THAT OUR BUSINESS REOPEN
WORKERS ARE SAFE AND THE AND
CONSUMERS ARE SAFE AS WELL. AND
LASTLY WITH REGARD TO PUBLIC
SECTOR JOBS. WE DID NOT
ACTUALLY RECOVER THE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC SECTOR JOBS FROM THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RECESSION WE'RE
STILL A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS JOB AS OUR
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND JOBS
BELOW PRE RECESSION LEVELS IF
YOU TAKE. APPELLATION GROWTH
INTO ACCOUNT. UP CUTTING PUBLIC
SERVICES DURING THIS RECESSION
WILL NEGATIVELY AFFECT THOSE
MOST IN NEED AND CREATE A DRAG
ON THE ECONOMY SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT CUTTING
PUBLIC IN POINT EMPLOYMENT. ON
THE CONTRARY WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN HIRE LOTS
OF WORKERS IN PUBLIC SECTOR
JOBS TO BE DOING CONTACT
TRACING. WE CAN LOOK AT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS. AND SO THESE ARE
SOME OF THE KEY IDEAS WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU LIKE
THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS TO SUPPORT
HIGH ROAD BUSINESSES. AND
WORKERS AT THE SAME TIME
SUPPORT COOPERATIVE DEVELOPMENT
RING REVENUE INTO THE STATE AND
SURE EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE SO THAT WE DON'T.
FURTHER BURDENS STATE HEALTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. NEXT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
MR PANIC SPEAK. OKAY HELLO
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO BE HERE TODAY.
I GET CREDIT QUICKLY OF ALICE I
WOULD- BEGIN JUST BY HAVE GOING
BACK- LOOK ON SOMETHING
PROFESSOR NICHOLS BURKE SAID
THAT CLEARLY IS THE ECONOMY HAS
ENTERED INTO A RECESSION. AND
IT APPEARS TO BE THE EARLY
SEVERE WANTED THAT. OUR OFFICE
IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING IT'S
THIS CALL ESTIMATES. WERE THEY
COMING BUDGET YEAR AND THE- THE
CURRENT ONE. AND WE DON'T HAVE
PRECISE ESTIMATES TO DISCUSS
TODAY BUT I THINK I CAN MAKE
THREE OBSERVATIONS WITH SOME
CONFIDENCE AT THIS POINT. THE
FIRST IS THAT THE STATE IS
PRETTY CLEARLY GONE FROM
ANTICIPATED- SURPLUS IN NOW
EIGHTEEN BUDGET PROBLEM BY
WHICH I MEAN. THE STATE'S
REVENUES ARE LIKELY TO BE
INSUFFICIENT TO COVER TO
EXISTING COMMITMENTS. THE
SECOND POINT IS THAT THE-
BUDGET PROBLEM AS IT USUALLY
DOES WHEN THERE'S A RECESSION
WILL LIKELY SPANNED MORE THAN
ONE BUDGET CYCLE. AND THEN
THIRD GIVEN THE DIS THE
SEVERITY OF THE DOWNTURN
THERE'S BEEN DESCRIBED. IT'S
LIKELY THAT THE BUDGET PROBLEM
ITSELF IN TOTAL WILL EXCEED THE
STATE'S ACCUMULATED BUDGET
RESEARCH. AND HAS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS. THIS STATE IS
CONSTRAINED BY ITS BALANCE BUT
REQUIREMENTS. THEREIS
GENERALLY MEANS THAT AN
INCREASE IN SPENDING IN ONE
AREA MUST BE OFFSET BY REDUCED
SPENDING IN ANOTHER AREA WHERE
BY BRINGING IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUES IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
TAXES. IS THE USUAL WAY.
NEVERTHELESS GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS THEY WERE FACING THERE'S
A REAL. AND PUTTING DOLLARS
INTO THE ECONOMY- ISSUING BONDS
FOR EXAMPLE IS SOMETIMES
THOUGHT OF THIS AS ONE OF THE
WAY TO DO THIS BY ACCELERATING
THE PLANNED BOND ISSUANCE
SCHEDULE AND- FINANCING CAPITAL
PROJECTS WITH THE BOND PROCEEDS.
THAT COULD BE BACK TO ONE IDEA
THAT IS SOMETIMES MENTIONED AS
A WAY TO BRING AND STIMULUS
HOWEVER I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
MUST KEEP IN MIND THAT DOING
THAT. BRINGS WITH IT HI YOUR
COSTS DOWN THE ROAD TO SERVICE
THE DEBT. IN ADDITION WHEN THE
NEED IS REALLY TO BRING FUNDS
INTO THE ECONOMY QUICKLY.
THERE'S A TIME PROBLEM BECAUSE
THE BOND. LANDING THE LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN A
RANGE YOU NEED IN THE FINANCING
X. TIME IT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE MOMENT
WE'RE IN. SO IN GENERAL THERE
ARE TWO WAYS THAT THE STATE CAN
SPEND MORE. THAN ITS CURRENT
REVENUE BASE WILL ALLOW WITHOUT
MAKING ACCENTING REDUCTIONS IN
OTHER AREAS WERE BY INCREASING
TAX REVENUE. AND THE FIRST IS
TO BORROW INTERNALLY BASICALLY
SPEND SOME OF THE BALLOTS IS
HELD IN THE STATE'S SPECIAL
FUNDS. AND THE OTHER IS JUST TO
SPEND DOWN IT'S MAKING RATED
BUDGET RESERVE. BUT WHEN YOU
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER I MEAN THE
STATE'S OPTIONS WERE PROVIDING
ECONOMIC STIMULUS ARE REALLY
VERY LIMITED DANCE COMPARED.
WHICH IS GOING TO HEAR
MENTIONED IN ABLE TO RUN LARGE
THAT. THE ECONOMY. NOW THERE'S
ONE EXCEPTION TO THIS AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT OUR OFFICE IS
WRITTEN ABOUT AND GIVEN TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IS INTERESTED
IN POLICY IDEAS AS WELL AS A
DISCUSSION OF THE BUDGET
SITUATION- MENTION ONE OF THEM
HERE TODAY MATT IS THAT THE
STATE COULD IF THE LEGISLATURE
WANTED THE STATE COULD BORROW
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WITHIN ITS- UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM. WHAT IS THE
BY WAY OF BRIEF BACKGROUND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
IS A SAFETY NET PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES A CASH BENEFIT YOU
WORKERS THAT LOSE THEIR JOBS
YOU TO NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
STATES GENERALLY HAVE PRETTY
BROAD DISCRETION FOR THE DESIGN
OF THE IT OF THERE BENEFITS
PROGRAMS. AND IN CALIFORNIA THE
MAXIMUM WEEKLY BENEFIT IS FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS AND
THE DURATION OF THE PROGRAM IS
A MAXIMUM OF TWENTY SIX WEEKS.
THE WAY THAT THESE BENEFITS ARE
PAID FOR THROUGH AN EMPLOYER OR
PAYROLL TAX ON THE FIRST SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF EMPLOYEE
WAGES. THE COLLECTIONS FROM
THESE TAXES ARE HOLDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND. THREE COMMONERS BEEN THE
CASE THAT IN RECESSIONS THESE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND WILL GO INTO INSOLVENCY.
NEVERTHELESS THE BENEFITS
CONTINUE TO BE PAID BECAUSE IN
THE IN AN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AUTOMATIC
STABILIZER PROGRAMS. FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EXTENDS LOANS SORT
OF EMERGENCY AN AUTOMATIC LOANS
TO THE STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BUT- NEITHER THE- THE
FUNDS THEY CAN THEN BE USED TO
CONTINUE TO PAY. THE BENEFITS
EVEN THOUGH THE FUND ITSELF IS
GONZALEZ. IN IT IT IS THIS
ARRANGEMENT PRECISELY THAT
WOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE
STATE TO INCREASE ITS ITS OWN
BENEFIT SCHEDULED FOR ME FIND
TEMPORARY BASIS. AND UTILIZE
BORROWED FUNDS BECAUSE- AN
INCREASE THE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE STATE INCREASES IN.
THE FUND IS LIKELY TO GO INTO
AND SOLVE IT THE DECISION GIVEN
THE SEVERITY OF THIS DOWNTURN.
WHAT DO WE THIS KIND OF IN MY
TO THE PRO OF COURSE WOULD QUIT
FIND FURTHER INTO INSOLVENCY.
BUT YOU KNOW AS I AM SAYING
THAT THE BENEFITS COULD STILL
BE PAID THROUGH THE- FEDERAL
LOAN. NOW THE STATE COULD
DESIGN THE INCREASES IN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS YOU
CAN HI U. FORMULA BASED ON
EMPLOYEES AND THE WAGES THAT
THE EMPLOYEE WAS EARNING BEFORE
THEY LOST THEIR JOB. WORKING
PROVIDING ACROSS THE BOARD
AMEN- INSTILL OR TO THE FEDERAL
CARES ACT RECENTLY THE FEDERAL
CARES ACT INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY BILLION IN FUNDING TO
PROVIDE A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
PER WEEK INCREASE TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WERE THE
ONLY PEOPLE THIS YEAR IS NO
ALSO EXTENDED THE PERIOD. OF
KNOWLEDGE ABILITY BY THIRTEEN
WEEKS. NOW THERE'S THE QUESTION
OF HOW TO REPAY THIS LOAN IN
THE NORMAL COURSE YEAH YOU KNOW
WHEN THE FUN GOES IN SOLVING.
THESE LOANS WHEN THEY'RE DRAWN
UPON GET REPAID BY FUTURE TAX
COLLECTIONS ON THE EMPLOYERS.
IN THE PAST- WHEN THE IT IT
THIS IS OCCURRED WHEN THE
ECONOMY IS STRENGTHENED AND
THEN USUALLY THE STATE GENERAL
FUND HAS PAID THE INTEREST COST
ON THOSE LONG. BUT GIVEN THE
EXACT IN ITS NATURE OF THIS
ECONOMIC SHOCK. AND THE BUT
BECAUSE OF THE DOWNTURN IS AS
PROFESSOR NICHOLS BURKE SAID
WE'RE SORT OF IN A PAN DOOM AND
DEREK INDUCED RECESSION.
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
RETAIN SEARCH LOANS STRAIGHT
FROM THE GENERAL FUND WITHOUT
SHIFTING THE BURDEN BACK TO THE
EMPLOYERS DOWN THE ROAD. OUR
OFFICE IS ALSO WRITTEN UP SOME
EXAMPLE OF THE OTHER IDEAS
STUDY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER. THESE WOULD
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE EXPANDING
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM TWO CATEGORIES OF
WORKERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
INELIGIBLE. FOR EXPANDING THE
STATE. PROGRAM YOU- WORKERS
THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. I'LL
SPEND LESSTIME ON THOSE IS
BECAUSE THOSE IDEAS WOULD NOT
BE. ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL
LOAN SUPPORT THAT I MENTIONED
IN THE REGIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM. AND AS SUCH
THEY WOULD REQUIRE THE USE OF
STATE RESOURCES WHICH BRINGS
BUT RANGERS BACK ABOUT A
REGIONAL TRADE OFF THAT I
MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING
BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S BALANCED
BUDGET REQUIRE. SO WITH THAT-
BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS WHEN
THE TIME COMES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS BURKE- NEXT WE HAVE
CHRIS HANEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET IN POLICY CENTER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN DAYS HEARING.
MY REMARKS TODAY WILL FOCUS ON
THE STATE'S OPTIONS FOR OUR
RESPONSE TO THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS OF THE CRISIS BUT
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THE WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY ISIS AND I WANT TO
START BY STRESSING. AS HAS BEEN
SAID HERE TODAY JUST HOW
DIFFERENT THIS RECESSION IS
ALREADY FROM THE FIRE EVEN IF
THERE WILL BE A TENDENCY TO
COMPARE IT IN TERMS OF SCALE IN
SIZE TO THE DEPTHS OF THE GREAT
RECESSION. WE HAVE AN
EXPERIENCED GOING FROM FALL
APPOINTMENT THE 15220%
UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS. ARE SO
QUICKLY IN THE LAST SIX WEEKS
AT LEAST NOT IN OUR
CONTEMPORARY HISTORY AND A
RECESSION SO FOCUSED ON CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND THE SERVICE
SECTOR IN PARTICULAR. AND THAT
MATTERS A LOT THE DECISIONS
THAT YOU MAKE IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD BECAUSE THE DEPTH
OF THE EFFECTS ARE REQUIRE A
TARGETED SAID OF PUBLIC SECTOR
RESPONSES. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE CRISIS ITS IMPACT
ON WORKERS AND FAMILIES AND TO
PROTECT IT AGAINST BECOMING A
LONGER TERM IN MORE SUSTAINED
DOWNTURN WITH LASTING IMPACTS
FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS AND OUR
ECONOMY. SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THAT
WE OUTLINED A SET A KEY
PRINCIPLES FOR HOW THE STATE
CAN RESPOND. OUT THE KEY ONE OF
THOSE WAS PROVIDING WELL
TARGETED REALLY AYE WRAPPING
AROUND THE FEDERAL FISCAL
RELIEF THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED. IN
THE SEVERAL PACKAGES THAT WERE
PASSED IN THE LAST. MONTH OR
SO. PRIORITIZING BEEN NEEDS-
FOR THOSE WHO ARE MOST
AFFECTED. AND HELPING
CALIFORNIANS WHO WON'T BE
REACHED BY EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND SUPPORTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
EXCLUDED VARIOUS REASONS. WE
RELEASED A SERIES OF REFER
PORTS EXAMINING WHO THE WORKERS
ARE THAT ARE MOST AFFECTED BY
THE ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS OF
THE CRISIS YOU CAN FIND THOSE
RESOURCES AT OUR WEBSITE AT CAL
BUDGET CENTER DOT ORG. THOSE
MOST AFFECTED INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THEY MAKE UP 6% OF
OUR STATE WORKFORCE IN SOME OF
THE INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS THAT
ARE MOST AFFECTED THEIR- AND
THE 30% OF THE WORKFORCE. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM RIGHT
WORKERS WHO LIVE IN AND HELP
SUPPORT MIXED. MIXED STATUS
HOUSEHOLDS THAT INCLUDE U. S.
CITIZENS THE CONTRIBUTORY
BILLION DOLLARS TO YOU- THE
STATE NEW TAXES AND NOT HOWEVER
THEY'RE LOCKED OUT OF MUCH OF
THE FEDERAL FISCALLY AND SOME
OF THE SAME SYSTEMS OF SUPPORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN. MENTIONED HERE
TODAY. AMONG THOSE MOST
AFFECTED ARE ALSO PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AMONG WORKERS AT HIGH
RISK OF LOSING THEIR JOBS OR
HOURS BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
WHERE THEY WORK IN A HIGHLY
AFFECTED IN THE THREE TWO ONE
THREE. ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR THEY
ALSO TEND TO BE WORKERS WHO
HAVE LESS EDUCATION RELATIVELY
SPEAKING AND WHO ARE PAID
LASSEN HAVE EITHER. YOU ARE JOB
PROTECTIONS. MANY OF THESE
FOLKS ACROSS THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
LEFT OUT OR WHO ARE. VERY
AFFECTED ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
THEY WORK ACROSS INDUSTRIES AND
SECTORS SECTORS THEY ARE
NEIGHBORS AND COWORKERS AND
MANY OF THEM ARE NOW FACING
EACH. ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO WHAT YOU
WALKING DO POTENTIALLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL. WITH A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU
FEEL AND- IN TERMS OF GAPS
AROUND FEDERALLY SO. I'LL START
WITH CASH ASSISTANCE ARE THE
FEDERAL REBATES AS EVERYONE.
COMMONLY REFERS TO THEM THEY
WERE AUTHORIZED MEDICARE'S ACT.
THEY NOTABLY EXCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS WITH
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS ARE AYE
TENDS. AND THEY REQUIRE THAT
EVERYONE IN THE HOUSEHOLD THAT
RECEIVES A REBATE HOW TO SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. IN OTHER WORDS
THE REBATE THE REBATES
THEMSELVES ARE NOT AVAILABLE
THE MOST. ECONOMIC STATUS
EMILY. AT THE GOVERNOR TO AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER A PROVIDED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SUPPLEMENTED BY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM PLAN TO BE A ONE
TIME CASH ASSISTANCE FOR THESE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THAT'S A REALLY GREAT FIRST
STEP- BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S
ALSO CLEAR THAT THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS OF CRISIS WILL
CONTINUE BEYOND THE IMMEDIATE
AREA. THERE'S GOING TO BE A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
I BOTH TAKE CASH ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. AT THAT- AT THE STATE
COULD PROVIDE AND THAT ALSO
OFFSET ACT THAT IS WORKERS ARE
UNDER- ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. ALSO
THE WAY THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IS IT CONSIDER
BUILDING ON TO THE CAL EITC ON
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT.
INCLUDE AYE TEN FILERS
INCREASING THE SIZE OF A CREDIT
FOR THOSE HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD.
OTHERWISE BE RECEIVING SMALL
AMOUNTS. IN THE HOW CARE THERE
WAYS TO HELP UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
HERE TODAY. I MEAN SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE WHICH IS PIVOTAL TO
ADDRESSING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC HAS ASPECTS OF THE
CRISIS. MOST UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS STILL LACK ON GOING
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
MISTAKE SHOULD CONTINUE TO TRY
TO MAKE PROGRESS ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE. FOR MEDICARE.
IN PAID LEAVE THE FEDERAL LEAVE
NOTABLY EXCLUDED EMPLOYERS WITH
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THAT'S FORTY FOUR
PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE OR ABOUT EIGHT
MILLION WORKERS. WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ADDRESSING THE GAP FOR FOOD
INDUSTRY WORKERS. AT THE
EXPIRED SPENDING WORK
PROTECTION FOR ELIGIBLE- ROAD
WORKERS FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT DEPENDING ON
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN FAVOR OF
EACH- FEDERAL RELIEF CALIFORNIA
MAY NEED TO CONSIDER LOOKING AT
OTHER OPTIONS PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PAID LEAVE AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. CARING FOR
CHILDREN OR ADULTS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO WORK. THERE'S ALSO A
GAP IN THE CHILD CHILD CARE IN
A CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERALLY SUPPORT CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE. I'VE BEEN GIVEN THE
MOST CHILD CARE PROVIDERS HAVE
BEEN FORCED A TEMPORARY
EXPEDIENT SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS. MANY ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ARE STRUGGLING TO MANAGE WORK
AND CHILDCARE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE
LARGE GAPS FIRED IN. THE STATE
FOR EXAMPLE COULD MAKE
AUTHORIZED FUNDS DIRECTED.
ALREADY AUTHORIZED FUNDS
THEY'RE PROVIDED FOR FACILITIES
AVAILABLE FOR IMPROVEMENTS- I'M
SORRY AVAILABLE TO HELP COVER
OPERATING COST FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. DURING THE
CRISIS IS JUST ONE WAY THE
STATE MIGHT RESPOND. OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE OUT
OF WORK WE KNOW THAT THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM COMES INTO PLAY
FORTUNATELY THE STATE INCREASED
THE GROUT LEVELS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. AMID THE LIKELY
INCREASES IN CASELOADS AND
CHALLENGES IT'S REVENUES MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE BENEFITS ARE
NOT. THAT SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
AND EXTENDING THE CAL WORKS I'M
LIMITS WOULD BE A GOOD POLICY
TO START PUTTING IN PLACE NOW
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
LIMITS ARE EXTENDED FOR PEOPLE.
LAST WORD. BOTTOM LINE EVEN
WITH HAVING TO BALANCE THE
STATE BUDGET AND RECOGNIZING
THE FISCAL REALITIES INTERFERE
IN THAT ARE COMING. WE SUBMIT
THAT YOU HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO
PROP UP THE ECONOMIC. SECURITY
OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WERE BOTH ACTIVE. RECOGNIZE YOU
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO EVERYTHING
YOU MIGHT. OTHERWISE WISH IT BE
ABLE TO DO. WE THINK ABOUT THIS
IS BASICALLY HAVING TWO SETS OF
OUR LEVEL SPONSOR. ONE FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY WILL BE HEALTHY UNTIL
WE'RE ASSURED. THE CRISIS IS
MITIGATED. AND ONE FOR THE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF THE
NINETEEN. EVERYTHING ELSE IS
PRETTY MUCH SECONDARY I
RECOGNIZE YOU HAVE SOME
CHALLENGING DECISIONS AHEAD OF
YOU BUT YOU SHOULD USE WHAT
RESOURCES AND SESSIONS YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- ECONOMIC CHALLENGE
THIS PRICES. OUR STATE HAS
SHOWN THAT IT CAN WHETHER
DOWNTURNS ANTI FISCALLY PRUDENT
BUILD RESERVES NEEDED TO
PREPARE FOR FUTURE NEEDS. ALSO
MAKERS IN CALIFORNIA CAN READ
THE STATE FOR IT AGAIN BY
ENSURING THAT THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES NO WORKERS HIT
HARDEST. AND THE ECONOMY
ECONOMY OVERALL DON'T PAY THE
PRICE FOR THIS CRISIS HERE'S
THE CON. THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMUTER MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS NEEDED AT THAT. TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY JUST
A BIG THANK YOU FOR ALL OUR OUR
PANELISTS- WANTED JUST CALL ON
MISTER- THESE WHEN HE CAN IF
YOU HAVE ANY. COMMENTS ON- ON
THE- PANEL OR HE JUST WANTS TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THAT COMMITTEE-
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
COMMENTS OF THE PANEL- WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON THE NAY
REVISION- WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS-
WILL BE. PROVIDED IN JUST OVER
TWO WEEKS AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
GO TO MISTER COOPER AND THEN
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
MILLER THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE AND JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS. FOR MISTER ALL HAM.
WHAT CHANGES HAVE YOU MADE YOUR
BUSINESS- STAFFING HAILING
PRODUCTS AND SHIPPING PRODUCTS.
GREAT GREAT QUESTION GOING BACK
REALLY A COUPLE MONTHS AGO MANY
CHANGES SO EVERYTHING KINDA
REVOLVES AROUND JUST I WOULD
SAY. HI GENE WHICH IS NOTHING
NEW TO US AS A FOOD COMPANY AND
THEN PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND
SEPARATION IT'S REQUIRING
SOCIAL DISTANCE SITTING WAITING
BARRIERS- MAKING ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR EMPLOYEES FOR ATTENDANCE WE
ALREADY HAVE GENEROUS LEAVE
POLICIES HERE SO THAT HELPED
FACILITATE THINGS ON THAT WE
PUT TEMPERATURE SCREENING IN
PLACE. WHAT MASKS AND P. B. E.
AND EVERYONE'S HANDS- THAT'S
YOUR WORK AND SO THAT'S A LOT
OF A LOT OF ACTIVITY AROUND
THAT INTO THANKS AND HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES DO YOU HAVE THERE
YOUR FACILITY THE FACILITIES I
JUST. JUST JUST SHY ABOUT
THOUSAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY YOU AYE WE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY WE'VE A LOT AG I KNOW AG
IS A FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AS FAR
AS GETTING YOUR FOLKS YOU KNOW
BACK TO WORK. HELP IS
REGULATION IMPACTED YOU.
RELATIONS FROM FROM THE STATE.
WE ALSO. IT IN TERMS OF THIS
COULD YOU MAYBE BE A JUST A LOT
MORE SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF THE
SITUATION- PREVIOUSLY OR HOW
HOW CAN WE MAKE IT EASIER TO DO
BUSINESS OBVIOUSLY WITH THAT TO
MAKE SURE EMPLOYEES CONTINUE
TO. REMAIN EMPLOYED. OKAY NO I
THINK I MEAN YOU'RE GONNA HIT
NINE ONE OF THE POINTS I HAD IN
TERMS OF. NOT ADD MORE WEIGHT
TO THE SHIPS- SO AT THIS POINT
IN TIME I JUST BELIEVE
JUMPSTART AND THE ECONOMY AND
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE AND NOT WAY
AND IT'S DOWN IN THE WAY IT IS.
IMPORTANT SO. NOW I AND WAIT ON
THE SHIPS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THING RIGHT NOW. AND FOR MISTER
NICHOLS BERG- HOW LONG WILL
SMALL BUSINESS BE ABLE SURVIVE
WITH A SHELTER IN PLACE. HOW
LONG WILL SMALL BUSINESS BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE WITH THE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE THAT'S AND
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION IN
ANY. RECESSION WE FIND THAT
BUSINESSES THAT WERE GOING INTO
THE RECESSION WITH THAT VERY
LOW MARGINS HAVE A HARD TIME
MAKING IT THROUGH. THE IN THIS
CASE IT DEPENDS ON. WELL REALLY
ON WHAT SECTOR THERE IN. AND
THAT HOW CONSUMERS COME BACK SO
FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE RETAIL
SECTOR THERE WILL BE MANY
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS- SMALL
AND MEDIUM AND EVEN LARGE
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS. THAT ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO. COME
BACK THEY WILL TRY TO OPEN UP
AND THEN THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
PAST SAYS THAT THEY WILL. END
UP IN BANKRUPTCY AND IN CLOSING
SO IN THE RETAIL SECTOR WE
EXPECT A PERMANENT SHRINKAGE.
IN LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY IT
DEPENDS ON WHETHER OR NOT THIS
FIRM IS SERVING. EARLY TOURISTS
OR PRIMARILY A LOCAL RESIDENTS
AND IN THE- ARENA OF TOURISM WE
EXPECT INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM
TO BE NEEDED FOR A VERY LONG
TIME WAY PAST THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO DOMESTIC TERRORISM
SHOULD START PICKING UP PEOPLE
ARE ANXIOUS TO GET OUT. NOT
THAT IT AGAIN THAT'S NOT A FULL
RECOVERY IN THE TOURIST SECTOR
SO THOSE ARE THE WEAKEST
SECTORS IN IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE SECTORS THAT
EMPLOYEE- REALLY AREN'T ON
AVERAGE LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THAN OTHER SECTORS
AND THAT'S WHY I WANT TO HIT ON
THAT IS THERE ANY MODELING THIS
BEEN DONE. REGARDING THAT. SO
THAT IN MODELING AS TO THE-
LONGEVITY OF SMALL BUSINESS IN
THESE SECTORS CORRECT. AND NOT
EXPLICIT MODELING BUT THE DATA
THAT WE OBSERVE ON THE
EMPLOYMENT AND UNEMPLOYMENT IN
THESE SECTORS FROM PAST
RECESSIONS ARE INDICATIVE OF
WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THIS. RECESSION AND RECOVERY
STILL IN THE THIRD AND FOURTH
QUARTER OF THIS YEAR WE EXPECT
BUSINESS FAILURES AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE RECESSION WHICH
WE I ANTICIPATE WILL AND-
SOMETIME IN THE THIRD QUARTER
AS WE KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES THE
BACKBONE OF ALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYS A LOT OF FOLKS- IN OUR
DISTRICTS. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
SMALL BUSINESS DO YOU FEEL WILL
NOT SURVIVE AND MAKE IT BACK.
OFFERED DIFFERING NUMBERS. AND
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU'VE HEARD ARE
SPECULATIVE. SO I'M GOING TO
HESITATE TO SPECULATE BUT- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY IN RETAIL AND
IN. THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
SERVING- TOURISM. AS THE NUMBER
MIKE QUITE HIGH. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WHAT. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND THANK YOU TO THE
PANELISTS THIS IS BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL- AND I'M GOING TO
PREFACE SYSTEM THERE WOULD BE
COM AT HER QUESTIONS- COMING
OUT OF THIS BUT I A ON SATURDAY
HAVE THE SECOND NOW CALL WITH
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS IN
MY DISTRICT I REPRESENT FIVE
COUNTIES. AND A COUPLE OF
THINGS IF HAVE COME UP ONE IS-
AND A MAYBE IT MAYBE- MARCO
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION THERE IS A DESIRE TO
START AS WE START LOOKING AT RE
OPENING- TO CHANGE THE WAY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUSINESSES
VERSES ESSENTIAL VERSES
NONESSENTIAL TO SAFE VERSES
MAYBE NOT SO SAFE- AND IS THE
IS THE ADMINISTRATION
ANTICIPATING ANY SORT OF A
CHANGE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. YOU
PROBABLY CONSIDER YOUR BUSINESS
ESSENTIAL IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
YOUR FAMILY IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
THE PEOPLE YOU EMPLOY AND- IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO YOUR COMMUNITY IN
MANY WAYS AND SO THAT WHILE WE
WERE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
THIS AND RAMPING UP- AND
LOOKING AT THE SURGE- THAT
TERMINOLOGY MAY HAVE BEEN MORE
APPROPRIATE BUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I HAVE TO FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT COULD BE OPERATING-
SAFELY. GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SO I THINK LIKE AN
ACCOUNTING FOR EXAMPLE MAY HAVE
A SMALL COUNTY FUHRMAN HAS ITS
OWN PRIVATE OFFICE REACH
EMPLOYEE OR AN ATTORNEY'S FIRM
THAT HAS THE SAME SORT OF- SAME
SORT OF- ARRANGEMENT OUT THERE.
SO IS THERE ANY ANTICIPATION OF
THE SORT OF A CHANGE IN THE WAY
WE LOOK AT BUSINESSES- AND SORT
OF THE JARGON THAT WERE USING
DESCRIBE WHETHER A BIT YOU KNOW
WHETHER BUSINESS COULD BE OPEN
OR NOT. WELL THANK YOU FOR.
THAT QUESTION THIS IS MARCO
WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. I HAVE I THINK
THAT- YOU'RE CORRECT IN THE
SENSE THAT YOU KNOW AND WE LOOK
AT THE SIX INDICATORS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS LAID OUT. WHAT WE
ARE REALLY TRYING TO FOCUS ON
IS FIGURE OUT WAYS IN WHICH
BUSINESS SAYS AMONGST VARIOUS
SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
SAFELY OPEN UP- BASED ON-
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE AND
ANYTHING TO YOUR PANELISTS
EARLIER UP POINTS FOR MAKING
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE. A CLEAR
CONCISE AND TIMELY GUIDANCE IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
AND SO WE ARE ENGAGING. WITH
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS FALLS IN RURAL AND
URBAN COUNTIES. AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND KIND OF. WHAT THEY
WHAT ARE THEIR LIMITATIONS AND
HER CHALLENGES AND THEN ALSO BE
IS VERY IS BUSINESS SECTORS
THROUGH OUR GUIDE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF MEN BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. YOU
REALLY GET A SENSE OF. HOW WE
HAVE REALLY HAVE RE ENGAGE THE
ECONOMY- FROM UP HEALTH SIDE
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE- THAT
REALLY DRIVES- DIFFERENT
CHANGES. BASED ON THE GUIDANCE
SO WE ISSUE AT THE STATE LEVEL
OR GUIDANCE THAT LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ISSUE. I TO
MAKE SURE THAT TWO THINGS ONE
THAT- THE EMPLOYEES ARE SAFE
AND THEN THAT ALSO THAT
CUSTOMERS OR THE PUBLIC OUR
STATE WHEN. WHEN INTERACTING
WITH- WITH VERY SECTORS OF.
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU'VE A
CALL THEME HERE AND A HUGE
CONCERN AND THAT'S PP. NOW PP
IS GONNA BE REQUIRED PRETTY
MUCH VIRTUALLY ON MOST
BUSINESSES I WOULD IMAGINE-
AND- THE FACT THAT I IT WENT
THINK I HAVEN'T HEARD IS. IS
THERE A TASK FORCE WORKING ON
PP- BECAUSE IT IT VARIES FROM
FROM PLACE TO PLACE LET ME GIVE
AN EXAMPLE AND MISTER COOPER
BROUGHT UP A REALLY GOOD.
REALLY GOOD POINT WONDERING HOW
BUSY HOW LONG WILL BUSINESSES
WILL BE ABLE TO SURVIVE. SO I'M
A DENTIST BY TRAINING AND
DENTISTRY IS A HIGHLY INTENSE
PP- USER. UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES NOW WE'VE ADDED-
DISPOSABLE GOWNS- HEAD
COVERINGS FACE SHIELDS MAYBE
FOOT COVERINGS IN ADDITION TO
GLOVES AND MASKS- THERE WERE
DENTAL OFFICES AT ACTUALLY
DONATED SUPPLIES- IN THE EARLY
PARTS OF THIS. AND THEY'RE
REALLY CONCERNED THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET PP
WHEN THE SORE ALL CLEAR SIGNAL
COMES OUT TO BE AGAIN TO READ
RAMP UP- IF YOU WERE A SMALL
OFFICE LIKE I WAS I HAD SEVEN
EMPLOYEES- HOW MY GOING TO
COMPETE. WITH THE WORLD OUT
THERE TRYING TO GET PP IF YOU
KNOW IF BIG HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
AND CLINICS AND ALL THESE OTHER
FOLKS ARE OUT THERE A WITH
BIGGER BUYING POWER- AND MORE
BETTER CONNECTIONS THAN I DO.
AND THE REASON THIS BECOME
SIGNIFICAN IS THAT. CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION HOLD THEIR
MEMBERSHIP. AND THERE'S A
BELIEF THAT IF THE DENTIST TREE
ISN'T OPENED UP AND I MEAN
REALLY OPENED UP- BY THE END OF
JUNE. 20% OF THE OFFICES WILL
CLOSE THEIR DOORS. AND IF IT
DOESN'T GET OPERATE GOT GET OUT
BEFORE THE END OF AUGUST. 50%
NOW THINK ABOUT THAT FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF OUR SAFETY NET
FOR EXAMPLE- I RESPONSIBILITY
TO MEDI CAL. THE NUMBERS OF
MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS ARE GOING
UP IN THIS RECESSION AND THE
PROVIDERS ARE GOING DOWN AND
THIS IS JUST DENTISTRY THIS IS
AN OPTOMETRY THIS ISN'T-
MEDICINE THIS ISN'T PODIATRY
THIS IS THIS IS JUST JUST
DENTISTRY. AND THERE IS A HUGE
CONCERN- ABOUT HOW THE VITALITY
OF THEIR OF A BUSINESS RELATED
TO THAT- SO THERE IS CONCERN
AMONG MANUFACTURING I HAVE A
FRIEND WHO DONATED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE MASKS
TO- COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
NOW WHEN HE GOES TO- TRY TO RE
OPEN HIS MANUFACTURING BUSINESS
HOW'S HE GOING TO GET THOSE
SEVEN HUNDRED MASS I'M PRETTY
SURE THEY'RE GONE AND SO- THINK
OF FOOD PRODUCTION THINK OF- A
SCHOOLS PUBLIC. AND WE HAVEN'T
EVEN TALKED ABOUT PRIVATE
SCHOOLS A PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS FOR
ONE- WHAT ABOUT WINERIES AND
BREWERIES- RIGHT NOW I KIND OF
CONSIDER THEM ESSENTIAL FRANKLY
BUT- ALSO IN MY DISTRICT
COMMERCIAL FISHING- YOU KNOW AS
WE LOOK AT SOCIAL DISTANCE
SCENE AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
AND SO. SO QUESTION REALLY OUT
OF THIS IS THERE GOING TO BE IS
THERE A CONCERTED EFFORT IS
THERE A TASK FORCE LOOKING AT
THE PP PP ISSUE BECAUSE IT IS.
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM FOR
pBUSINESS RIGHT NOW. HI GOOD
MORNING DOCTOR WITH THIS IS
TINA CURRY WITH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WERE DEFINITELY LOOKING AT THIS
AT THE STATE LEVEL IT IS
CONSIDERED PART OF WHAT WE CALL
OUR LOGISTICS FUNCTIONS ARE
LOGISTICS. FOLKS AS PART OF THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ARE NOT
ONLY- LOOKING AT ALL THE OTHER
RESOURCE REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
ARE RECEIVING AT THE STATE. AND
WORKING TO BE BUT WITHIN THAT.
EP ITSELF IS ITS OWN I'M JUST
JUST A BIG AREA THAT WE WE'VE
BEEN CONTENDING WHERE IT. AND
WE'RE ARE LOOKING TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT AS A NEW RICH
RECOVERY BECAUSE I THINK AS YOU
ARE AS YOU WERE SAYING THAT
THAT THAT- ABILITY TO HAVE
THAT- PROSPECTORS IS REALLY
INSTRUMENTAL. THIS RECOVERY
PIECE THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY SO IF YOU- EFFORTS ALONG
THOSE LINES I KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT. SOME OF THE OTHER
HEARINGS WITH THE STATE'S DOING
TO REALLY SECURE AND THAT
DEDICATED SUPPLY LINE IN LARGE
QUANTITIES. NOT JUST FOR
HEALTHCARE BUT FOR OTHER
EFFORTS BUT THE SAME TIME I
THINK AND I THINK IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THING THAT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING IS THAT EITHER TO
TEASING ARE NORMALLY HAD A WAY
OF. SECURING OUT ON THEIR OWN
WHETHER IT'S PRIVATE SECTOR- OR
OR OTHER ENTITIES AND THAT
SUPPLY LINE IS JUST NOT
AVAILABLE OR THERE'S JUST
FUTURE COMPETITION OR AT. AND
SO THAT THAT SUPPLY I'M OUTSIDE
OF EVEN THE EMERGENCY NEED IT
IS A PROBLEM AND- SO WE'RE
PREPARED TO LOOK AT THAT TO NOT
ONLY. YOU KNOW ASK THE SHORE
THAT UP AS AN EMERGENCY NEED
AND TELL THAT ONLINE BE CAN
BECOME MORE STABLE OR PEOPLE
TO. IT'S KIND OF BACKED DOWN
BEGIN TO BURKE HERE ARE JUST
SAY WE BACK DOWN FROM THE
EMERGENCY BE ABLE TO- THINGS AS
THEY NORMALLY WHITE SO. I TASK
FORCE FOR SAY I WOULD SAY IT'S
EMBEDDED WITHIN WHAT WE
NORMALLY HAVE EMERGENCIES HICH
IS A LOGISTICS COMPONENT AND
WENT IN THAT IS THAT. IS THAT
HE HE PART OF IT OR BOTH CV FOR
CLASSIC DISTRIBUTING AND
PRIORITIZING AS A BEACON BILL
AS WE CAN BUILD ON. AND WE ARE
CONTINUE WILL GET YOU NEED
SUPPORT THAT AT THIS. NOT FOR
AS LONG AS NEED. FOR THE
DURATION OF THIS EMERGING. I
HOPE THAT ALL WELL. HE YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT IS A PROBLEM I
CAN SEE TO CRY QUITE IF YOU
TELL A BILL THEY NOW- OPEN
WHERE THEY CAN BEGIN TO HAVE A
PLAN FOR OPENING AND THEY CAN'T
GET PP. WE HAVEN'T ACCOMPLISHED
ANYTHING QUITE FRANKLY AND
THOSE BUSINESSES WILL CONTINUE
TO SUFFER UNEMPLOYMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO GO UP AND THE
ECONOMY WILL CONTINUE TO TURN
DOWN AND SO I GUESS WHAT I WAS
HOPING FOR OUT OF THAT WAS THAT
THERE IS A PLAN TO HELP WE ARE.
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY AND
IN THE WORLD. COULD WE NOT
FIGURE OUT A PLAN MAYBE TO
ACTUALLY BEGIN TO PRODUCE OUR
OWN PP THESE MASKS. AND ALL
THESE OTHER THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE A WAY OF LIFE FOR MONTHS AND
MAYBE LONGER- AND I WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
AT SHORING UP THINGS BECAUSE
SHORING UP DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR
THE HUGE INCREASE. IN THE
DEMAND IN THE NEED FOR THESE
SUPPLIES YOU CAN SHORE UP THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. BUT THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN IS GROSSLY INADEQUATE
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S GOING TO BE
GROSSLY INADEQUATE FOR A LONG
TIME. SO MY HOPE IS THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE A
CONCERTED EFFORT BECAUSE I JUST
THINK OF PEOPLE WHO GAVE AWAY
THEIR PP AND THE SPIRIT OF
WANTING TO HELP. NOW THEY'RE
GOING TO GET A CHANCE TO REOPEN
THEIR BUSINESS AND THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO GET PP. AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE ANOTHER I CONSIDER
THIS A CRISIS QUITE FRANKLY ON
TOP OF A CRISIS SO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE THE
MISTER FUNK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF MY FIRST QUESTION IS
FOR MR PADDOCK YOU HAD US IN
TESTIMONY ABOUT CREATIVE USES
OF THE TITLE TWELVE LOAN
PROCESS TO BORROW MONEY- FORM
THE FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT SYSTEM
AND- I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON- THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHER STATES
WHICH HAS BEEN THAT THIS NEW-
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
BENEFIT OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
A WEEK- OTHER STATES THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF CALIFORNIA
AND RE OPENING THEIR ECONOMIES
HAVE FOUND THAT IN CERTAIN-
WORK FOR SECTORS IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT TO HIRE BACK
EMPLOYEES WHERE THE COMBINATION
OF- STATE AND FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. CREATES
AN ECONOMIC INCENTIVE FOR
WORKERS NOT TO COME BACK TO
WORK AND SO THEY'VE HAD
PROBLEMS A PARTICULARLY IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY RE OPENING
THOSE SECTIONS OF THE ECONOMY
SO- MISTER PATRICK DO YOU FEAR
THAT SHOULDN'T WE- IMPLEMENT A
PROGRAM LIKE THE ONE THAT YOUR-
THOSE PROBLEMS WOULD BE
EXPERIENCED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
YES THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
I THINK THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION. AND I THINK IT IS I
THINK IN GENERALTHE IDEA THAT
I. MENTIONED WAS BORN OUT OF
BUT SOME BRAINSTORMING AND WE
WERE DOING IN OUR OFFICE ABOUT
WE USE. THAT THE STATE COULD
GIVE IN ITS- OVER ARCHING
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS AND THE
ISSUES THAT I MENTIONED WE WERE
TRYING TO DO SOME BRAINSTORMING
ABOUT WAYS THE STATE COULD. YOU
KNOW HELP GET FUNDS INTO THE
ECONOMY. SO IT IS ONE WAY TO DO
THAT AT THE SAME TIME I THINK
THERE'S A VERY. MATERIAL
TRADEOFFS BUT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT IT ALONE WOULD HAVE TO BE
REPAID ALTHOUGH I WOULD MENTION
THAT THAT THERE IS ACT- MADE
THE BILL FEDERAL LOAN INTEREST
FREE AT LEAST FOR THE REMAINDER
OF. TWENTY TWENTY BUT THEN
THERE ARE ALSO THESE ARE
ECONOMIC- INSTEAD OF. I OF
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE- AND I
THINK THAT THE ANY GOT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD PROBABLY
WARRANT FURTHER DISCUSSION
PERHAPS WITH INCLUDED EXPERTS
LIKE. PROFESSOR NIKOLSBURG OR
OTHER ECONOMIST BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A VALID QUESTION AND
SOMETHING THAT. THAT YOU KNOW
THE- YOU WOULD WANT TO WAIT
BEFORE BEFORE PROCEEDING. I
THANK YOU AND TO FOLLOW ON TO
THAT QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHEN MR
PEDICLE WAS- SPEAKING ABOUT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
HE MENTIONED A CONCERN ABOUT
HOW THOSE LOANS GET REPAID. AND
I WONDERED IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAD- SOME- SOME
INFORMATION FOR US ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THOUGHTS ABOUT
HOW THOSE LOANS WOULD GET
REPAID BECAUSE AS MR PADDOCK
TESTIFIED IF WE DO NOTHING THAT
ENTIRE BURDEN IS GOING TO FALL
ON THE BACKS OF EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH- WOULD BE A
GROSS INJUSTICE AND STAY REALLY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS
CRISIS. AND I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
WANT TO LAY OFF THOSE EMPLOYEES
OR MAKE THEM UNEMPLOYED. YES
MISTER OBERNOLTE THIS IS TO
MAKE THIS NOT THAT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK-
IN THE LAST RECESSION YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT- AS MR PROTOCOL SO
SAD. THE GENERAL FUND PAID THE
INTEREST ON THE LOAN WHILE THE
PRINCIPLE OF THE LOAN WAS PAID
BACK THROUGH EMPLOYERS VIA
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT. TAXES I
THINK THE WAY THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS RIGHT NOW- YOU
KNOW AS OF APRIL SIXTEENTH WE
STILL HAD ONE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS- IN OUR TRUST
FUND BUT WE IMAGINE THAT THAT
WILL BE DRAWN DOWN IN PRETTY
SHORT ORDER WE- RECEIVED.
AUTHORIZATION TO BORROW- AND WE
WILL LIKELY YOU KNOW BE DOING
BORROWING IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE RAIN REMAINDER
UP THIS YEAR- IT DEPENDING ON
HOW THAT SITUATION INVOLVES. I
THINK IT'S A DIFFICULT QUESTION
TO ANSWER RIGHT NOW BECAUSE- AS
YOU NOTED THIS WILL BE AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS
JUST AS IT WAS DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. AT THE SAME TIME-
THE GENERAL FUND WILL BE UNDER
VERY SIGNIFICANT PRESSURE AND
YOU'RE RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES DOING. OUR FINAL
FORECASTING FOR THE NAY
REVISION- BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
AS WELL AS ALL OF YOU WANT TO
MAKE VERY DIFFICULT AND EVEN
PAINFUL DECISIONS. ABOUT HOW
THE GENERAL FUND WILL BE
ALLOCATED NOT ONLY THIS YEAR
BUT IN SEVERAL YEARS AFTER
THAT. SO THERE IS A TRADE OFF
AND THAT IF THE GENERAL FUND
PICKS UP SOME OF THE PRINCIPLE
IN ADDITION TO THE INTEREST-
THAT WILL BE MONEY THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER PROGRAMS-
INCLUDING UNDERSECRETARY. OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WHICH I KNOW IT'S BEEN A THEME
OF SOME OF THE OTHER PANELISTS
SO THERE'S NO REALLY. GOOD OR
EASY ANSWER HERE AT ALL STATE
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW. I'M AS PART OF OUR
DELIBERATIONS I JUST MAY NOT. A
NAY CLASS AND OF THAT. BUDGET
THIS YEAR BUT WE HAVEN'T BAR
YEAH IT IS CERTAINLY A QUESTION
OUR BROADER. PLAN AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE HOPING FOR A SMALL.
SUPPORT BECAUSE MORE THAN
FEDERAL GOT. THE LAST WILL BE
DEPARTING THEIR OWN AND- OR THE
GENERAL FUND. AS MISTER PATTON.
THAT IF I GOVERNMENT HAS TO
THAT THEY WILL NOT BE. CHARGING
ANY INTO FIRST ON LOW. WITH THE
REMAINDER OF. TWENTY TWENTY. I
THE GOVERNOR AT HIGH SPEED.
ASKED IF I GOVERNMENT. TO
EXTEND THAT DAY. I IN ADDITION
TO. WHEN IT. TO THE- YEAH JUST
THE ENTRENCHED. WE'RE HOPING
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL STEP UP AND PROVIDE. FOR
THEIR- THAT THERE IS WELL THEY
HAD DONE IT WITH THE PANDEMIC.
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS BUT THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER WEEK BOOST. AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE AS YOU NOTED MISTER
OBERNOLTE THAT WE ARE REALLY AN
UNPRECEDENTED CIRCUMSTANCES
HERE. AND SO WE'RE HOPING FOR
THEIR ASSISTANCE AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS CRISIS. RIGHT
THANK YOU I THINK THIS IS AS
YOU SAY A DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE-
HOWEVER. I FEEL VERY STRONGLY
THAT. WE OUGHT TO HOLD
EMPLOYERS HARMLESS FOR.
REPAYMENT OF THAT PRINCIPLE
SINCE THEY REALLY HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH- EITHER THE
SITUATION THAT CAUSED. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT OR OUR RECENT
DECISION TO BORROW BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TITLE TWELVE LOANS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SO. I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
A COMMITMENT BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT. COME HELL
OR HIGH WATER. THAT THE BURDEN
OF REPAYING THIS PRINCIPLE IS
NOT GOING TO FALL. ON THE BACKS
OF CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS- IN
IS YOU KNOW. THE PROBLEMS THERE
REALLY TO A KIND OF UNRELATED
PROBLEMS AS A PROBLEMS OF
REPAYING THE PRINCIPLE OF THOSE
LOANS THAT WERE MAKING THIS
YEAR. THERE'S ALSO THE RELATED
PROBLEM. THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
GOING TO FACE HIGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PREMIUMS
BECAUSE OF. THE CLAIMS AGAINST
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
RESERVE ACCOUNTS AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE TO
SINCE THAT'S ANOTHER-
DIFFICULTY THAT REALLY THEY HAD
NO- THEY HAD NO- A PARTNERSHIP
IN MAKING- I'D LIKE TO HAVE
ONE. LAST QUESTION IT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THAT
REGARDS WERE RELATES TO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF AB FIVE SO I
KNOW IT'S AN ONGOING DISCUSSION
THAT WE- HAVE BEEN HAVING WITH
THE MINISTRATION. BEFORE THIS
CRISIS SAID. THE PLAN WAS TO
SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
STATE MONEY AND INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT. FOR AB FIVE- BUT
I'M WONDERING IF THE CURRENT
SITUATION CHANGES THOSE PLANS
BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE ONE ANYWAY
THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT WOULD SEEM
LIKE ES- THE TESTIMONY TODAY
WOULD INDICATE IF MORE OF OUR
ECONOMY A SHIFTING TO WARDS
WORKING FROM HOME. THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO
TAKE A PAUSE AND RETHINK. IN
TERMS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB FIVE AND I WAS INTERESTED
ONE MISTER ALLEN WITH A
HALLMARK SHE'S COMPANY VERY
ASTUTELY POINTED OUT. IF THE
SHIP IS PARTIALLY SUBMERGED YOU
DON'T THROW EXTRA WEIGHT ON THE
SHIP IN THIS IS- WHAT OBVIOUSLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
CALIFORNIA SMALL EMPLOYERS SO I
WONDER WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STANCE IS. ON
PERHAPS PAUSING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE AND
ALSO IN WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIX SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE BEEN.
IDENTIFIED WITH THAT
LEGISLATION. YES I'LL SPEAK
VERY BRIEFLY TO THAT AND THEN
MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS **** WHO'S
ON THE LINE AS WELL AND MAY BE
ABLE. BOOKS SO IT IS A LOT OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE IT I THINK
WE'VE SEEN WHAT THIS EMERGENCY
MAKING SURE THAT WORKERS. KNOW
WHO FEEL LIKE THEY'VE BEEN
MISCLASSIFIED YOU KNOW THEY CAN
CERTAINLY WORK WITH ARMS LIKE
TO MORE DEPARTMENT BUT WE ALSO.
BELIEVE THAT THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALSO
PROVIDES ANOTHER AVENUE OF
SUPPORT- FOR SOME OF THESE
WORKERS YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
OBSTACLES THAT THEY'RE FACING
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT- BUT WHEN
IT COME SECIFICALLY CARE
QUESTIONS ALTERNATE OFFERED AT
CHRIS **** WITH REGARD TO
ENFORCEMENT. GREAT THANK YOU AT
CHRIS COOK WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND AS YOU KNOW THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES HAVE-
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT DOES- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
ENFORCEMENT- AS WE'VE SAID WITH
ALL OF OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS WERE GOING TO BE
CONTINUING TO WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THOSE- DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO SHARE IT WITH
REGARDS TO THE APPROACH ON
EIGHTY FIVE BUT DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT THAT AS SOMETHING AS
PART OF A MAJOR REVISION AS M.
AND- CONSIDERING- RE LOOKING
AT- THE EIGHTY FIVE
CONVERSATION BUT NOTHING
ADDITIONAL SHARE AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO-
HOPEFULLY THE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
ON A SHORTENED LEGISLATIVE
CALENDAR FOR THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA BE FOCUSING ON THE THINGS
THAT ARE EITHER CORONAVIRUS
RELATED OR ARE CRITICALLY
URGENT FOR A CALIFORNIA'S-
ECONOMY IN GETTING OUR US
THROUGH THE SITUATION AND- I
DON'T THINK I'M ALONE IN SAYING
THAT FIXING SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT ABOUT AN
IDENTIFIED WITH AB FIVE- IS ON
THAT SHORT LIST OF THINGS TO DO
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS. YOU
KNOW BIPARTISAN BICAMERAL
SUPPORT FOR ADDRESSING SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES THIS YEAR I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE DO THAT.
AS CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES START
TO EMERGE FROM THIS CRISIS SO
IT'S SOMETHING I'M HOPEFUL TO
BE WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON.
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO
COME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG IN THE
MISTER WERE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OTHER CERTAINLY NO DOUBT
THAT GROWING THE ECONOMY IS THE
KEY TO IMPROVING THE STATE'S
FINANCIALS- A STATUS AND
SITUATION. AND I WANTED TO USE.
BUT THE VISUAL PAINTED- THAT
THE ECONOMY AND SMALL
BUSINESSES IF IT'S A SHIP WE
DON'T WANT IN HERE WITH THE
RECOVERY YOU WANT A LIFT THE
BURDENS ON SMALL BUSINESSES AND
REDUCE THE WEIGHT- THAT THE
STATE CALIFORNIA'S PLACING WITH
HIM. SO AS MANY INDUSTRIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR
BUSINESS THE FLOAT- TO QUESTION
TO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCED WITH
ADMINISTRATION BE WILLING TO
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND- ANY NEW
NON A NON COATED NINETEEN
RELATED REGULATIONS IN ORDER TO
GIVE BUSINESSES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REBOUND. THERE OKAY WE'LL
WE'LL SKIP THAT WILL COME BACK
TO THE QUESTION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION MR FONG GIVEN
THE QUESTIONS- CABLE ARE MOVING
ON TO THE LA- IS THERE
PRESIDENT'S FOR PAUSING TO
REGULATIONS TO ALLOW THE
ECONOMY TO REBOUND. THE BILL IS
THE LA OKAY. RIGHT HELLO HELLO
SO WE HAVE CONNECTION OR A.
OKAY WELL WHICH SOLD OFF WANT
TO YEAH. NO GET HIS WAY BACK.
YEAH WHICH IS THE- SIT TIGHT
FOR A SECOND. IT.
YEAH.
RIGHT
RIGHT THE QUESTION YOUR I CAN I
CAN I GET A REPEATED. OUTDOORS
HAPPY TO REPEAT.
I DIDN'T BREAK
I AM BREAKING. THERE ARE. ALL I
KNOW IS YOU WERE TALKING WITH.
RICHARD SHERMAN BUT YOU KNOW.
I'M GONNA FINANCE. THE REST.
DIPLOMA FINANCING HERE YOU WANT
TO SAY YES. SEVEN AS WE CAN
HERE YEAH. SO JUST REPEAT THE
QUESTION I JUST IN CASE IT
WASN'T HER- THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT GROWING THE ECONOMY IS KEY
TO IMPROVING THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL SITUATION AND- TO USE
THE ANALOGY THAT WAS PRESENTED
IF GIVE THE ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA AND SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE SHIP TRYING TO STAY AFLOAT-
WE DON'T WANT TO INHIBIT THEIR
RECOVERY HE WON A LIFT AS MUCH
BURDENS ON THEM AS POSSIBLE AND
REDUCE THE WEIGHT SO WITH THEM
SO MANY INDUSTRIES STRUGGLING
TO KEEP THEIR BUSINESSES OF
FLOAT. AND SAME BUSINESS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION BE WILLING
TO TEMPORARILY SUSPEND ANY NEW
NON COATED NINETEEN RELATED
REGULATIONS IN ORDER TO GIVE
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REBOUND. HI
MISTER FUNG RESIDENT EIGHT MISS
WENT OFF AND I THINK WE ARE
DEFINITELY TAKING A LOOK AT
REGULATIONS AND YOU KNOW SOME
OF OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE
SPECIFICALLY ENGAGED- WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY WORK WITH
OR THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT THEY
WORK WITH. ON HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
MOST ESSENTIAL RIGHT NOW AND
THAT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING THAT
WILL UNNECESSARILY. AND KEEP
THE RECOVERY OUT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY FEEL THAT A
BLANKET- REMOVAL OR PAUSE AND
ALL REGULATIONS IS THE BEST WAY
FORWARD HERE- GIVING HOW
COMPLICATED THE SITUATION IS-
BUT- IT'S DEFINITELY THE CASE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO TO MAKE THE RECOVERY
A SPLIT AS POSSIBLE GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT WORK. CAN I.
WAIT. WITH SO MUCH I HAVE BEEN
THERE
ART OR NO. SURE ABSOLUTELY. HI
AS CHAIRMAN I YOU KNOW I HE I'M
HEARING A LOT OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT SMALL BUSINESS AND OF
COURSE WE SHARE THEM I JUST
WANT TO. ALL BUSINESS IN
OPENING WILL RELY ON CONSUMERS
WILL RELY ON PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY
PURCHASE AT EAT OUT. AND IF
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT GUARANTEED
CERTAIN PROTECTIONS- INCOME THE
ABILITY TO TAKE TIME OFF WHEN
THEY'RE SICK THE ABILITY TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO CONSUME AND
SO I THINK IT'S CRITICAL TO
NOT- YES WE NEED TO LIFT ALL
BOATS BUT THOSE BOATS HAVE TO
INCLUDE WORKERS AND PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS NOT JUST MOTHER. IS
OTHERWISE THE SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SURVIVE
WITHOUT CONSUMERS WHO CAN
ACTUALLY THAT HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL TO ACTUALLY SPEND ON
TO ITS A CRITICAL THAT WE ARE
NOT ONLY PROTECTING SMALL
BUSINESS AND LOOKING AT WHAT
REGULATIONS WE CAN- SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESS WITH BUT ALSO
NOT TAKING AWAY ALL PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS AT THE SAME TIME.
WHO WILL NEED PROTECTION IS TO
BE ABLE TO SURVIVE THRIVE FEED
THEIR FAMILIES AND CONSUME SO I
IS SO I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT THAT THAT'S WHY THE
QUESTION WAS SPECIFIC TO
PAUSING ANY NEW NON COVE EIGHT
NINETEEN RELATED REGULATIONS SO
FOR EXAMPLE- BLARING ON
REGULATIONS FROM CARP ON OUR
PORTS- LAYERING ON. REGULATIONS
ON OP OF OUR TRUCKING INDUSTRY
THAT MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
LAYERING MORE REGULATIONS ARE
AND THEY HELP MORE CHEESE
COMPANY THAT'S ACTUALLY TRYING
TO PRODUCE CHEESE AND FOOD
PRODUCTS FOR CALIFORNIANS
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME. IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO ME THAT WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN GROW THAT THEY
CAN EXPAND THEY CAN RE HIGHER
CALIFORNIANS SO THAT THEY CAN-
THAT THEY CAN BEGIN TO
PARTICIPATE AND ACTUALLY
GENERATE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. ON
A SIMILAR NOTE THE GOVERNMENT
IS ALSO TAKING US A MEASURES
PROVIDE CRITICAL ASSISTANCE TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW WOULD IT BE ADVISABLE AND
WITH ADMINISTRATION AND THIS IS
QUESTIONS THE PALMER FINANCES
WELL. CREATE A MORATORIUM ON
NEW TAXES AND FEES SO THAT WE
AREN'T ACTUALLY TAXING THE
FAMILIES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE RECEIVING RELIEF RIGHT.
MR FOG ON THE QUESTION OF THAT
THAT TAXES AND FEES- GENERALLY-
AS YOU KNOW WE DON'T THAT TAXES
OR FEES UNDER PROP TWENTY SIX
REQUIRE- THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
SO THE GOVERNOR'S FINALIZING
THAT AT THE SCHOOL PLAN IN THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS SO I DON'T WANT
TO. GET AHEAD OF ANY DECISIONS
THAT HE MAY MAKE- BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ANY NEW TAXES OR FEES
THAT FALL UNDER PROP TWENTY
SIX- DOES GENERALLY WILL NOT GO
FORWARD WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL. SO THE GOVERNOR IS
CONTEMPLATING A MORATORIUM ON
TAXES AND FEES BROADLY OR JUST
FOR THAT SPECIFIC. YEAH I WOULD
NOT SAY THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTEMPLATING A MORATORIUM I
THINK I ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS WORKING ON THE
NAY REVISION BUDGET- AND WHEN
IT COMES TO NEW TAXES AND FEES-
THOSE GENERALLY ARE ENACTED FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. SO THE
GOVERNOR IS IN AN AS IS LOOKING
AT SOME MEMBERS WERE RELIEF AND
SOME ON AND SOME SOME MORE AND
MORE TOWARD A MONTH SOME TAXES
AND FEES. THE WORD MORATORIUM
I. RESERVE WHATEVER'S IN AND IF
YOU WANT TO USE. OR TO THE YEAH
NOW THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS THAT
DIRECTLY- YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE NAY REVISION
pTHE LAST COUPLE WEEKS. HAS
REALLY BEEN ON PROVIDING
EMERGENCY AND URGENT RELEASED
AYE TO THAT HE PAUL IN A SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE ENTITIES
THAT NEED IT MOST AND SO. SOME
OF THE MEASURES YOU SEEN THEIR
BAN ON FOR EXAMPLE SALES TAX
FOR SMALL BUSINESS DAYS OF A
CERTAIN SIZE- REVENUE. THEY CAN
ADD MAKE THEIR PAYMENTS OVER
THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS RATHER
THAN HAVING SALES TAX ALL AT
ONCE THAT PROVIDES SOME
REGULATORY RELIEF. I IN
ADDITION FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AS WITH INDIVIDUALS- THE FILING
DEADLINE FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TAXES I WAS MOVED FROM APRIL
FIFTEENTH TO JULY FIFTEENTH AND
YOU KNOW WE ARE CERTAINLY
WORKING ON OUR OWN CASH FLOW TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT. I KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE AS WELL SO
THESE ARE THE TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY TYPES OF MEASURES
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
CONTEMPLATED AND ALSO WORKING
WITH LENDERS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE PROVIDING RELIEF
TO THAT AT THE DEBTORS ARE NOT
MET THEY HAVE AS WELL- BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO BUY NEW TAXES OR
NEW FEES. I GUESS WHAT I'M
SAYING THERE IS THAT ULTIMATELY.
THAT BY JUST WHAT WE ARE A THE
IN. IS IN THE. REALLY WE CAN
ADD TO GET. YOU KNOW THE OF
THIS EMERGENCY RIGHT OUR- WHILE
AT THE SAME. LOOK TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU. ON THE NAY RIDLEY AND
A BY WHICH AS MISS CAN MATCH
THAT THE STAR OF THIS YEAR I.
THE STILL THE PLAN YOU ARE
PROPOSED THAT BOUNCE BUDGET ON
A FOURTEEN. AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT A BALANCED
BUDGET ON JUNE FIFTEENTH IN ANY
TAXES OR REVENUE DECISIONS I
WILL BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THAT BY THE LEGISLATURE. SO
WHAT I BY I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER IT
CERTAINLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
TO ME THAT AT A TIME WHEN SMALL
BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA OR STRUGGLING. AND
THAT WE WANT TO BURDEN THEM
WITH WITH ANY. ADDITIONAL
BURDENS WHETHER IT'S A NEW
TAXES NEW FEES OR NEW
REGULATIONS- IN TERMS OF THAT
QUESTION TO THE LA. IS THERE
PRESIDENT'S. TO DOING AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW AT LOOKING FOR
AREAS WHERE WE CAN. TEMPORARILY
PIES- ANY NEW REGULATIONS ARE
NON COVERED RELATED- ANY-
APOLOGIZE TO ADD TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY RELIEF AT OR TO YOU-
PAS TAXES AND FEES TO ALLOW.
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA TO
REBOUND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON IT
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION IT'S
ACTUALLY ONE OUR OFFICE IS ALSO
BEEN IN SOME DISCUSSIONS WITH
BEHIND THE SCENES HERE AS WE-
GET READY FOR THE COMING THAT.
YOU WERE MY COLLEAGUE CAROL AND
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO ADD SOME
OF THE SENATE DID WELL.
COMMENTS ON THIS TOPIC
MORNING CAROLINE CHEER FROM THE
LA SHOW YES SO BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG I
DON'T KNOW IF IN PAST
RECESSIONS THE STATE
NECESSARILY- TOOK A FOR ITS
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE REGULATIONS
AS YOU KNOW REGULATIONS ARE ARE
DERIVED FROM STATE STATUTE-
THAT OUR GOVERNING BY THE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS THAT SAID
THEY'RE LIKELY ARE SOME
REGULATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
THAT WERE ENVISIONED FOR FORGET
OF A DIFFERENT WORLD AND THAT
THE- MISTER PICKS POINT WE WILL
LIKELY IN THE LEGISLATURE
LIKELY MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THERE ARE SOME THAT-
EITHER COULD BE TEMPORARILY.
CAUSED OR STEPPED BACK IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE ECONOMIC RE
OPENING AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT- WHAT THOSE
POTENTIALLY COULD BE- AND NOT
NECESSARILY JUST NEW
REGULATIONS BUT IT EXISTING
ONES AS WELL. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WELL WHY TO IMPLORE
THE MINISTRATION INTO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THERE'S ONLY
SO MUCH. THE GOVERNMENT CAN DO
TO ASSIST IN GETTING OUR
FINANCIAL HOUSE IN ORDER
CERTAINLY THERE ARE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS TO BE LAID TO BE
MADE- MOVING FORWARD BUT
ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO BE.
THE INNOVATORS DUTCH ADORES
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS- IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOING TO GET
OUR OUR ECONOMIC ENGINE GOING
AND OUR ECONOMIC HEALTH IN A IN
A BETTER SITUATION SO IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS LAWMAKERS HAD
TO CREATE A SMOOTH OF A PATH A
PATH AS POSSIBLE FOR THEM. INTO
NOT TO LAYER ON AND BIRD IN AN
ALREADY SINKING BOAT THAT IS
TAKING ON WATER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PUSH IT THANK YOU BEFORE
YOU GO TO MISTER GRAY UNTIL-
PROFESSOR AT JAIRAM AN NEEDED
TO LEAVE AT NOON ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. FOR HER I WAS GONNA
MOVE THOSE UP IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS FOR HER. OKAY
THANK YOU SCOTT DUNCAN'S
CORRECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAN THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPERTISE YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE THIS AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TING FOR PUTTING
THIS HEARING TOGETHER I THINK
AS WE TURN OUR EYES TO-
DEPENDING- NEED FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY INVESTMENTS- AND
FOSTERING ECONOMIC GROWTH IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SIT WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND
INTO THIS ISSUE. I WANT TO
START. FOLLOWING UP ON SEVERAL
MY COLLEAGUES WHO BROUGHT UP.
THIS NOTION OF REDUCING
BARRIERS REDUCING REGULATION I
WANT TO THANK. DAVE BOLLAND
WHOSE BOTH A CONSTITUENT AND-
RUNS A GREAT. BUSINESS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT EMPLOYS A LOT OF
PEOPLE- AND CONTRIBUTES A WHOLE
LOT NOT JUST CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. IT
STRUCK ME AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
I SEE THINGS EXACTLY THE SAME
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER FONG BUT
I DO THINK WHETHER IT'S A
BLANKET- RELAXATION OF NEW
REGULATION- AND FRANKLY- NEW
LITIGATION AS WELL YOU KNOW WE
BECOME- CHANGES- WITH TOO MUCH
REGULATION CALIFORNIA AND-
WHILE I APPRECIATE. THE
COMMENTS. REGARDING BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
STRESS BOTH I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF ROOM TO RELAX- OF-
REGULATIONS AND CERTAINLY HALL
NEW REGULATIONS LOT AREAS THAT
AREN'T CAN ADVERSELY IMPACT BUT
RATHER WOULD HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES AND- JUST IN OUR NECK
OF THE WOODS I KNOW MR FONG
SHARES MANY OF THESE INDUSTRIES
AND IN HIS BACKYARD- THE
AIRBOARD THE WATER BOARD YOU
KNOW CURRENTLY THE WATER BOARDS
LOOKING AT- EXPANSIONS OF THE-
PHASE TWO BAY DELTA THAT HAVE
HUGE CONSEQUENCES. THESE ARE
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT HAVE NO
URGENT NEED RIGHT NOW AND I
WOULD STRONGLY SUGGEST THE
GOVERNOR CONSIDER- HALTING SOME
OF THOSE ACTIVITIES TELL WILL
GET THROUGH THIS ECONOMIC
CRISIS YEAH I'VE SEEN. SEVERAL
OPINION PIECES THROUGHOUT
PUBLICATIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE COUNTRY TALKING ABOUT THE
GAMES WE'VE MADE.
ENVIRONMENTALLY DURING THIS
CRISIS THAT SOME OF THE
SLOWDOWN ACTIVITY HAS ACTUALLY
HAD A POSITIVE EFFECT AND I
KNOW. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHERE MY DISTRICT. IS WE
CONTINUE TO. PRODUCE FOOD WE
HAVE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE
CONTINUE TO. MOVE THAT FOOD
ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND YET ARE THERE IS
MUCH CLEANER WHICH CERTAINLY.
BEGS THE QUESTION THOSE THAT
HAVE. LAY IN THE AIR QUALITY
ISSUES AT THE DOORSTEP OF
AGRICULTURE AND ARE REAL
COMMUNITIES- MAY HAVE BEEN-
MISINFORMED OR MAY HAVE
INTENTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE. ANOTHER LOOK AT POST THIS
CRISIS. I'D LIKE TO GOVERNOR TO
CONSIDER REGULATORY EXPANSION-
HOLIDAY BUT MAYBE MORE
APPROPRIATELY- TO RESPOND FROM
THE FINEST COME TO ME WE NEED A
TASK FORCE THAT IS- BIPARTISAN
BICAMERAL- INCLUDE
ADMINISTRATION TO LOOK AT VERY
SPECIFIC TARGETED. REGULATORY
RELIEF- BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
AN EXCEPTIONAL POINT MAY WE
DON'T WANT TO. INCREASE THE
WEIGHT ON OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE.
SO IT'S VERY COMMON THAT I WANT
TO ASK YOU TO COMMENT FURTHER
I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO SMALL
BUSINESS LENDING AND FIND OUT
WHAT IDEAS DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AS IT HAS BEEN EXTORTED
FRUSTRATION- IN MY DISTRICT I'M
SURE THROUGHOUT MY COLLEAGUES
DISTRICTS TO SEE SMALL
BUSINESSES- ARE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE LINES OF
CREDIT THAT THEY NEED. TO GET
THROUGH THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TIME AND FRANKLY I THINK SOME
OF OUR BANKS. HAVE DONE A VERY
POOR JOB- AND I REALIZE WE HAVE
SOME LIMITATIONS TO WHAT THE
FEDS AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STATE REGULATE AS A GHOST BANKS
I KNOW WE HAVE OUR BANKING
CHAIR HERE TODAY PARTICIPATING
THIS HEARING AND I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE HER TO TAKE
A GOOD LOOK. AT WHAT ACTIONS
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE
LINES OF CREDIT- TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THIS DIFFICULT TIME
JUST FINANCE HAVE ANY COMMENT
ON THAT ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PLANS GOING INTO THIS BUDGET.
YES THANK YOU THROUGHOUT SAY
VERY BRIEFLY NUMBER WHY AND- I
THINK THAT SITUATION THAT. WE
HAVE SEEN-WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES WITH THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR WHICH IS I THINK.
WHAT YOU WERE REFERRING TO AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL- GOVERNOR'S
MAKE CLEAR THAT- THOSE ISSUES
ARE UNACCEPTABLE THEY NEED TO
BE FIXED. AND WHAT WE SAW IN
THE BILL THAT PASSED THIS LAST
WEEK WAS MAKING SURE THAT SOME
OF THOSE ASSETS AT NEW WE
PROVIDED. BY CONGRESS WILL BE
CARVED OUT A SPECIFICALLY FOR
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
REALLY GET THE ACCESS THAT THEY
WERE ENTITLED TO. THE FIRST
TIME- SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
ISSUES BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES OTHER ISSUES
IN THE PROGRAM. CONGRESS HAS
AFFECTS ALL OF THEM SO I THINK
BAG GOVERNOR HAS CERTAINLY
CALLED FOR MAKING SURE. THAT
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THIS
PROGRAM IT'S NOT PRIVILEGING.
THE LARGEST LENDERS AND I'M A
I'M SORRY THE LARGEST BORROWERS
ARE THE MOST WELL CONNECTED
BUSINESS AS BUT THAT ALL. SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN AND ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM AND IN PARTICULAR I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS IS A LOT OF.
NAMING AND SHAMING AROUND SOME
OF THOSE BUSINESSES AND THAT
MAY BE IMPORTANT TO MAKING
SURE. THAT SOMEBODY'S LARGER
MORE WELL KNOWN BUSINESSES ARE
EXPLAINING THE PROGRAM. BUT I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS
A MORE SYSTEMATIC ISSUE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE VERY
CLEAR- NEEDS TO BE FIXED. I
THINK SECOND WHEN IT COMES TO
THE STATE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON BASE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IN MAKING SURE
MORE AND MORE BORROWER IS A
REALLY DO NEED THAT ASSISTANCE
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT PROGRAMS.
AND THEN FINALLY- AS YOU KNOW
WE DID HAVE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA FOR
STRUCTURE INVOLVING BANKS ALSO
KNOWN AS THE AYE BANK I
SPECIFICALLY FOR THOSE ENTITIES
THAT FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE OR
AND I COULD EASILY ACCESS SOME
OF THE OTHER EIGHT INCLUDING
THE FEDERAL AID. THAT WAS
MENTIONED SO THESE ARE SOME OF
THE TOOLS THAT WERE WORKING ON
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE DOING
MORE ON THIS YOU KNOW LOOKING
FOR THE NAY REVISION PROCESS
THAT WHAT MORE. WE CAN DO- AND
THEN AS YOU KNOW AND WE HAD A
BRIEF DISCUSSION LAST WEEK
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
TASK FORCE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS STOOD OUT. THERE GOING TO
BE FOCUSED. VERY MUCH ON THIS
ISSUE. AS WELL SO SOME OF OUR
TOOLS ARE. IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE OF THE DOWN. BUDGET
REQUIREMENT WE WERE DISCUSSING.
BUT CERTAINLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
ACCESS- PUSHING OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO DO MORE AT THE
GOVERNMENT ADMINISTRATION
REALLY COMMITTED TO DOING EVERY.
WELL MAKE SURE THAT I DOUBLE
DOWN ON MY COMMENTS THAT WE
HOLD THESE INSTITUTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE I KNOW MY DISTRICT
SOME OF THE SMALLER COMMUNITY
BANKS. SEEM TO HAVE NO PROBLEM
GETTING LINES CURVED OUT TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHILE THE
LARGER NATIONAL BANKS-SEEM TO
OR APPEAR TO. BE DRAGGING THEIR
FEET IN SOME INSTANCES- IN A
VERY UNACCEPTABLE WAY AND I
HOPE- BOTH THE GOVERNOR. AND
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR ANY ACTIVITY.
RESEMBLING THAT. AND I WANT TO
REITERATE I HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK. WITH ADMINISTRATION WITH
FINANCE AND OTHERS TO EXPLORE
WAYS THAT WE CAN. PUT A
TEMPORARY- EASE OF WATER BOARD
AIRBOARD IT CETERA-
IMPLEMENTATIONS ON NEW
REGULATIONS THAT ARE COSTLY.
AND DIFFICULT SO THAT WE CAN AT
LEAST ALLOW THOSE BUSINESSES
STILL FLOAT TO CONTINUE TO
REMAIN FLOAT. I WANT TO MOVE
NOW TO. STANDING ON THE SOCIAL
WORKER NATURE OF MY DISTRICT
WHILE MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN SHELTER IN PLACE MAYBE THE
PEOPLE I REPRESENT CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE FOOD- AND TO DO THE
CRITICAL WORK THAT ALLOWS ALL
OF YOU AND YOUR DISTRICTS TO
HAVE A- RELIABLE AFFORDABLE
FOOD SOURCE. THAT INVOLVES
TRACKING THAT FOOD UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA AND- IT IS TRAGIC
THAT THOSE VERY WORKERS LIVING
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ROBUST HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE.
TO PUT THAT VERY REAL TERMS IN
SAN FRANCISCO SITTING CARRY
THEIR FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN
PHYSICIANS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. IN MERCED
COUNTY WHERE I LIVE THERE ARE
NINETY ONE POSITIONS PER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE NOW THAT
SHORTAGE IS- PLAYING ITSELF OUT
VERY DANGEROUS WAYS DURING
THIS- VERY- PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS I JUST RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM A PEDIATRICIAN MY DISTRICT
THE OTHER DAY DOCTOR SAUDI. WHO
WAS HIGHLIGHTING THE VERY REAL
CONCERNS OF POSITIONS- ON THE
FRONT LINES. UNDERSTAFFED IN
THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES-
LOOKING FOR ANY HELP- THE
LEGISLATURE CAN PROVIDE. MY
COLLEAGUE DR REGULAR EARLIER
THIS AFTERNOON MADE SOME
MENTION OF- MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT AND THE NEED TO
INCREASE THOSE RATES ARE
COMPARABLE TO WHAT WE SEE- IN
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM- AS A WAY OF
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THAT I HOPE THE
GOVERNOR- PUTS THAT AT THE TOP.
OF HIS PRIORITY LIST AS WE LOOK
TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND LOOK
TO STABILIZE OUR HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK FORCE. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO ENTER IN VERY
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR- IN IT
MAY BE VERY DIFFICULT BUDGETING
SEVERAL YEARS. BUT I'D LIKE TO
CALL ON BOTH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO. LOOK TOWARDS A BLUE NEW
DEAL. WHERE WE MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN NEW MEDICAL
SCHOOLS NURSING PROGRAMS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS LOAN REPAYMENT
RESIDENCY SLOTS THINGS THAT
HAVE FOR TOO LONG. BEEN IGNORED
AND VERY MUCH TO OUR DETRIMENT
AS WE STRUGGLE TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY DURING THIS WORLD
EVENT THAT WE'RE FACING WITH
COVERT NINETEEN. JUST A FINANCE
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK CONSISTENT WITH
MY VISION FOR A NEW BLUE DEAL.
A BLUE NEW DEAL RATHER THAT.
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE THOSE
NESTOR INVESTMENTS I KNOW THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR EXAMPLE HAD
MONEY IN IT FOR THE MED SCHOOL-
IN THE VALLEY WANT TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE BUT I THINK WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE EVEN A BIGGER
EXPANSION AGAIN I REALIZE THE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN. ALTHOUGH THAT
MEANS WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE-
EVEN MORE THOSE THAT PRECIOUS
RESOURCE IN THOSE FINANCES SO
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANY PLANS AS
A RATES AS RELATES TO- MAKING-
INVESTMENTS IN THOSE AREAS.
VERY BRIEFLY AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE ADAM DORSEY ON THE
LINE AS WELL I THINK YOU
REALLY. DESCRIBE THE TRADE
OFFS. YEAH ACTUALLY THERE WHICH
IS THAT. WE HAD TO ADD SOME OF
THESE COMMITMENTS THAT WE WERE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO IMPORTANT IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET. AND NOW WE
DON'T KNOW- IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THAT WELL WE KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO ARE DOLLARS THAT.
WE HAD IN JANUARY SO WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
YOU KNOW. PUT OUT A REVISED
BUDGET THAT WILL HAVE CUTS BUT-
MAKING SURE THAT WE REDUCE THE
IMPACT TO MINIMIZE IT ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SO.
SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS AND
HELP- ARE CERTAINLY. AT THE TOP
OF OUR WESTERN THINKING THROUGH
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE GIVEN THAT WE'RE IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S JUST YOUR DOLLARS
AVAILABLE SO I CAN'T COMMENT ON
THE SPECIFIC- ITEMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED REGARDING IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND- OTHER FUNDING-
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR
IS LOOKING AT ALL THAT
TOGETHER. IN CONTACT AS HE
THINKS ABOUT WHERE TO PUT
INVESTMENTS AND REVISED BUDGET.
AND OF COURSE ONCE WE PUT THAT
OUT IN MAY FOURTEENTH OF THE
LEGISLATURE- WILL BE AT
THINKING ABOUT THEIR PRIORITIES.
AS WELL AND ADAM YOU WANT TO
SAY ANYMORE. YEAH I THINK IT'S
YEAH. I AGREE I THINK THAT
IT'S- WE MADE SOME HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS AND IN THE BUDGET
ACT LAST YEAR- WITH RESPECT TO
WORK FORCE- WORKFORCE PROP THAT
PROGRAMS AT THE OFFICE OF THAT.
A STATEWIDE. HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND YOUR MEDI CAL
PROGRAM USING PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDS. AND YOU KNOW LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THAT. I
DON'T KNOW THAT. WE KNOW AT
THIS POINT. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THOSE THINGS CAN BE SUSTAINED
ON GOING- INCREASED OR WHATEVER
BUT I THINK THAT. WE WILL- WE
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE- OVER THE LAST YEAR SO. WE
APPRECIATE RESPONSE ALTHOUGH I
THINK I'M. RECOGNIZING THE
FRONT END THAT WE DON'T KNOW IF
THOSE THINGS CAN BE SUSTAINED
WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE. HOW-MANY DIFFICULT BUDGET. WHAT I'M
SAYING IS WE MUST SUSTAIN THOSE
INVESTMENTS WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO BE SHORT SIGHTED- IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SPENDING YOU KNOW
FOR. THE ENTIRE TIME INSURANCE
LEGISLATURE I'VE FOUGHT FOR
REAL INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS IN. RURAL
COMMUNITIES NOT DONE THAT
BECAUSE WHEN WE MADE THE
PROMISE OF HEALTH CARE FOR ALL-
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY WE LEFT
RURAL COMMUNES BEHIND. WE MADE
MAJORS EXPANSION OF INSURANCE
COVERAGE PROGRAMS. WITH NO
EXPANSION WORKFORCE AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IN A PRACTICAL SENSE
FOR PEOPLE RURAL COMMUNITIES IS
NO EXPANSION WHATSOEVER AT NO
ADDITIONAL HEALTHCARE AND WE'RE
SEEING SOME. SOME TRAGIC TRAGIC
SITUATIONS THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES A PUBLIC HEALH
CRISIS LACKING THOSE RESOURCES
THERE FOR SEVERAL YEARS I
CARRIED A BILL. RELATIVE TO
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY DIABETIC
ON MEDI CAL COULD RECEIVE A
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE WATER. A
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE TO EVERY
PRIVATE INSURANCE PLAN-
CUSTOMER- AND A YOU KNOW A
QUICK BEEN AVAILABLE TO-
FEDERAL MEDICARE RECIPIENTS BUT
ONLY NOT AVAILABLE TO SOME OF
THE POOREST CALIFORNIANS. AND
INVESTMENT IN CGM WITH FOLKS
HAVE DIABETES HAS INCREDIBLE
LONG TERM SAVINGS AND I THINK
DOES THE CAR CHOICES WE'RE
GONNA BE MAKING HERE'S WHAT IS
THE LONG TERM VISION AND HOW DO
WE SUREUP- IN A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE. IS IT
MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR THE
STATE TO FREE UP AN EXISTING
HOSPITAL BED OR PROCURING
DISTRIBUTE SURGE CAPACITY BETS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS THE
BANK- AND WE'VE GOT MARK OF
YOUR MAKE IT JUST AS WELL I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THAT DATA
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US WE MAY
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
QUESTION. OKAY I WILL. FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU ON THAT. WE CAN
FOLLOW UP IS THAT WHAT I HEARD.
WE WANT TO AYE HSS ANOTHER PART
OF OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE I
THINK IS TOO OFTEN. OVERLOOKED
YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD HORROR
STORIES OF SKILLED NURSING
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY
STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN THEIR
WORK FOR STERN THIS PANDEMIC
CAN ANOTHER EXTRAORDINARILY
VULNERABLE GROUP. IS ISOLATED
SENIORS LIVING ALONE AT HOME
WHO WERE SERVED BY I. H. S. AS
CARE GIVERS. I HSS PROVIDES
HELP FOR SENIORS THEY CAN LIVE
SAFE IN THEIR HOMES INSTEAD OF
NURSING HOMES AND HOSPITALS
REDUCING COSTS FOR THE STATE- I
THINK WE COULD SAFELY SAY THEIR
WORK NOW IS PROBABLY MORE
IMPORTANT. THAN EVER. BUT YET
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF CARE GIVERS- IN MY DISTRICT
AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND-
I THINK THAT MAY HAVE A LOT TO
DO THAT MANY OF OUR PROVIDERS
ARE. EARNING MINIMUM WAGE AND
OFFERED NO BENEFITS SO GIVEN
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO RECRUIT
MAINTAIN THIS WORKFORCE I HOPE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PLANS
ARE WILL CONSIDER- PLANS TO
PERHAPS. GIVE SOME KIND OF
SUPPLEMENTAL HAZARD PAGE THAT
WE CAN GET THESE IMPORTANT
WORKERS IN THE SENIOR HOMES-
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS ANY COMMENT ON THAT FROM
FINANCER OTHERS. LARA
DEFINITELY TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION- AS THE GOVERNOR
FINALIZES DECISIONS OVER THE
COMING WEEKS OUT BUT I THINK
THAT ALL NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THAT BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU
ALL LOOK FORWARD TO. FOLLOW UP
IN THOSE AREAS- FINALLY IN THE
AREA OF ECONOMIC COVER I WANT
TO. REYES AN IDEA YOU KNOW AS
WE STRUGGLE TO. RESTART AND
REOPEN ECONOMY I THINK WE NEED
TO TAP THE EXPERTISE OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS NOBODY KNOWS HOW TO RUN
THEIR REALIZATION OF THE
BUSINESS- BETTER THAN THE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK EVERY DAY
IN THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESSES. AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR ADMINSTRATION
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER-
CALLING UPON THAT EXPERTISE A
CALL TO ACTION- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP PLANS TO
SAFELY WHEREVER WE ALL REALIZE
THAT COVERT IS GOING TO BE AN
EXTENDED- CHALLENGE AT SOME
LEVEL AND I THINK THE IDEA OF A-
SILVER BALL IT- SOLUTION OR A-
OR A DAY IN THE NEAR FUTURE
WE'RE WE'RE JUST GONNA BE OPEN
A BACK TO BUSINESS AS USUAL IS-
IS MISPLACED. AND WE NEED TO
PLAN FOR THE LONG TERM I THINK
WE SHOULD ENGAGE ALL
CALIFORNIA'S IN THAT PLANNING A
PERHAPS SOME TYPE OF PROCESS
WERE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
OTHERS COULD- IN GAUGE WITH
THEIR LOCAL DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH SOME OF THE
TASK FORCE THE GOVERNOR'S WORK
AND I'D CERTAINLY. BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP THIS IS- A ROUGH
IDEA- I'VE- SENATE A FEW PLACES
IN ADMINISTRATION BUT I'D LOVE
TO SEE. SOME ADDITIONAL FOLLOW
UP- WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THE TOPIC. A COMMENT FROM
FINANCER OTHERS. YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALL SPEAK VERY
BRIEFLY AND THEN I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE MARK OF HHS BASED
BECAUSE WELL I THINK IN TERMS
OF HAT GENERAL APPROACH SHOT
THAT YOU OUTLINED IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FOUND VERY
VALUABLE I KNOW WHEN IT COMES
TO EVERYTHING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CORD THAT WAS
STOOD UP IN THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS TO THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
ALL- CAMPAIGN YOU'RE RUN BY DR
CHIEF SERVICE OFFICER JOSH
FRIDAY ALONG WITH THE FIRST
PARTNER- ENGAGING PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND WHO ARE CLOSE TO THE
ISSUE AS YOU MENTIONED. IS THE
BEST WAY TO REALLY DRIVE THE
IDEAS THAT CAN GIVE US
SOLUTIONS- SO WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BROADER ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
I THINK THERE ARE MANY WAYS FOR
PEOPLE TO ENGAGE AND CANDIDLY I
THINK ONE OF THE BEST IS TO
ENGAGE WITH ALL OF YOU BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE ARE WORKING ON A
REVISION OF THE BUDGET ONLY
GETS ENACTED ONCE YOU SHAPE AND
APPROVE IT SO I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE CONSTANT CONVERSATION.
WITH YOU ARE HAPPY TO ALSO TAKE
BACK YOUR FEEDBACK ON AYE
DESCRIBING OR PUTTING TOGETHER
ANY SORT OF MORE FORMAL
VEHICLES ARE MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE MECHANISMS
AGAINST THE BACK- TO THE POLICY
MAKERS AND MARK UP YOU WANT TO
ADD. THE ONLY THING I WOULD I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THAT I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS WE LOOK
AT THE SIX INDICATORS THAT THE
GOVERNOR OUTLINED AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF. THIS BUILDING OUT
THOSE SIX INDICATORS AND
DELIVERING ON THE STATE'S
INTEREST IS BOTH OUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ON A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES SITE BUT ALSO WITH THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR MORE GENERALLY INDICATOR
FIVE IN PARTICULAR IS AROUND
LOOKING AT- THE VARIOUS SECTORS
OF OUR ECONOMY AND I THINK THAT
IS AN AREA WHERE WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING TO ENGAGE WITH- I WRITE
YOU DIFFERENT ENTITIES REALLY
HELPED SHAPE. OUR THINKING ON
THOSE ASPECTS MORE BURKE AS WE
BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT IS THAT
THE POINT THAT I ALLUDED TO
EARLIER AS WE BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS TO
VARIOUS SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY
SO THAT THEY CAN SAFELY OF
BEGIN THE RE OPENING PROCESS
IT'S GONNA BE VERY OF OUR PRICE
TO ENGAGE WITH AND WHY OUR.
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS TO HELP
INFORM RIGHT THINKING AROUND.
HOW THERE WAS AND START MEANS
REALLY LOOK LIKE. AT IT'S
ESSENTIAL. HOW DO YOU DO CENTER
CHECKER WE DO NEED TO DO SOME.
I HOW ARE YOU GOING TO DELIVER
AN PHYSICAL. CALL FROM. WORKER
SIDE BUT ALSO FROM A CONSUMER
SIDE RECORD. SITE SOMEONE WAS
INTO A- PARTICULAR BUSINESS.
AND THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED A
CONTEMPLATING AND I THINK YOU
POINTED OUT VERY WELL. THAT
LIFE. IS LIKELY NOT GET AT. IT
AS WE MODIFIED THE STATE IN
ORDER THINGS ARE NOT GOING TO.
IMMEDIATELY GO BACK TO HOW THEY
WERE IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME TIME
FOR US TO GETTO THAT POINT.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE ON ALL OF
US TO THINK ABOUT. I WHAT WE
CAN DO TO CONTRIBUTE BACK IT
CERTAINLY. THERE ARE PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY BUT WE AND- AND CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS TO HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY
IN THAT AND SO. I THINK I'LL BE
UPON ALL OF US TO THINK ABOUT.
HOW WE ARE IN DANGER. I
APPRECIATE. YOU SPENDING SOME
TIME DIG INTO THAT. I MENTIONED
LAST MONDAY- IN OUR PREVIOUS
OVERSIGHT HEARING THAT- MYSELF
IN THE SPEAKER HAD AUTHORED A
LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR- REGARD
THE TASK FORCES ARE GETTING
LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT AND-
CHAIRMAN TAKING CHAIRMAN WHAT
OTHERS HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THAT. I BELIEVE
WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING A TASK
FORCE CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE MINISTRATION- IN
THE NEAR FUTURE HERE- IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS AND I'LL BE
RAISING THESE ISSUES IN THAT
TASK FORCE- AND IN THAT
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE EXECUTIVE
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN DEVELOP A
WAY TO BOTH CREATE SOME
REGULATORY RELIEF AS WAS
DISCUSSED- ENGAGE IN A BLUE NEW
DEAL AS FAR AS HEALTH CARE-
INVESTMENT- AND OF COURSE
TAPPED THE EXPERTISE OF ALL
CALIFORNIA- AS WELL AS HOLDING
OUR BANKS ACCOUNTABLE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE
TODAY- AND ALL YOU'LL BACK TO
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
GREAT JUST WANT TO MAKE A NOTE
AGAIN- I KNOW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN LA- CAN STAY ON BUT
ALL THE OTHER PANELISTS HAVE TO
LEAVE. SO DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. MR THE MOST NEXT TO
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR THE
PANELISTS SAID MISSISSAUGA
MISLIM ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND SO I WILL START ACTUALLY
WITH MY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE
OTHER PANELISTS FIRST I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT THAT TO US MR
FONG- FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE TALKED
ABOUT ONE HIS FIRST POINTS
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS. FOR
SCHOOLS- BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC TO RE OPEN AND THAT THAT
WAS AN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
THING- A FOR EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
SO MANY OF OUR PARENTS. ARE OR
WORKING AND SO I HOPE THAT IN
THE BUDGET SUB TO HEARING
TOMORROW- WE WILL DELVE INTO
THAT BUT I DON'T WANT THAT TO
BE LOST IN THIS CONVERSATION
HOW MANY PARENTS- ARE WORKING.
AT HOME WILL STILL NEED TO WORK
FROM HOME BECAUSE SCHOOLS WILL
NOT BE OPEN AND I THINK IT'S
PART O THAT IS RECOVERY FOR
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
HAVE TO BE PART OF THAT
CRITICAL CONVERSATION SO THANK
YOU FOR. FOR ADDING THAT AND IF
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC THINGS TO ADD
I WOULD WELCOME HEARING THOSE
SINCE I'M NOT SURE YOU WILL BE
ON. OUR PANEL TOMORROW AND FOR
BUDGET SUB TO. IT'S MISTER FUNG
SO LONGER HE'S- OKAY. SO NOT
ONLY CAN HE CAN FEND THEM THEN
THERE WE HAVE IT THE OTHER
QUESTION THAT- I HAD WHICH WAS
MORE. BROAD IN IT IT'S ACTUALLY
A SOMEWHAT RELATED TO THE
COMMENT- THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MODESTO MADE WHICH IS- IT IN
TIMES LIKE THIS- IT IS.
SOMETIMES A CRITICAL FOR US TO
LOOK AT WHAT WE COULD DO BETTER
AND SO- YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED A
LOT AS A CHAIR BANKING ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- A BUT
IT'S NOT LOST ON ME THAT A
CONSUMER IS. EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT'S LIVING IN THE
STATE AND- IT DURING THIS TIME
WE HAVE HEARD FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES BIG BUSINESSES-
INDIVIDUALS. IT'S NOT JUST
RELATED TO A LOAN OR WHAT A
BANK IS IT'S RELATED TO FEES
IT'S RELATED TO GETTING A HOLD
OF SOMEONE- A AND I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW- AND PERHAPS. MISTER
NICHOLS BERG CAN COMMENT THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS WE
NEED A PLACE- AND IT IS THIS IS
NOT TO SAY THAT FINANCE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS- HAVE
NOT- TRYING TO DO SOMETHING BUT
I THINK IT'S CLEAR. WHERE WE'VE
MISSED THE MARK- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW- BUT
AS YOU KNOW I'VE HAD COLLEAGUES
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS
IS NOT EVEN A REGIONAL ISSUE
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TALK
ABOUT- WELL WHY CAN'T WE DO
THIS WHY CAN'T WE DO THAT AND
ASKING FOR MORE TO BE DE. FOR
THE- CAL. THAT LOOK FOR SO SORT.
SO I AM ONE IF YOU CAN. MORE
BROUGH. ON THIS THAT UPPER. HIS
STORE WE SEEN OUR THAT WE TAKE.
IT SEE WHICH CAN AS STATE. IF
ARE GO NOT TO. AT. SEC THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I AM NOT
AN EXPERT IN- IN FINANCIAL
PROTECTION. FOR CONSUMERS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THE BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT THIS IS A- TIME IF WE
SEIZE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE
SOME FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES AND-
AND SO ONE THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO YOU NEED TO TALK ABOUT
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE ONE THING
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT IS THAT
THIS RECOVERY IS GOING TO BE A
SYMMETRIC IT'S GOING TO BE MORE
RAPIDLY IN SOME SECTORS AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO EXIST IN
OTHERS AND I TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT- THE LOW WITH EACH SECTOR
OF. LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY AND
RETAIL AT THE SECTORS OF BIG
GOING TO BE GROWING OUR
MANUFACTURING. CONSTRUCTION
TECHNOLOGY AND HEALTH CARE IT
IS SO I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. AB HELP THE WHO
ARE NOT GOING TO RECOVER THEIR
EMPLOYMENT IN THE DECLINING
SECTORS. THE MOVIE INTO HIGHER
WAGE SECTORS. IT AND- SO THAT'S
NOT AN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT FINANCIAL PROTECTION- BUT
JUST AN ILLUSTRATION OF HOW YOU
KNOW THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME BUT IT IS A TIME WHEN WE
CAN REALLY THINK ABOUT. WHAT
SHOULD THE STRUCTURE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS BE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE RECOVERY. THANK YOU AND NAY
IF ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANYTHING TO
ADD I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SOME OF REAL
CONCERN I KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT- HAS KEPT
VERY BUSY AND TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ROLE CALIFORNIA
CAN PLAY- TO BETTER TRANSITION
THE SUPPORT. AT AND NEED AND
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR ALL OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
CONSTITUENTS IN INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT. PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION I KNOW THAT- AT
ONE TIME THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN ENHANCE
SOME OF THIS SUPPORT THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT AND I HOPE THAT- IN
LIGHT OF THIS- WE DON'T NEED
LESS WE NEED. OUR CONSTITUENTS
NEED MORE SUPPORT- AT TO HELP
THEM AND THE OTHER PIECE THAT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU KNOW AND AS
THE CHAIR OF THE NONPROFIT
SELECT COMMITTEE IS WHAT ABOUT
NONPROFIT THEY ARE A TYPE OF
BUSINESS AND THEY ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH. LARGEST
EMPLOYER I'M IN THIS STATE SO
WHAT ARE WE DOING AT TO HELP
NONPROFIT AND WHAT AT CAN'T DO
A I SO STAR WITH PANEL THAT NOT
NOT. THE AT SEE IF IT WHEN
STILL A ON THE CALL THAT CAN IN
ON WE SHOULD BE THINKING OF AS
A FUNCTION BILL. AND OUR
COMMUNITY. AND MAYBE THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF FOLKS LEFT BETTER.
ON THE CALL. CAN YOU HEAR US.
YEAH WE WERE WE WERE ON MUTE-
SO- ENGAGING WITH NON PROFITS
IS DEFINITELY AT KEY PART OF
OUR STRATEGY I'LL JUST OUTLINED
A COUPLE WAYS AND THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MARCO AS WELL MAY WE
WANT TO SPEAK I THINK THE
FIRST- WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF
OUR FEDERAL ADVOCACY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE AID THAT WE
GET FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- BOOK DIRECTLY TO
THE STATE BUT ALSO- JUST
GENERAL A THAT'S GOING OUT FROM
CONGRESS. IS GOING TO NON
PROFITS AS WELL AND SO I THINK
IT IS WE TALKED ABOUT THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
ALREADY BUT WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT NON PROFITS ARE
ELIGIBLE I NOT ONLY ELIGIBLE
BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
THE ACCESS THAT THEY EAT WHEN
IT COMES TO SPECIFICALLY TO THE
STATE LEVEL I THINK WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF EFFORTS AT FIRST OUT
WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE TO RESET DESCRIBED IN
THE HEARING. LAST WEEK GOT MANY
OF THEM WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS
LIKE SUPPORTING FOOD BANKS AND
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE GET THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED- THOSE CLUBS
ARE NOT PROFITS PERHAPS- ON A
DIFFERENT SCALE- THE GOVERNOR'S
AT SENIOR ADVISER ON SOCIAL
INNOVATION KATHLEEN KELLY
JANICE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WITH- YES
WITH HHS I'M TRYING TO. GET AS
MUCH SUPPORT AS WE CAN FROM
OUTSIDE THERE IS- NON PROFITS
AND OTHER COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND ENTITIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
NUMBER ONE STEPPING UP WITH ALL
THE RESOURCES WE CAN BRING TO
BEAR TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND
MORE IMPORTANT NUMBER TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE COORDINATED
AND I THINK YOU SAW THAT WITH
THE RELIEF- THAT THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK. OR
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATIONS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY WERE LEFT OUT OF
A LOT OF THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THAT PASSED
CONGRESS AND SO SOME OF THAT
WAS A COMMITMENT OF STATE
DOLLARS BUT SOME OF IT WAS ALSO.
PRIVATE SECTOR NOT PROP DOLLARS
AS WELL. SO MAY SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL WORKING TOGETHER IS STEP. A
BIG PART OF THE STRATEGY AND
WERE VERY CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT
THAT. EVEN THOUGH THE AD
GENERAL FUND BUDGET THAT WE'RE
ALL THINKING UP FOR THE NAY
REVISION AND THAT. ALL OF YOU
WILL BE WEIGHING IN ON HOW IT'S
ALLOCATED IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS AND MONTHS- THAT IS THE
PRODUCT OF STATE REVENUES AND
FEDERAL FUNDING. WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
STRATEGY OR YOU THAT'S
INCORPORATING ALL THE ACTORS.
ABLE AND PARKER THERE'S
ANYTHING YOU WANT THAT YEAH I
MEAN I THINK I'VE BEEN BACK-
WAS. RESPONSE IN TERMS OF HOW
WE ARE LEVERAGING WHETHER IT BE
IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FACE IN PARTICULAR AYE
WE ACT. PRIOR TO THIS WE HAVE
ENGAGED ARE VERY. HAPPILY WORK
OUR PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS- AND
WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT IN THE
SPACE I THINK. MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE THE LINEMEN- AND
LEVERAGING- THEIR INFORMATION
AS WELL AS THEIR- ABILITY TO
GET INTO THE COMMUNITY TO HELP.
AYE AYES WITH REGARDS TO
MESSAGING BUT ALSO HAVE. BEEN
PROVIDED SPEED BACKGROUND I WE
GET IT RIGHT OR IMPROVE WITH
REGARDS RESPONSE ACTIVITIES IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT FACTOR.
IN HOW WE DO BUSINESS SO I
DIDN'T GET. I YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON AS WE-
CONTINUE WITH THIS RESPONSE. SO
I WANTED. THE IN THE REMARKS
AROUND THAT I THINK IT'S AN-
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TIME WE TALK ABOUT NON PROFITS
AND WE HAVE NON PROFITS LIKE A
FOOD BANK O LIKE THE
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH- NONPROFITS
IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
KAISER IS A NONPROFIT SO THE
SCOPE OF NONPROFIT THIS HUGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND
WHILE WE COULD TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE PARTNERSHIPS. NOT ALL
ARE IN THE POSITION OF
PHILANTHROPY THAT IS ONE
SECTION OR ONE SECTOR OF THE
NONPROFIT INDUSTRY AND SO-
THERE IS STILL MUCH TO DO
BECAUSE AS THE FOURTH LARGEST
EMPLOYER OF THIS STATE
NONPROFITS NOT BEING ABLE TO.
KEEP FOLKS EMPLOYED- EIGHT IS
GOING TO BE A VERY BIG ISSUE-
AND THIS IS SIMILAR TO I THINK
SOME OF THECOMMENTS I'VE HEARD
RELATED TO THE FIFTY MILLION
RELATED TO THAT I THINK. THAT
THAT IS A GOOD START BUT AT AN
END AND CERTAINLY THE SUPPORT
THAT WE'VE GIVEN TO OUR AND
DOCUMENTED- ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IS AN INCREDIBLE START BUT IT'S
GOING TO LEAVE HOLES THAT AND
NEEDS THAT ARE AND MATT SO
WHETHER IT'S A SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT DIDN'T GET PPP. AT BEING
ABLE OR NOT BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS SOME OF THE FUNDS IN THE
AYE BANK IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
RELATIVELY THAT MUCH FOR THE
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
WE HAVE AND SO- I A THINK THAT
I HOPE WE TRANSITION FROM
CHECKING OFF A BOX AND ST WE
DID THIS FOR THIS GROUP THIS
FOR THE OTHER GROUP- TO ALSO
START TO THINK ABOUT WE HAVE
UNMET NEEDS AND GAPS THAT. ARE
STILL NOT THERE AND WE SHOULD
BE RECOGNIZED FOR BEING LEADERS
AND THE FIRST- AND MAYBE THE
ONLY STATE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
IS DOING SOME OF THESE THINGS
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY NOT GOING T
BE ENOUGH BASED ON WHAT MEMBERS
ARE SEEN WHAT PUTTING TOGETHER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- SO
YOU KNOW I ADD THAT THERE AND
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT IS
FULL RESPONSIBILITY THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- IT SHOULD HAVE A
ROLE IN SHOULD BE CHIMING IN ON
HOW WE NEED SOME OF THOSE AND-
IT NEEDS. BUT RECOGNIZE THAT
WHILE THIS IS A GREAT STEP AND
THESE ARE GREAT FIGHT FIRST AND
THEY PUT CALIFORNIA THE LEAD.
THERE IS STILL MORE TO DO
BECAUSE WE HAVE SERIOUS UNMET
NEEDS FOR ALL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES- SO. I BELIEVE THAT
THERE IN IN TERMS OF NON
PROFITS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MODESTO ALSO TALKED ABOUT AND
THAT THE RATIO TO MEDICAL
PROVIDERS IN COMMUNITIES AND
SOMETIMES I THINK ON THAT- YOU
KNOW ON THE- OUTER LEVEL WE
DON'T THINK THAT COMMUNITIES
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE MODESTO OR
SANTA BARBARA MIGHT HAVE A LOT
IN COMMON. BUT IT TURNS OUT
THAT ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE-
IT'S HITTING COMMUNITIES VERY
HARD- AND I THINK THAT THIS
IDEA THAT CERTAIN COMMUNITIES-
WHO MIGHT BE QUOTE UNQUOTE
BETTER OFFER NOT BETTER OFF.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT MIGHT BE
IMPACTED IN DIFFERENT WAYS- IT
TURNS OUT THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
MEDICAL SERVICES AND PROVIDERS-
WE HAVE REAL CONCERNS AND A LOT
OF SIMILARITIES- SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE-
METROPOLITAN. URBAN AREA LIKE
SOME OF THE BIG CITIES DO. AND
WHEN I WATCH- COMMUNITY CLINICS
LIKE SAMPSON THAT PROVIDES ONE.
THIRD OF THE ENTIRE CAL ANNE'S.
MEDI CAL SERVICES- THAT IS NOW
FIFTEEN MILLION- INTO THEIR
LINE OF CREDIT THAT IS GOING
DOWN- AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE I THINK OF THE
SIMILARITIES THAT. ARE COUNTY
HAS WITH COUNTIES LIKE
STANISLAUS RIGHT WHERE YOU'RE
LIKE WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO IF
YOU DON'T HAVE INDIVIDUALS. ARE
HEALTHY THEY CANNOT GO BACK TO
WORK AND WE ARE WATCHING. OUR
MEDICAL. AID YOU KNOW CENTERS-
REALLY BE CRIPPLED AND
CERTAINLY LAST YOU KNOW WEEKS
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE- SOME OF THE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES AND SELECT TO US
SURGERIES IS GOING TO HELP. BUT
IT GOES BACK TO MY PREVIOUS
COMMENT THAT WHILE WE CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME OF THIS
HELPS IT DOESN'T SOLVE FOR THE
PROBLEM. SO I THINK I HAVE
HEARD EXAMPLES ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF MEDICAL PROVIDERS
WHO ARE SEEN THEMSELVES- ON THE
VERGE OF GOING DOWN NOT KNOWING
IF THEY WILL BE ABLE TO EXIST
AND ALSO LEGISLATORS
RECOGNIZING THAT WITHOUT THEM.
WE CANNOT CARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY THERE IS NO WAY THAT
EVERY SINGLE HOSPITAL IN THIS
STATE CAN PICK UP- AND SOLVE
FOR THE ABSENCE OF MEDICAL
CENTERS AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROVIDERS BOTH ARE CRITICALLY
NEEDED. SO I'M WONDERING IF THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COMMENT ON
MORE THOUGHTS BESIDES WHAT WAS
DONE LAST WEEK AND THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WAS DONE LAST
WEEK ON WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
BUT TO PROVIDE. SUPPORT TO
COMMUNITIES OF ALL DIFFERENT
SHAPES SIZES COLORS EVERYTHING
I'M IN THE STATE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE ADAM DORSEY. I
THINK- SIMILAR TO SOME OF OUR
CURRENT COMMENTS THAT YOU KNOW
I THINK THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
THE FEDERAL RESOURCES REALLY
KIND OF NEED TO BE BROUGHT TO
BEAR TO STABILIZE THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND- I THINK
THAT WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE IN
THAT. KERR'S ACTOR AND GAVE
PROVIDE FUNDING THAT OUR
PROVIDERS ARE BEING ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. AND WE
LEARNED THIS MORNING OF A
SECOND BATCH OF FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO-
DOES THE BAND IN IN THE
BILLIONS- ANSWER WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT. WILL REALLY IS HER
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE IN THE
SHORT TERM AND REALLY. HELPING
TO STABILIZE THE SYSTEM- AND SO
THAT IS WHERE OUR EFFORTS ALL
RIGHT NOW. AND IT WAS-
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL- SO FOUR
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS AN
OUNCE TODAY- IN ADDITION. TO
SEVERAL BILLION THAT WERE
ANNOUNCED- JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO. AND BUT WE ARE GOING TO
LET THAT PROCESS AND KIND OF
WORK THROUGH THE SYSTEM
STABILIZE THE SYSTEM. AND THEN
EVALUATE WHERE WE ARE FROM
THERE AND JR FEDERAL PARTNERS
YOU TAKES STEPS EVEN FURTHER IF
YOU HELP STABILIZE THAT THE
SYSTEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU AND I THINK THAT TO
US. I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING LOOKING AT
HEALTH PLANS- PROVIDING SELECT
SERVICES AT THE THOUGHT THAT
THEY THE CENTERS AND MEDICAL
CENTERS WHO WRITES LIKE
SERVICES- PERHAPS- YOU KNOW
BANKING ON EARLY PAYMENTS FOR
MEDICARE MEDIC HAL-
REIMBURSEMENTSARE LINE OF
CREDITS ARE GOING TO SOLVE FOR
ALL OF THIS SO I IT JUST AGAIN.
I WANT TO SAY THAT THERE'S NO
DOUBT I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE ADMINISTRATION
IS WORKING SO INCREDIBLY HARD-
ON THIS I A THINK IT'S JUST A-
I'M NOT AS CONVINCED THAT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING IS GOING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM- FULLY I
WISH IT WORK- BUT TO AT. A
THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO HAVE
TO WORK TOGETHER INCLUDING
LEGISLATORS. AND MY FINAL.
QUESTION THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE CUT TOPIC THAT CAME UP LAST
WEEK AND I'M WONDERING IF THE
ADMINISTRATION PERHAPS HAS MORE
INFORMATION- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
WITH POPULATIONS CENTS LESS
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
LOCAL COUNTY GOVERNMENTS WITH
POPULATIONS LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THE SAME LEVEL OF
SUPPORT AND LOCAL- LARGER
GOVERNMENTS SO WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT- ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY
FOR IT THESE COUNTIES- THERE
ARE MANY OUT IN THE STATE. AND
pAND THE COMMENT WAS MADE THAT
PERHAPS- YOU FOR THE MAY REVISE
WE WOULD HAVE MORE INFORMATION
AND I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE DO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION IN THE
LAST WEEK. I'M WHAT WE CAN TELL
OUR COUNTIES AND THAT DID NOT
RECEIVE THIS DIRECT FUNDING. WE
CONTINUE TO BE FOCUSED ON WE
KNOW ESPECIALLY WITH COUNTIES-
WE ARE- YOU KNOW THE STATE AND
LOCALS ARE YOUR PARTNER SO
CLOSELY IN TERMS OF THESE KEY.
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS AND
THAT OF THE OVERALL FIFTEEN
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WAS PART OF THE CARE IS
ABSENT A CORONA VIRUS OR WE
FIND AT NINE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS I WAS ALLOCATED TO THE
STATE- AND THEN THE BALANCE AS
YOU MENTIONED WAS ALLOCATED TO.
I BELIEVE TWENTY ONE NOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COUNTIES AND
CITIES. I THINK. WHAT WE AT.
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES IS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SPENDING
THOSE DOLLARS IN A WAY THAT
BENEFITS. THE WHOLE STATE SO UP
UNTIL THE GOVERNOR MAKES HIS
DECISIONS AND PUTS OUT HIS
PROPOSAL WE CAN'T GIVE A
SPECIFIC BREAKDOWN ON HOW THOSE
DOLLARS WILL BE SPENT BECAUSE
THE GOVERNOR HASN'T MADE THAT
DECISION YET. IT'S ALSO A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WHILE WE WANT
TO DO AND ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN HELP
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
COUNTIES CITIES. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE ALSO HAVE A
HISTORIC BUDGET GAP THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO CLOSE HERE WITH ALL
OF YOU ON THE STATE LEVEL AND
AS YOU MUCH OF A BEGINNING
THERE WILL BE SOME VERY PAINFUL
DECISIONS. THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE- BUT I THE GOVERNOR'S
FISCAL PLAN WILL BE OUT ON MAY
FOURTEENTH AND THEN I KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE WAY. THANK
YOU AND I DO THINK THAT- FOR A
FIFTY EIGHT STATE COUNTY- I
HOPE WE DON'T LEAVE- THE
COUNTIES WITH UNDER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE BEHIND-
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO. DO AS BEST WE CAN
TO HELP THOSE COUNTIES WHICH IS
A LOT OF THEM. AND BE ABLE TO
RECOVER AS WELL SO I WANT TO
ADD THAT AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'RE DOING. I KNOW THESE ARE
TOUGH DIFFICULT QUESTIONS- AND
WE AS LEGISLATORS ARE THE
VOICES FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT EVERYONE IS WORKING AS
HARD AS WE CAN- BUT- I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RAISE THE
MORE DIFFICULT AND COMPLICATED
QUESTIONS ON BEHALF OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISTER BERLIN
THE DOCTOR RIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. OF MY FIRST
QUESTION IS FOR MARCO AT HHS-
KIND OF FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT
DOCTOR WOULD RAISE ABOUT TO PEE
PEE AND AN OPENING UP THE
ECONOMY- OVER THE WEEKEND I
SPOKE WITH SOME EMERGENCY ROOM.
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER DOCTORS
AND- ONE POINT THEY BROUGHT UP
WAS THAT IN OTHER EPIDEMICS-
THEY INSTITUTED WHAT'S CALLED
UNIVERSAL PROTECTIONS. AND WHEN
THOSE UNIVERSAL PROTECTIONS.
WERE IMPLEMENTED IN A PHYSICIAN
OFFICES COMMERCIAL FISHING
BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS COULD
OPEN UP ARE YOU LOOKING ARE YOU
WORKING WITH COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS TO. IMPLEMENT ANYTHING
LIKE WE DID IN THE PAST
REGARDING THESE UNIVERSAL
PROTECTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS IS MARK A MAJOR THE
HELPING IMAGE SERVICES AGENCY I
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH UNIVERSAL
PROTECTIONS FOR SAY SO I WOULD
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IS WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THE HEALTH
EXECUTIVE I TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DEVELOPING GUIDANCE
TOGETHER AROUND- HOW WE RE OPEN
VERY SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY SO
I THAT IS A CLOSE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE STATE AND OUR
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH PARTNERS-
AND I WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU IN YOUR SEEM TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- THIS PARTICULAR
COMPONENT THAT YOU REFERENCED
HERE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MARK A LOOK FOR TO SPEAK ABOUT
FURTHER ON THIS- A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE- WE HEARD
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING THAT
RESTAURANT WORKERS WERE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION OF THE
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS- EIGHT
ARE YOU LOOKING AT ANYTHING
LIKE SUSPENDING THE MINIMUM
WAGE- TO HELP BUSINESSES AS
THEY RE OPEN OR- THE- TIP
CREDIT. FOR HOURLY WORKERS OR
PAYROLL TAX- WAIVER OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO
ME IF. IF ONE POINT ONE MILLION
ARE THESE RESTAURANT WORKERS-
DOING THINGS LIKE THAT COULD
GET THEM IMMEDIATE. IMMEDIATELY
BACK TO WORK AND ACTUALLY
PROBABLY A PAY RAISE AND GET
THEM OFF OF UNEMPLOYMENT OR ARE
YOU LOOKING AT ANY IDEAS LIKE
THE- SO THIS IS THE VEGAS WHAT.
THEM FROM THAT OF FINANCE- WHEN
IT COMES TO THE MINIMUM WAGE-
THERE'S A PROCESS OUTLINED BY
LAW IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
DETERMINATION IS MADE. WHETHER
A MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE GOES
INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY FIRST OF
THE FOLLOWING YEAR- SAID THAT
WILL BE DECIDED IN THE WEEKS
AND MONTHS I'VE HAD- SO I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANYTHING TO SHARE.
ON THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION RIGHT
NOW WHAT I CAN SAY IS A NUMBER
ONE NOT ONLY IS- THE HELP THAT
GONNA RESTAURANT WORKERS IN A
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. A PRIORITY
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY NUMBER TWO AND YOU
KNOW MY COLLEAGUE ENDORSES ON
THE LINE. AB ONE TO SPEAK WITH
THIS UP THE MAIN PURPOSE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT THE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED LAST FRIDAY WITH
REGARD CHEST SENIOR MEALS WAS
TO MAKE SURE. THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE AGE SIXTY FIVE AND ABOVE
FOR WHAT IN A LONER MAYBE WITH
ONE OTHER PERSON I BLOW A
CERTAIN INCOME LEVEL I CAN GET
THAT HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS MEALS
IN THE SUPPORT THEY NEED AT A
TIME WHEN. WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE
TO STAY AT HOME- BUT A
SECONDARY PURPOSE TODAY WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT HE'S RESTAURANTS
AND BETTER. CAN PROVIDING THIS
GOOD ARE ALSO GETTING THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO EXPAND
THAT NEXT WE'RE NOT ONLY
HELPING THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
SERVICE. OR ALSOBOLSTERING THE
WORKERS AND THE PEOPLE IN THE
STREET SO I DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT PROGRAMS ON THE
MINIMUM WAGE NOTHING TO SAY
RIGHT NOW BUT CERTAINLY IT'S A
QUESTION YET BUT YOU KNOW THAT
BY WILL. BACK YOUR FEEDBACK THE
ADMINISTRATION. HAS ALSO. THANK
YOU YOU CAN SMALL GUIDANCE ON
THAT. MY I BELIEVE SEE SIXTY A
DAY FOR RESTAURANTS HAD A LOT
OF PEOPLE READ OUT TO ME. THAT
WAS AND BY THE GOVERNOR. THE
LAST WEEK SO IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE US MORE INFORMATION
I'LL PEOPLE PUT COULD
PARTICIPATE IN THAT. I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YES I
KNOW MORE INFORMATION IS GUY
WILL BE COMING IN THE COMING
DAYS SO YOU KNOW WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON DAIS. YOU
KNOW WE KNOW IT'S ENERGY I SURE
AND WE ARE WE WILL BE PUSHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
QUESTION OR A COMMENT. OR
SUGGESTION FOR LA L. THE LAST
TIME WE WENT THROUGH THIS NONE
OF US WERE HERE- PERHAPS. A
COMMENT IF YOU IF YOU DON'T
KNOW THE HISTORY. NOT RIGHT OFF
THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD BUT- MAYBE
YOU COULD PRODUCE A REPORT. OF
WHAT ACTIONS WERE TAKEN IN. TWO
THOUSAND NINE IN THE LAST
CRISIS- AND MAYBE SOME ANALYSIS
OF WHAT. PROGRAMS WORKED WHAT
DIDN'T WOR TO HELP US AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THIS YEAR WAS.
MUCH OF A COMMENT ON THAT.
CERTAINLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON
WHAT. I DID AND THEN WE CAN
ALSO PROVIDE SOME OF OUR
PREVIOUSLY WRITTEN ANALYSIS
RESPOND ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THAT BUT THE
LAST TIME WHEN THE STAGE STATE
WAS FACING A LRGE FISCAL
BUDGET PROBLEM. THIS SOLUTIONS
COMPRISED A COMBINATION OF-
INCREASE FEDERAL AID. THROUGH
THE STIMULUS ACT. THIS STATE IN
YOUR LIFE. INTERNAL BORROWING
AND ENGAGED IN PAYMENT
DEFERRALS- THOSE RESULTED AND
SUBSEQUENT YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN TURN THE BUT
WHILE. OVER THE SUBSEQUENT
YEARS IN THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
PART OF OUR REVENUE GROWTH WENT
TO PAYING DOWN SOME OF THOSE-
THOSE BUDGETARY DEBTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ACCUMULATED BUT IT WAS
REALLY A COMBINATION OF THOSE
KIND OF. ONE TIME MEASURES AND
THEN OF COURSE THERE WERE ALSO
SOME ONGOING REDUCTIONS TO
PROGRAMS THAT THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE TIME SOME OF THEM ARE
RESTORED BUT NOT ALL OF THEM
AND SO- IT ONE OTHER AREA WAS
THAT A RIVER. SOME REDUCTIONS
IN PARTICULAR TO THE SCHOOL- K.
FOURTEEN FUNDING- AND A LOT OF
BILLS THAT SPEEDING SO WHERE IT
SHEET THROUGH THE DEFERRAL SOME
OF THE STATE PAYMENTS TO THE
SCHOOLS SO. IN A WAY IT SHIFTED
SOME OF THE CASH FLOW
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGE. FROM THE
STATE TO THE SCHOOLS. BUT I IT
WAS REAL A COMBO OF AND I KNOW
HAVE DONE WORK ON THEM. HAPPY
TO PROVIDE THE PALACES ARE NOT
THAT TO YOU GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- ONE QUESTION OVERLOOKED
FOR FINANCE. ONE INDUSTRY
THAT'S REALLY BEEN STEPPING UP
IN THESE TIMES IS- PRIVATE
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES OFTEN
MALIGNED INDUSTRY- HAVE LAUGHED
AND MANUFACTURED ALL OVER THE
WORLD AND I THINK IT'S PRETTY
EVIDENT NOW THAT WE ARE- HELD
HOSTAGE TO SOME COUNTRIES AND
CAN'T GET PRODUCTS. THIS
ADMINISTRATION CAN OFFER ANY
INCENTIVES TO LURE THESE
MANUFACTURERS OF P. PEAS AND
VACCINES AND TESTING- TO COME
BACK TO CALIFORNIA AND HIGHER
CALIFORNIANS. HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS MARKHAM EACH
AGAIN WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES SO- WE
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL BACK NOW I
MEAN I THINK WE ARE ACTIVELY
CONSTANTLY ASSESSING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- BALLS WITH
REGARDS TO- THE P. P. E. S.
CERTAINLY HAVE. AS WELL AS THAT
THE PHARMACEUTICAL PIECES THIS
IS BOTH RELATED TO DRUGS THAT
ARE. AVAILABLE NOW BUT ALSO
DRAGS THAT MIGHT BE IN
SHORTAGE- AND THEN CERTAINLY
WERE PAYING VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION. TO ROWS THAT ARE HOW.
AROUND A POTENTIAL TREATMENT
FOR KOBE NINETEEN AND THE
IMPACT THAT MIGHT HAVE AS WELL
AS A VACCINE THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE- BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR RIGHT
NOW I DID SPEAK TO THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU BUT MY FINAL QUESTION
IS. WELL FIRST STATEMENT THAT
THE BIGGEST THE BIGGEST ISSUE
IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE RIGHT NOW
IS A TWO DAY- CALLS COMING IN.
MAY FIRST IS COMING AND I KNOW
THIS HEARING IS ABOUT LOOKING
FORWARD AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TAKEN CARE OF RIGHT
NOW AND FRIDAYS MAY FIRST THEIR
BILLS ARE DUE. HOW CAN MY
OFFICE AND OTHERS GET HELP I
MEAN THERE'S PEOPLE FROM APRIL
EARLY APRIL THAT. THAT FILED I
KNOW THEY'RE OVERWHELMED BUT-
YOU KNOW MY CASE WORKER IN THE
DISTRICT OFFICE CAN'T EVEN GET
THROUGH TO A NEEDY PERSON- IN
THE LEDGER OFFICE HOW CAN WE
GET SOME HELP. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IS THAT NEED TO GET
THEIR CHECKS NOW- RATHER THAN
TRYING TO STABILIZE THEM IN THE
FUTURE. LAKE I'LL JUST SAY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT KNOWS
THIS IS AN ISSUE AND IS REALLY
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN RIGHT
NOW INCLUDING. A SIGNING YOU
KNOW OVER A THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
WORKERS FOR ET DE CALL CENTERS
AND THAT THE LABOR SECRETARY
JULIE STALEY HOSTED A CHAT LAST
FRIDAY. EXPLAINING YOU KNOW
WHAT'S IN THE ISSUES ARE AND
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DEALING WITH THEM SO. VERY
FOCUSED ON THIS NO IT'S AN
ISSUE WE ARE FACING- WE KNOW
THAT THAT TECHNOLOGY CAN ALWAYS
BE IMPROVED OR ALSO LIKE YOU
MENTIONED JUST TRYING TO GET
THROUGH THE NEXT SEVERAL DAYS
AND WEEKS- DEALING WITH THAT
HISTORIC LEVEL OF UNEMPLOYMENT
AND AT. STORK WE SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME- SO DEFINITELY- WE WANT
TO KEEP- HEARING THE FEEDBACK
THAT YOU HAVE AND WE'RE GONNA
CAN TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING. THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THANKS SO MUCH I KNOW
EVERYBODY'S OVERWHELMED DURING
THESE TIMES BUT- IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET THESE PEOPLE TO
**** OUT OF WORK FOR. FIVE SIX
WEEKS YOU KNOW SOME MONEY RIGHT
NOW TO KEEP ON GOING. THAT
CONCLUDES MY QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU
WERE GOING TO GO DOWN TO THE
DOCTOR REGULAR AND THEN MISSED
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- IF I CAN START WITH AGAIN
I JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SAFETY MAN.
ESPECIALLY NOW. OUR INVESTMENTS
IN OUR ECONOMY. AND WE NEED TO
IDENTIFY WHICH CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS WE CAN SUPPORT.
WHICH WILL HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. MY
FIRST QUESTION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT ACCESS TO THE SAFETY NOT
SUPPORTS. I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND IF I COULD FROM YOU.
ARE PEOPLE IN FAMILIES ABLE TO
ACCESS SAFETY NET PROGRAMS SUCH
AS CAL WORKS AND CAL FRESH.
DURING THE CRISIS. NOW THAT
COUNTY OFFICES ARE CURRENTLY
CLOSED. AND HOW IS THE
APPLICATION. PROCESS SEES
WORKING AND WHAT DOES THE
VOLUME LOOK LIKE. AT THE
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ADAM DORSEY AND THEN MARCO.
WELL. BARBARA FINANCE SO- YOU
KNOW ONE THING I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
BEFORE HEADING UP HHS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
MAKING SURE WERE THAT WE WERE-
YOU KNOW PREPARE JUST SORT OF
HANDLE THE INFLUX OF CASES
GIVEN THE PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE
FACING AND SO WE DID SEND A
SECTION THIRTY SIX REQUEST
LEGISLATURE- THAT PROVIDED MORE
FUNDS TO YOU COUNTIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN PROCESS
APPLICATIONS- THE AND THAT'S
REALLY TRUE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER- COUNTY OFFICES WERE
OPENED AND THAT WORKERS WERE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO- TO
CONTINUE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AS THEY CAME IN.
SO THAT THAT'S BEEN A GREAT A
CRITICAL STEP THAT WE'VE TAKEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
RESOURCE HANDLE THE SITUATION-
THE SHOW I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
THE AGENCY HAS ANYTHING FURTHER
ON THE. YOUR REGULAR THIS IS
MARK ON MAJOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY I THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND- I THINK ADAM
ELABORATED ON THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION SIDE. LET ME
ALSO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING AROUND
THEIR CONSUMER SIDE BECAUSE YOU
ARE CORRECT WE ARE SEEING. AN
INFLUX OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
COMING TO THE STATE AT TAXES
SERVICES AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
BE NIMBLE WHERE ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS TO THE EXTENT- WE ARE
ALLOWED BY FEDERAL LOT- TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE ARE. HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO SIGN UP FOR THESE
PROGRAMS ARE TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE AND HOW IT WORKS AND
ACT I REFERENCE THIS. IN A
HEARING LAST WEEK I WE HAVE
WAIVED THE FACE TO FACE
REQUIREMENTS AND WE BE THAT WAY
THAT WAY IT SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS A
COMPLICATION. YEAH AND IT
DIFFICULTY FOR FOLKS TO GET
ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES AND SO
WERE WANTING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.
AS ISSUES DO ARISE WE DO WANT
TO PROBLEM SOLVE WITH THEM AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PUTTING
THE INDIVIDUALS FOR COMING
FORWARD- FIRST IN TERMS OF HOW
WE DELIVER. SERVICES AND FROM
WHAT. MARGOT IF I MAY. PRESENT
WE WENT FROM TWO. HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA APPLICATIONS LAST
MONTH TO TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED.
CALVET LOCATIONS THIS MONTH AND
KNOW THAT THE NEED IS GREAT
WITH AND MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND WOULD LIKE TO
AND THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO WORK WITH THE LET THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO BOTH MODIFY
EXTEND AS WELL AS CODIFIED THE
FLEXIBILITY IS AND
STREAMLINING. THAT YOU WERE
MENTIONING JUST A SECOND AGO-
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
EITHER THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND OR- STATE DEPARTMENTAL
GUIDANCE. HAS REALLY HELPED AND
I'M WONDERING. IF IN OUR BUDGET
PROCESS FOR JUNE FIFTEENTH. CAN
I ASK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PARTNERSHIP AS WE CRAFT THIS IN
HOPES OF BEING ABLE. TO ADOPT
THESE IN OUR BUDGET PROCESS I'D
LIKE TO KNOW IF WE CAN CODIFY
MANY OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE WITHIN YOUR EXECUTIVE
ORDER. WITHIN OUR BUDGET
PROCESS ON JUNE FIFTEENTH. AND
IF I MAY JUST AS AN ASIDE.
THROWIN WELL YOU HAVE WORKED ON
CAL WORKS AND- AM APPRECIATIVE
OF IT. I'M SENSITIVE TO THE
FACT THAT MANY PEOPLE ON CAL
WORKS ARE ON TIME CLOCKS. AND
DURING THIS CRISIS WE HAVEN'T
PAUSED THOSE TIME CLOCKS ARE
STOPPED THOSE TIME CLOCKS. AND
IN ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
LIMITING- THOSE- A RESOURCE TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST IN A
TIME WHEN THEY'RE MOST
VULNERABLE. I WOULD LIKE TO GET
THE A MINISTRY. HI THIS IS THAT
THEY ARE ADAM YOU WANT TO GO
FIRST. CERTAINLY I MEAN I THINK
THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO EVALUATE IS THAT YOU KNOW
THIS IS BàN I'M SUCH AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION AND
WE'RE MOVING SO QUICKLY. YOU
KNOW AS WE TRY TO RESPOND TO
THE CRISIS AND I THINK THAT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT A LOT
OF THESE FLEXIBILITY IS WE'RE
STILL SORT OF EVALUATING- BUT
WHAT THE COSTS ARE NAMED SO AS
WE GET INTO THE BUDGET
CONVERSATION I DON'T THINK THAT
WE CAN COMMIT TO OUTCOMES RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE'RE STILL WORKING
ON DEVELOPING THE REVISION BUT-
I THINK WE CAN COMMIT TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
PRIORITIZE SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITY IS THAT WE- SHOULD
ON SHORT TERM BASIS. EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
FUNDED TO PRIORITIZE PART OF A
BUDGET YOU KNOW AGREEMENT AT
THE END OF THE- FISCAL YEAR.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
IF I CAN I'D LIKE TO TURN THE
CONVERSATION TO THE EMERGENCY
AID FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY. AND I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR DISASTER RELIEF FUND.
FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
WHICH IS FUNDED THROUGH- THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
NOW THIS CURRENT FUND IS
DESIGNED TO REACH A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET
CENTER ESTIMATES THAT. THE
NUMBER OF UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY THIS CRISIS IS
THREE TIMES THAT AMOUNT.
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUSES HAVE NOW WAIT IN WITH
THE REQUEST FOR A MODICUM OF
RELIEF. FOR THIS COMMUNITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
RELIEF BUT FOR THEIR STATUS.
AND SO I WANT TO ASK. WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE
TO THE RECENT LETTER FROM THE
LATINO. BLACK API JEWISH AN
ELBOW G. B. T. Q. CAUCUSES.
ASKING FOR SUPPORT FOR I TEN
FILERS WITH THE ITC.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANGLE OF THIS IS
THE DATE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO DEFINITELY- AS YOU
MENTION WHAT THE APPROPRIATION
THAT MONEY THAT THE STATE PUT
FORWARD AND WHAT WE- HAVE
SOMEONE PARTNERS- FOR
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS THIS
IS A PRIORITY ESPECIALLY
GIVING. THE GAPS THAT WOULD
SEEM FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO AYE TEN FIVE HOURS IN
THE EITC- THAT SIMPLE HAS TO BE
WEIGHED AT IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE OVERALL BUDGET BECAUSE-
THEY RAISE- GENERAL FUND TRADE
OFF AND WE KNOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE SIGNIFICANTLY
CONSTRAINED GENERAL FUND
PICTURE- AND THAT WOULD ALSO BE
AN- ON GOING CHANGE. IN DATA
SETS AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE STRUCTURE OF OUR BUDGET NOT
JUST FOR THE COMING YEAR OR THE
CURRENT YEAR BUT FOR SEVERAL
YEARS FORRIGHT SO I THINK THE
GOVERNOR STILL MAKING HIS
DECISIONS ON THAT. I WOULD
DEFINITELY RECEIVED THE
FEEDBACK AND IT'S ON OUR RADAR
SCREEN- BUT I THINK UNTIL THE
GOVERNOR PUTS OUT HIS NAY
REVISION. I CAN'T REALLY GET
AHEAD OF HIS DECISION. IF I MAY
I'M GOING TO- CHANGE THE
SUBJECT AND- ADDRESS MY FINAL
TWO QUESTIONS. IN TERMS OF HOW
WE HELP TO STABILIZE THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM. AND I WILL
EDITORIALIZE AN AD THAT I AM
NOT SURE THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IS SUFFICIENT- AND
BELIEVE THAT MORE WILL BE
NEEDED FOR US TO STABILIZE THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM. AND I'D LIKE TO
ADD ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
REGARDING A REGULATION.
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT WE'VE-
PASSED IT THAT MAY CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL TROUBLES
FOR OUR HOSPITALS. AND I'M
WONDERING IF WE CAN BECAUSE IT
SEEMS THAT EVERY YEAR WE- TALK
ABOUT CLOSURES OF MORE
HOSPITALS AND HOW THIS- REALLY.
LIMITS OUR ACCESS TO
EMERGENCIES AND OTHER TYPES OF
HOSPITAL CARE WHICH PLACES OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK AND NOW
IRONICALLY IT IS OUR HEALTH
CARE CRISES WHICH HAS EMPTIED
OUR HOSPITALS. CUTTING OFF
3240% OF THEIR REVENUE AND
POTENTIALLY PUTTING THEMSELVES
ON LIFE SUPPORT. MY SECOND
LARGEST HOSPITAL IN FRESNO
COUNTY FOR LOAD A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES
YESTERDAY OR SIX AND A HALF
PERCENT OF THEIR ENTIRE WORK
FORCE. AND SO I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND AND- ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION IF THEY WOULD
SUPPORT REVISITING THE CURRENT
SEISMIC RETROFITTING
REQUIREMENTS. AND DEADLINES FOR
LOW RISK HOSPITALS AS A WAY TO
REDUCE THE IMMENSE FISCAL
PRESSURES PARTICULARLY ON A
RURAL HOSPITALS. ALL TRYING TO
SORT OF LIKE A LIKE ADAM DORSEY.
ALL YEAH SO- I THINK THAT- IT
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT HERE IS
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE YOU KNOW
AGREE THAT THERE IS A BIT OF A
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW AND THAT- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE INDUSTRY-
BUT THIS IS BEEN A REAL. A
PRIORITY OF OURS IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE ASKED TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH RESPECT
TO RELIEF- AND- WE'VE GOT MARK
MARK OF EACH YEAR DAVE- CAN
TALK MORE ABOUT- AUSTIN'S ROLE
pCERTAINLY YOU KNOW OVER THE
COURSE OF MANY YEARS THE
ADMINISTRATION. HAS WORKED WITH
HOSPITALS AND THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- WITH RESPECT TO-
SEISMIC SAFETY- ISSUES AS THEY
ARISE WITH FACILITIES THAT- YOU
KNOW EVER HAVING TROUBLE
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS BUT
CERTAINLY- THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE KIND OF CASE BY CASE
BASIS AND OPEN DISCUSSIONS AND
HAPPENED AT HANDED OVER TO HHS
IF THEY HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THAT. THANKS ADAM BY DR MARTIN.
WITH HHS I ALSO THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AS ACTING
DIRECTOR OF. THE OFFICE IT
MIGHT HELP PLANNING DEVELOPMENT
THAT- THAT. IMPLEMENTS A
SEISMIC SAFETY REQUIREMENTS- ON
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
AND ASKING TO WHY- ADAM DORSEY
JUST ALLUDED TO- WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS. AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY REQUIREMENTS. AND WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH HOSPITALS AND YOUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AROUND THE
TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENTS- AND
CERTAINLY- WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU IN TERMS OF- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE. HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN HOSPITALS
IN YOUR DISTRICT DO OTHERS- AND
WE WANT TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE LOOK AND
ACCESS. THAT ARE. THANK YOU AND
UP AS MY FINAL I REALLY WANTED
TO DIG INTO MLR AND DON'T MEAN
TO GET TO ONE KEY BUT- MEDICAL
LOSS RATIO IS A BILL THAT WAS
CHAPTER TO A FEW YEARS AGO I.
BELIEVE IT WAS AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE. BUT AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW CERTAIN INSURANCE
INDUSTRIES HAVE BEGUN RETURNING
PAYMENTS TO CONSUMERS AS OUR
LIFESTYLES HAVE CHANGED SUCH AS
DRIVING LESS. HOWEVER THE
HEALTH INSURANCE DâN THE
MANAGED CARE INDUSTRY HAS YET
TO DO THE SAME. AND DESPITE
THAT THE PROVIDERS AND THEIR
NETWORKS ARE DRAMATICALLY
SEEING LESS MEDICAL CARE OR
GIVING LESS MEDICAL CARE TO
THEIR PATIENTS AND SO I'D LIKE
TO ASK IS THE ADMINISTRATION
WORKING WITH THE HEALTH
INSURERS AND- MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO UNDERSTAND THE AMOUNT
OF RESERVES WHICH ARE BUILDING
UP IN THE INDUSTRY.
PARTICULARLY IN THE CONTEXT
THAT THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
MEDICAL LOSS RATIO WHICH WAS
ADOPTED THROUGH MY BILL. BUT
ADAM DORSEY DISCUSS THIS AS
WELL. ALL YOU ARE I GUESS
THERE'S TWO THINGS THAT I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT NODE ONE IS THAT
YOU KNOW IT HEALTH PLANS ARE
ARE KIND OF DIFFERENTLY
SITUATED AND THERE ARE SOME
HEALTH PLANS THAT ARE MAKING
PAYMENTS TO- PROVIDER GROUPS
AND HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THAT I
THINK ARE HELPFUL AND- IN
STABILIZING. IN HELPING TO HELP
STABILIZE THE SITUATION THAT'S
BEING FACED BY THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY BUT- YOU
KNOW OTHERS YOU KNOW DON'T FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE IN A POSITION AS
EARLY AS IN THE SAME WAY- THAT
BUT- WHAT I'LL SAY ABOUT MLR IS
THAT- MLR IS THE LAW OF THE
LAND. AND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS VERY YOU
KNOW AND FORCE THEM ALL OUR-
AND THAT. YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
THOSE ARE AS- YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT TAKE A COUPLE OF YEARS AS
AND WE AUDIT DATA AND
ENFORCEMENT I'M KIND OF A
CRUISE ON THE BACK END BUT-
BUT- THAT. YOU KNOW THE PLAN IS
RIGHT NOW IS TO IMPLEMENT
CURRENT LAW WHICH INCLUDES YOU
KNOW MEDICAL LOSS RATIO
REQUIREMENTS. AND UP IF THE
AGENCY HAS ANYTHING ELSE THAT
ON THAT CERTAINLY. YEAH THANK
YOU HAVE. IF THERE'S NOTHING TO
ADD AND- I AM PRECIADO THAT
IT'S THE LAW OF THE LAND BUT I
BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE TO ENFORCE
THOSE LAWS AND SO I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND IF THE GOVERNOR IS
WILLING TO- SIGN AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT MLR IS
RESPECTED AND ENFORCED. IN
ORDER FOR US TO REBUILD OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. SO I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
TAKE BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT.
THANK YOU I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO TRY TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF- DECREASE.
ACCESS THAT IS COME FROM COVERT
NINETEEN. AND SO- WOULD WANT US
TO LOOK TOWARDS TOOLS THAT- WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED AND LOOK TO
ENFORCE THOSE AND- BELIEVE THAT
MLR IS A SIGNIFICANT WAY THAT
WE CAN. LOOK TOWARDS
STABILIZING OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND WOOD WANTS TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS. WITH
THAT I WILL TURN MY QUESTIONS
BACK OVER TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR A BILLER
MISTER MCCARTY EUROPE. THANK
YOU THAT MISTER VICE CHAIR. I
HAVE- A SERIES OF QUESTIONS BUT
MOST HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
ALREADY SOFTRIDE WRAP MY UPS WE
GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT. BUT I
KNOW THAT TODAY'S FOCUSES ON
THE RECOVERY AND ECONOMIC. THE
ECONOMIC STIMULUS IN THIS FOCUS
OF THAT IS IMPORTANT- I DO
WANNA KNOW IT WOULDN'T SOMEONE
MEMBER LIMóN SAID THAT WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR- CHILD CARE PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILIES AND PARENTS THAT IT'S
REALLY HARD TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL SO WE'LL BE SPENDING
SEVERAL HOURS TALKING ABOUT
THAT TOMORROW SO I WILL HOLD
THAT. I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
BIG PICTURE. RIGHT NOW AND
REALLY ENGAGE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND LA- I KNOW THAT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE UPCOMING
MAY REVISE. AND THE BUDGET
DECISIONS. YOU KNOW THERE'S-
TOUGH CONVERSATIONS AND- THE
TALK ABOUT US THIRTY BUDGET IN
TIGHTENING OUR BELTS. AND I GET
THAT'S IMPORTANT- TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT THINGS IS THAT. WE
HAVE WE ALL REALIZE THIS THAT.
THERE ARE REAL COSTS OF THAT AS
WELL AND LOOK WE'RE NOT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE CAN'T
PRINT OUR OWN MONEY- DOES NOT
JUST THE ROUTE THAT WE CAN GO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW BALANCE OUR
BUDGET. BUT WE ALREADY HAVE A
BIG PROBLEM AND I I'M NOT
CERTAIN HOW HAVING. DOCTOR
RAMBLIN I. ESSENTIALLY CUT.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OUT
OF OUR EDUCATION HEALTHCARE.
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA HOW
THAT'S GOING TO. WORK HOW IT'S
GONNA LESSEN THE PROBLEM AND
FRANKLY WILL ONLY. EXASPERATED
SO. REALLY AREN'T AREN'T OUR
GOAL. BUDGET PROCESS SHOULD BE
HOW TO BE BRIDGED THE PAIN FROM.
WHETHER IT'S A ONE YEAR- GAP
LOOKING AT OR A MULTI YEAR AND
REALLY OUR GOAL SHOULD BE
SOMETHING LIKE SHOULDN'T OUR
NUMBER ONE FOCUS NOT BE MAKING.
THE PROBLEM WORSE AND CREATING
NEW PROBLEMS SO IN OTHER WORDS
IF YOU LOOK AT JUST AN ESTIMATE
AND I KNOW THIS IS JUST NUMBERS
PULLING FROM THIS GUY WE DON'T
HAVE THE MAY REVISE IN FRONT OF
US. LET'S SAY THAT THE GAP THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS I'M JUST
THROWING A NUMBER OUT THERE
IT'S NOT THE GAP OF COURSE YET
MAYBE SOMEONE WILL SAY IT IS A
NUMBER LIKE THAT. LET'S SAY
LET'S THE THREE YEAR GAP IS
SEVENTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
WELL IF YOU LOOK AT. THE END
THE EDUCATION BUDGET YOU COULD
LOOK AT- THE ENTIRE HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGET YOU SEE CSU
COMMUNICATIVE CAL GRANT-
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS YOU
CAN LOOK AT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA- ALMOST
A BILLION DOLLARS YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE ENTIRE. CHILD CARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION IN PRESCHOOL BY
JUST IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
ROUGHLY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AND SELL I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
WOULD SAY GETTING TWENTY TWO
BILLION BY COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING THOSE THINGS. WOULD
HELP US ON OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND SO WE GET THAT WE
CAN'T PRINT MONEY LIKE THAT
FEDERAL MEANT BUT I MY QUESTION
IMPLORE US. TO WE HAVEN'T HAD A
ALL FOR ON OUR OUR NARROW PAST
PRACTICES FROM PRIOR RECESSIONS
TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN KEEP
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HOLE- WE HEARD EARLIER WE
TALKED ABOUT DEFERRALS WITH- WE
WITH RESPECT TO EDUCATION- YOU
KNOW- USING OUR ONE TIME MONEY
AND RESERVE- SOME MAY SAY WELL
THAT'S T. IS A SMOKE AND
MIRRORS BUDGET WELL MAYBE.
HAVING IT CALLED THAT IN
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE IS- CENTERS AND
PROVIDERS OPEN IN OUR ON OUR
SYSTEMS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
OPEN THOSE ARE KEY. TO OUR
ECONOMY TO KEEPING US GOING
FORWARD SO- THE QUESTION IS
DEPARTMENT OF. FINANCE HOW ARE
WE LOOKING AT OPTIONS THAT ARE
LESS PAINFUL TO ALLOW US TO
KEEP OUR ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS- THAT KEEP OUR ECONOMY
GOING. TO KEEP THOSE- GOING FOR
IN CALIFORNIA SO THE- F. AND LA
PLEASE. YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PARTY ALL SPEAK AND I KNOW LA-
WILL HAVE COMMENTS AS WELL I
THINK YOU OUTLINED A CHALLENGE.
I ALSO. HELP THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO ADD EXCEPT THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT ALL THE OPTIONS THAT
IN MANY OF THE WAYS THAT YOU
DESCRIBE THINKING OUT. FIRST OF
ALL WHAT'S AVAILABLE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WE CAN
OF ICE THESE ISSUES- DEALING
WITH OUR ISSUES BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
COMPELLING AND THAT WE ARE IN
PARTNERSHIP ADMINISTER. THAT WE
DELIVER FOR CALIFORNIANS. ALSO
THE ISSUE USE RESERVE
RECOGNIZING AS YOU SAT WITH
SCOTT THE ONE YEAR GAP. THREE
YEAR GAP. WE DO HAVE SOME. CAN
PART BECAUSE IT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND PRETTY I IN THE GOVERNOR
MADE ABOUT PUTTING MONEY AWAY
AND SAVING FOR A RAINY DAY AND
THE CREATION OF THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
NOT DUMPING THAT ALL IN THE
FIRST YEAR WHICH MIGHT RELIEVE
THE PAIN AND BUDGET YEAR BUT
THEN IN THAT YEAR AFTER THAT
YEAR AFTER THAT COULD LEAD TO
EVEN. CAUGHT THE AND IT'S- CAN
I THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO TAKE
TO ACTIONS THAT CREATE LONG
TERM COSTS THAT HURT- PEOPLE IN
THE STATE IN THE STATE BUDGET
YOU KNOW. THREE FIVE TEN YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME RECOGNIZING THAT WHILE WE
WILL HAVE. THAT ARE PAINFUL IN
FACT VERY PAINFUL- WE HAVE TO
FIND A WAY OF NOT JUST WATCHING
EVERYTHING IN SIGHT BECAUSE WE
ALSO EVEN AS WE APPROACH THIS
VERY DIFFICULT BOTCHED SEASON.
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN THE INVESTMENTS IN
PROTECTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE. AND ALSO THINKING ABOUT
THE FUTURE AT AND MANY OF THE
BEST THINGS THAT YOU MADE US
ALL INTO EXACTLY THAT CATEGORY.
SO LIKE YOU SAID THERE'S NO
MAGIC SOLUTION TAUGHT TO IT BUT
WE ARE LOOKING AT EVERY
AVAILABLE OPTION- IN TERMS OF
THAT DECISIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAKING. OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL DAYS FOR HIS NAY
RECREATION. AND WILL BE DOING
WHAT'S ALL THE OF. OKAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY THIS IS
OUR GATE PRODUCT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. AND YOUR
QUESTION IS VERY WELL TAKEN I
THINK- THE CHALLENGE. THAT THE
STATE WILL PLACE COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT AS- THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT AS INDICATED. THAT
THEY THINK THAT. THE SOLUTION
TO THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER. THIS THE-
SEVERAL LAY TO THE STORE. YOUR
COMBINING THE USE OF JUDICIAL
USE OF RESERVE. MAYBE ARE
INTERNAL BORROWING AND THEN
ALSO THERE ARE NO BUDGETARY-
SHIPS OR PERHAPS THERE'S SOME
SOME KIND OF DEFERRALS THAT
WOULD HAVE LESS LESS OUR IMPACT
ON THE OPTIONS IN ANY MATERIAL
WAY SO THE COMBINATION OF THOSE
AND THEN HOPEFULLY- IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
FORTHCOMING THEN THAT WOULD.
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THE PROBLEM
BUT I DO THINK IT SHOULD BE-
RECOGNIZED FOR A MOMENT THAT
THE SIZE OF THE STATE BUDGET
RESERVE THAT HAS BEEN BUILT UP
OVER THE EXPANSION IS REALLY A
KEY ASSET FOR THE STATE AND FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE AT ITS
DISPOSAL AND ONCE WE HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE BUDGET
PROBLEM YEAH I THINK YOU WILL-
YOU KNOW YOU. WANT TO DROP THAT
DOWN THIS IS WHAT THIS IS THE
RAINY DAY THAT IT WAS BUILT.
MORE THAN ONE WAY THEY HOPE YOU
WITH THAT OR OFFICE IS.
CURRENTLY WORKING ON. DEVELOP
SOME. FISCAL ESTIMATES WOULD
LOOK AT JUST KIND OF GO INTO
THE- JUST GO LIBERTY. YOU GO
INTO WITH A SENSE OF WHAT THE
BASELINE OF EXPENDITURES IS
WE'RE WORKING ON SORT OF A- AN
UPDATE CALLING IT OUR SPRING
OUTLOOK AS OPPOSED TO OUR
NOVEMBER FALLOUT. AND THAT WE
HOPE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH KIND
OF A YOU KNOW EXPENDITURE BASED
HIGH IN AN EXPENDITURE BASED
LOW AND- THOSE WOULD BE SOME
WAYS TO GIVE SOME. WAYS TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT SERVICES AND
RESISTING BASELINE BUDGET BUT
THEN. THIRD THERE ARE MORE
COSTLY INCLUDING THE LESS
COSTLY WAYS TO DO THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PRESENT THAT TO YOU AS
A- SO ROUND FOR DISCUSSION- OF
COURSE IT WILL BE. VERY CRUCIAL
A INFORMED BY WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT ARMY REVISION
INCLUDES- BUT- WE HOPE THIS
WILL BE A GOOD PLACE TO START.
YEAH THAT AND THOSE FRANKLY ARE
ARE JUST THE ANSWER IS I WAS
HOPING FOR AYE AYE I WOULD NOT
WANT TO HAVE OUR GOAL TO BE
GETTING THE OTHER NATIONAL
AWARD FOR AN AUSTERITY BUDGET
AND- SLASH. AND RAISING TAXES
OF COURSE AS WE HEARD FROM SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES BUT- WHAT CAN
WE DO CREATIVELY AND LOOK AT
OUR PAST RECESSIONS BUT I ALSO.
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AND I
THINK THAT- OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL
SHOULD BE TO NOT MAKE THE
PROBLEM WORSE AND- CUTTING
ACCESS AT HIGHER EDUCATION AND-
HEALTH CARE BACKS AS CHILD CARE
SLOTS- EARLY EDUCATION PRE K.
PROGRAMS AFTER SCHOOL GETTING
RID OF THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
GOING TO MAKE THE SITUATION. A
YEAH SO I. ASK NOW QUESTIONS
ON- BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD. THAT
TO. KNOW HAVE COME UP ABOUT THE
RECOVERY IN CALIFORNIA. ONE IS
ROM OUR OUR FOLKS IN THE
BUILDING TRADES IN AND LABOR-
FEW DAYS AGO. OUR LOCAL
CARPENTERS INVITED ME TO GO
ACROSS THE STREET AND ACTS ACTS
I COULDN'T GO BECAUSE RIGHT IN
OUR FIRST YEAR. THEY WANTED ME
TO OR THE MINISTER THEATER EGGS.
ACROSS THE CAN ANNOUNCED THEY
HAVE THEIR- FOLKS WERE OUT
THERE. ON SAY AND SO WILL
DISTANCING AND THAT ESSENTIAL.
GO THAT IS ENDING. BUT THERE
pTHROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT ARE.
ON THE BUBBLE ESPECIALLY IN
CERTAIN AREAS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE OVERALL CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
ON THE HINK THE THINK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE OUR OUR HOUSING
SHORTAGE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SORTAGE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WORKFORCE HOUSING THE WORKS.
WEEK WE'D WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE
THAT SO WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT- THESE ESSENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS- CAN
REMAIN AND WE CAN- ADDRESS.
THESE ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE
REGIONS THAT HAVE SOME OF THAT-
LIMITATIONS RIGHT NOW. I CAN
SPEAK AT BRIEFLY TO THAT AND
THEN I KNOW THAT WAY ON THE AT
COMMENTS AS WELL I THINK. IT IS
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
CHALLENGING- WITH YOUR- MARK
YOUR DOLLARS BAND WE WERE
ANTICIPATING IN JANUARY- BUT
WHEN IT COMES SPECIFICALLY CHAT
HOUSING AS YOU MENTIONED THAT
THIS WAS. A HOUSING AND OF
COURSE HOMELESSNESS RELATED
ISSUE- THIS IS THE TOP PRIORITY
THE GOVERNOR AND AS- WE ALL
RECALL IF HE DEVOTED HIS. IN
TOP OF THE STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS HERE TO HOMELESSNESS SO
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND A WAY
EVEN WITHIN THIS CONSTRAINED
BUDGET. THAT WE'RE CAN TO PUSH
THE PACE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AND MAKE. HOW AFFORDABLE. MORE
PORTABLE PLAY TO LAND SO THE
EXACT WAYS AND WE'RE GONNA DO
MORE. WITH YOUR RESOURCES WE
ARE WORKING FOR THAT RIGHT NOW
AND AFTER THAT THEY WERE VISION
YOU TO WILL BE DISCUSSING WITH
ALL OF YOU- AS YOU PRINT FOR
YOUR PROPOSALS BUT IT IS
DEFINITELY. A PRIORITY ON HOW
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HITTING OUR GOALS IN
TERMS OF HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT. RAPIDLY
RISING UNEMPLOYMENT- WE'RE
MAKING SURE THAT GOOD PAYING
JOBS OUT THERE CONTINUES TO BE
A PATH FOR THOSE AND I THINK
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. TASK
FORCE OF WILL BE FOCUSED ON
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU TWO TWO MORE
QUESTIONS. ONE IS ON WE TALKED
EARLIER IN YOUR PRESENTATION
ABOUT UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE THAT
INCREDIBLE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
APPLYING CALIFORNIA NORTH NORTH
OF THREE MILLION WE ALSO HAVE
THAT ARE YOU KNOW STATUS
BILLION PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAMS AND I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT WE ASK FOR BUDGET
PEOPLE IS. HOW DO WE MAKE THESE
PENCIL OUT FOR THIS FOR IT WITH
STATE RESOURCE IS EMPLOYERS
HAVING THEIR CONTRIBUTION THEIR
SHARE AND POTENTIAL FEDERAL
MONEY BUT THE REAL QUESTION
FRANKLY PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THEY DON'T CARE HOW
IT'S PAID FOR THIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S AVAILABLE SO. ARE WE
CERTAIN THAT IT'LL BE RELIABLE.
TWO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE DURATION OF THIS CO IN
NINETEEN CRISIS. YES WHEN IT
COMES TO THE- STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS- I KNOW
THIS CAME UP AS YOU MENTIONED
BRIEFLY EARLIER WE ARE REALLY
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BENEFITS
GET OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
THAT'S ALSO TRUE FOR THE
FEDERAL BENEFITS BECAUSE A LOT
OF THOSE YOU KNOW TEND TO FLOW
THROUGH THE STATE SO FOR
EXAMPLE THAT SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
BOOST- THAT YOU DE IS ALSO AND
WEBER AGENCIES MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE PAYMENTS AS WELL. ARE
GOING OUT FOR A SYSTEM AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WILL BE WE TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUES WITH.
FEDERAL SUPPORT IN MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S NOT GOING IN THAT THE
ALONE SEPARATE CHECKING OUT AT
THE INTEREST COST IS NOT
FALLING DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
US GIVEN THE HISTORIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WERE AND I
THINK YOU'RE ALSO SEEING FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR PAYMENT- THAT SOME OF
THAT WILL BE ENDING THIS SUMMER
AT THE END OF JULY. AND SO WHAT
NOBODY CAN SAY FOR SURE- WHERE
WE WILL BE WITH THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS SO SEATED
ECONOMIC IMPACT BY JULY I THINK
IT'S A PRETTY STATE BET. THE
IMPACT OF THE CRISIS BE. IT'S A
FOR SURE SO EASY DAY AND WEBER
AGENCY AT THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE ALL FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT WHETHER IT'S OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEMS OR CALL CENTERS AT THE
MONEY'S GETTING OUT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT I THINK YOU SAW THAT
EVEN IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS.
WITH RELAXING SO THE CATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY REQUIRED AND I
THINK THE TWO OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOINGIS NUMBER
ONE. IN TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO MAKING SURE
THAT IF MORE HELP IS NEEDED
pOF THIS CALENDAR YEAR AT THAT
AGE IS FORTHCOMING AND THEN TO.
EVEN AS WE ARE TRYING TO. HAVE
OUR LEGACY SYSTEMS YES IT OUT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THINKING
THROUGH- WITH ALL THE EXPERTISE
WE CAN BRING TO BEAR ON HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE OUR SYSTEMS AND I
THINK. JULIE SU AD IS MENTIONED
LAST WEEK AT ANSWERED SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT ON HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO BRING EVERY
SINGLE RESOURCE TO BEAR SO.
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY WE
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY AS YOU PUT
IT BACK. FOLKS DON'T REALLY
CARE WHO'S PAYING FOR IT WHERE
WHERE IT'S COMING FROM THEY
JUST ONE NOW THAT THEY HAVE IT
WHEN THEY NEED IT SO THAT IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE- AND SO YOU
MENTIONED. YOU WHY BUT THAT THE
SECOND PART OF MY QUESTION WAS
ARE STATES DISABILITY AND PAM.
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE- EFFORTS
PROGRAM SO. DO WE HAVE THE SAME
CERTAINTY WITH THOSE TWO. YES I
THINK IT COMES TO THAT IS THERE
WILL HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON A
REVISION BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE. CRITICAL AS
WELL. YES AND THEN MY FINAL
QUESTION IS RELATE TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION. AND OF COURSE
THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY NOW
WITH CLAIMS WITH COVERT CLAIMS
AND YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY THIS
WILL BE- ADDRESS I KNOWS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM L. GROSS ON THEM
OR COOPER HAS ANNOUNCED
LEGISLATION WHICH SIDE SUPPORT
ON THIS TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
PROTECT OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
WITHIN THE MINISTRATIONS FAR AS
PEOPLE- BEING DENIED WORKERS
COMP CLAIMS THAT HAS- COVERT
NINETEEN. IMPACT IN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS YOU
KNOW GET THE GET THE GET THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE. SO
ANY ISSUES WHEN IT COMES TO-
THE SPECIFICS OF PEOPLE BEING
DENIED WHICH IT MIGHT CLAIMS
YOU KNOW DEFINITELY BRING THEM
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND IN THIS
EMERGENCY AT THOSE CLAIMS NEED
TO BE ADJUDICATED. FAIRLY
OBVIOUS ON THAT I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION MORE
GENERALLY AND I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED A LEGISLATION THE
GOVERNOR HASN'T WEIGHED IN ON
THAT YES I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD DEAL OUT. I DO NOT
GONNA HAS. THANK YOU HAS MY
FINAL QUESTION THE STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER BUSH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I TOOK NOTE
TO I THINK IT WAS YESTERDAY-
TIM COOK THE CEO OF APPLE- GAVE
HIS OPINION- TO THE PRESIDENT
THAT- HE FELT WE WERE GOING TO
BE IN A WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS A
V. SHAPED ECONOMY WHICH WAS
CHARACTERIZED BY A VERY RAPID
DECLINE. AND THEN HE FELT-
THERE WOULD BE A RAPID
IMPROVEMENT AND IN THE ECONOMY
AND I THINK THAT AT THAT'S AN
OPTIMISTIC VIEW OF WHERE WE
MIGHT BE HEADED- BUT I THINK
THE FUNDAMENTALS OF THE ECONOMY
THAT WE HAD ARE GOING TO RETURN
AND TO AND THERE IS SOME
REASON. FOR OPTIMISM. I THINK
IT'S WORTHY OF US TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE OUR
GOALS ARE- FOR THE FUTURE WHEN
THE ECONOMY DOES RETURN. AND I
WAS HEARTENED WHEN- I BELIEVE
IT WAS THE ADMINISTRATION-
MENTIONED TO- THE- APARTMENT
FINANCE MENTIONED THAT
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE A UP A
PRIORITY. AND I AGREE I THINK
THAT SHOULD BE A OF A PRIORITY-
I THINK ANOTHER PRIORITY OUGHT
TO BE PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND IMPROVING OUR BEST BENSON
HOW WE PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND MY COLLEAGUES HAVE. HAVE
MENTIONED THE NEED TO INCREASE-
AND TAKE STEPS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DOCTORS AND NURSES
AND ALLIED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE OUT
THERE ARE NO. OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM A MODESTO IS INTERESTED IN
INCREASING- THE AVAILABILITY OF
NURSING THROUGH A PROGRAMS
THAT- I THINK IT'S AT MERCED.
I'M AND I THINK I THINKTHESE
ARE VERY VALUABLE GOALS BUT
WHAT- I THINK IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE AND WHAT IS- REALLY
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED FROM. THE PANDEMIC THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN IS THAT WE
HAVE TO INCREASE OUR EFFORTS ON
THE PREVENTION SIDE OF. THE
WE'VE GOTTEN VERY GOOD AT
TREATING DISEASE- BUT WE HAVE
REALLY LEFT BEHIND EFFORTS TO-
A TO PREVENT DISEASE FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND THAT IS PLAYING OUT OF WITH.
A TRULY DEVASTATING RESULTS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD TODAY. HOW
MINUTES EVERYTHING FROM OUR-
LACK OF PREPARATION WITH- NOT
STOCKPILING PP- VENTILATORS
OTHER ESSENTIAL EQUIPMENT. I TO
A LACK OF FOCUS ON- MANY OF
THE- FACTORS THAT ARE MAKING A
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
DIFFICULT SITUATION UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE BUT ARE MAKING IT
WORSE NAMELY- THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE ALLOWED A CRISIS OF- AN
EPIDEMIC OF OBESITY AND TO-
DIABETES AND OTHER CO OCCURRING
DISORDERS. TO FASTER FOR MANY
MANY YEARS SO- I WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT BE ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES GOING FORWARD I'M
WONDERING IF- ANY OF THREE. OUR
FOLKS HERE HAVE BEEN VERY
PATIENT AND HAVE STUCK IT OUT
UNTIL NOW- IF- IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS IN THAT REGARD. NUMBER
ONE THIS IS A MISS WON OUT AND
I THINK- YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT THAT THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND THAT.
TREATMENT IS NOT NOT SAID THERE
REALLY NEEDS TO BE A FOCUS ON
PREVENTION I THINK IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET I HE
REALLY PUT OUT A NUMBER
PROPOSAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHAT BECOMES OF THE GOALS OF
THE OBJECTIVES OF. HOW WE
DELIVER CARE HEALTHCARE THAT IS
FOCUSES ON THE WHOLE PERSON AND
FOCUSES ON ALL THE DRIVERS ARE
THAT CREATE PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND NOT SIMPLY
DELIVERING. TREAT CERTAINLY.
ALLEN'S NOW I WE ARE GOING FOR
OUR HELPING HUMANS ADD BUDGET
THIS WEEKEND. AS WE PREPARE FOR
THE NAY REVISION. YOU KNOW
WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO MAKE ALL THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAD
ANTICIPATED IN JANUARY. AND
THAT'S GONNA BE TOPS YOU KNOW
AT THE VERY MOMENT THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A CRISIS THAT
SHOWS. JUST HOW MUCH THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED BUT I
THINK THAT OBJECTIVE AND THAT
FRAME IS STILL THERE WILL NOT
ONLY ABOUT PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. BUT
DELIVERING SERVICES TO THAT AND%
IN A WAY WHERE WE ARE GETTING
TO THE PREVENTION AND BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH- ISSUES THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND NOT SIMPLY
TREATING EGGS AT THE BACK. AND
MARCO. WANT ANY. THANK YOU. Q.
WELL IN ORDER FOR US TO GET
THERE IN ORDER FOR US TO ADD
THIS- RETURN HAVE A SEAT PEOPLE
RETURNING TO WORK- WE HAVE TO
RAMP BUT I THINK IT'S A
GENERALLY ACCEPTED TODAY THAT
WE HAVE TO WRAP UP PARK ARE AT
THE TESTING IN A DRAMATIC WAY
AND TO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT- THE- OVER SOME.
OF OUR OF OUR TESTING PROGRAMS-
SEEMS TO BE. THE WHELP OVERSIZE
NOT THE WORD RIGHT WORD THAT
ARE- THAT OUR PROGRAM AND OUR
PROGRAMMATIC APPROACH TO
INCREASING WE- ACCESS TO
TESTING SEEMS TO BE WORKING AND
THE- AS OF LAST WEEK I THINK
WE'RE AT SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TESTS- OKAY A LITTLE
BIT AHEAD OF SCHEDULE FULL TO
THE ANTICIPATED. A TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PER DAY- THE TO WERE
EXPECTING AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MNTH REALLY AT THE VERY
END OF THIS WEEK. I'M BUT I'M A
LITTLE BIT PERPLEXED AND
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE ARE NOT AT
THIS POINT FIVE DAYS BEFORE-
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND. THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A AND UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THOSE GUYS ARE GOING TO WRAP UP
BEYOND THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND TO THAT TO ME IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE BECAUSE I
THINK- THE- NUMBER OF TESTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED. THROUGHOUT
THE STATORS SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF- BEWEEN SIXTY
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY AND WE'RE STILL A
LONG WAY FOR OUT SO IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
CAN BE- PROVIDED. AS TO WHERE
WE ARE ON TESTING AND THAT'LL
HAVE FOLLOW UP QUESTION OF
ABOUT TO CONTACT GRAYSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS MONICA
MEETS WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES SO EAT RIGHT
YOU'RE CORRECT WE ARE ON OUR
WAY TO GET TO THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MARK BY THE END OF THE
WEEK OR BY THE END OF THE
MONTH. I AND AS SECRETARY IN
THE GOVERNOR AND NOTED- IT LAST
WEEK OUR GOAL IS TO GET TO
ANOTHER SIXTY TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND- PER DAY AND MOVING
FORWARD. AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE
POCKETS OF WORK- THAT I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ASTOR MINOR STRATEGY IS YEAH.
WELL RIGHT THE FIRST ONE IS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW WE-
ARE CAPACITY- BY WRITING ONLINE
HIGH. RIGHT I TESTING SITE SO
THESE ARE PLACES WHERE YOU
COULD DO A LOT OF TESTING ALL
UP ONE ASK THAT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEMS OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A LOT. AB OUR COMMERCIAL
PLANES I HAVE LAW LEVER WE ARE
ACT WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
STATE THINK ABOUT I'M ADDED
CAPACITY THE SPACE THAT WE
COULD DO A LOT OF MORE HIGH
THROUGH PROTESTING I SO IT'S
NOT ONE OR TWO TESTS DURING
THEIR BUT- HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS OF TEST A IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO BE FROM
OUR CITY SO THAT'S ONE. THIS
LINE ABOUT. IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT DO WE STRATEGICALLY
DEPLOYED POINT OF CARE I TASK
AND THESE ARE TESTS PRIMARILY
DONE IN HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SETTINGS- AND THEY ARE LOW
VOLUME BY FAX TEST. IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO- USE THAT
INFORMATION FROM A CLINICAL
PERSPECTIVE IN ORDER TO MAKE
DECISIONS AROUND. WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL POSITIVE EFFECT
EXAMPLE. IS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IF WE CAN QUICKLY
CAST SOMEBODY AND DETERMINED
THAT THEY ARE POSITIVE OR
NEGATIVE IF THEY'RE POSITIVE
THEN WE CAN MOVE QUICKLY AROUND
MITIGATION TO ISOLATE THAT
INDIVIDUAL WITHIN OUR FACILITY.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT EXPOSED
QUICKER SO OUR ABILITY TO
DEPLOY THESE POINT OF CARE TASK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL PARTS OF
THE STATE AS WELL AS- PARTS OF
THE STATE WHERE WE HAVE HIGH
VOLUMES ARE STILL NURSING
FACILITY OR CONGREGATE CARE. I
SETTINGS FOR LONG TERM CARE ON
THE LONG TERM CARE SIDE THE
REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
AND OUR ABILITY TO DO THAT. THE
THIRD LINE OF EFFORT IS REALLY
AROUND THE SEROLOGY. TASK AB
OBVIOUSLY HAS ITS- CAST THAT WE
ARE ON CARRYING A WE'RE
GRATEFUL TRAP PARTNER. I AM
YEAR AND THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE ARE BEEN WORKING WITH
STANFORD TO GET THIS WRONG
WOULD YOU TEST- ON THEIR END AS
WELL AND A SEROLOGY TEST IS
DIFFERENT FROM MY PCR TEST IN
THE SENSE THAT IT REALLY LOOKS
AT THE ANTI BODIES AND THE-
LIVE- ACTED TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT YOU BUILD. IMMUNITY I FOR A
PARTICULAR VIRUS AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT. TO US AS
WE LOOK AT MORE COMMUNITY
SURVEILLANCE CORPORATE OR AND
SO WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
GETTING MORE OF THESE BLOOD
TESTS OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
SO. THAT WE CAN IMPROPER
ABILITY TO TEST MORE BROADLY
AND THEN RELEASED THE FORT LINE
OF EFFORT OR THE FOURTH POCKET.
IS WHAT I WILL CALL LOOKING AT
THESE TESTING DESERT SO REALLY
BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
ARE WE WHERE DO WE HAVE
SPECIMEN COLLECTION SITES NOT
NECESSARILY WHERE YOU CAN GO
GET TESTED BECAUSE- CERTAINLY
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO SHIP
SPECIMENS. THE DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE TO CALIBRATE
CAPACITY IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO YOU TESTING OR MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHERE DO WE HAVE A
SPECIMEN COLLECTION SITES. THE
ORDER FOR US TO BE EQUITABLE.
IN TERMS TO. HOW WE GET PEOPLE
IN THE DOOR TAX TEST SO LAST
WEEK AGAIN THE GOVERNOR NOW A
PART OF WITH OFTEN SIR WHICH IS
GOING. I HAVE UP RIGHT NOW.
EIGHTY SO. AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH FIFTEEN TO TWENTY AYE AYE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES RIGHT NOW TO
IDENTIFY THOSE SITES. IN ORDER
FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THESE TESTING
SPECIMEN COLLECTION. THIRDS
ASSET WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING A
TO. COLLECT SO. ALL THIS TO SAY
IS THAT WE ARE NOT PUTTING ALL
OUR EGGSIN ONE BASKET OR
LOOKING AT JUST ONE STRATEGY
OUR STRATEGY IS HAS FOUR
DIFFERENT CRIMES IN ORDER FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE. AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND THEN THE LAST THING I WILL
SAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING OUR SAID THIS ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS NOW WE'RE
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT WHAT IS A
SUPPLY CHAIN LOOK LIKE. AND HOW
DO WE NOT ONLY- ADD TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN BUT A DRESS THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN SHORTAGES SO I'M
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT TRYING TO
PROCURE AN ADDITIONAL FILES
FILES A VIRAL MEDIA. ARE THE
REASON WHICH WE CAN MAKE OUR
OWN VIRAL MEDIA AND SO THOSE
ARE THE EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDER
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
ONLY YOU CAN. ASK THE OWNER. TO
TAX BUT I. OUR CITY BEST TO BE
ABLE TO EXPRESSED. THE STATE
ENACT WAY. THANK YOU FOR A THEM
OF DETAIL RESIDUE OF SORT OF
WHERE WE ARE ALL ON TESTING.
THE ONE THE ONE THING- THAT I
THINK IS NOT WHERE THEY LET LET
ME BACK UP FOR A SECOND SAY
THAT I- HAD THE- PRESENTATION
LAST WEEK- THERE WAS A- ONLINE-
PRESENTATION UP FROM THE
TESTING TASK FORCE THAT
PRESENTED A LOT OF- AND THAT
INFORMATION AND MORE- I WAS
VERY VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE- AND ALSO
CAME AWAY WITH AN UNDERSTANDING
OF JUST HOW COMPLEX THIS ISSUE
AS- A BUT THE MAIN THRUST OF MY
QUESTION WAS WHETHER WE WERE
POSITION TO PROJECT WITH ANY
DEGREE OF CERTAINTY- WHEN WILL
BE ABLE TO ACT AS WE DID A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND SAYING
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO WRAP UP TO
TWENTY. FIVE THOUSAND TODAY
WHEN WE WOULD BE TO- OF MOVE
THAT GOAL POSTS TO THIRTY
THOUSAND AND THIRTY FIVE IN FOR
SO LONG SO FORTH AND IT APPEARS
TO ME THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT NEED TO FALL INTO
PLACE BEFORE WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO DO THAT WITH ANY.
PREDICTABLE UP SO THAT LEADS ME
TO MY NEXT QUESTION. AND
COMMENT WHICH- HAS TO DO WITH
CONTACT TRACING AND I THINK
THAT- WITHOUT GOING INTO A LOT
OF DETAIL ABOUT CONTACT TRACING.
THE FEWER ACTUAL TASKS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THE MORE IMPORTANT
THE CONTACT TRACING BECOMES AND
IT'S LABOR INTENSIVE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL TAKE SOME
AMOUNT TIME TO RAMP UP. AND HI
I ASSUME IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GIVING A
LOT OF THOUGHT TO I CERTAINLY
HOPE SO OTHER STATES ARE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS PLACES AROUND THE
WORLD- WE HAVE- IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER. A
GROUP OF FIVE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS THAT
ARE- BEGINNING TO ORGANIZE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE- THE TYPES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAINED AND- OF
A HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY ABOUT
HEALTHCARE ISSUES. TAKING
NOTES- ENTERING IT INTO A
SYSTEM THAT VERY- IMPORTANT
SKILL SET THAT LENDS ITSELF TO
THIS THEY CAN ALSO DO TRAINING
OF OTHER OF OTHER INDIVIDUALS
AND I WILL- WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ASK IF WE ARE- BEGINNING GUY OR
IN ANY. STAGE OF- SCOTT OR
MOVING ALONG IN THE DIRECTION
OF- RAMPING UP FOR WHICH TO-
CONTACT TRACING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS MARK FROM EACH
AGAIN WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AGENCY AND THAT
IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND I'M
VERY IMPORTANT AND TIMELY
TOPIC. AS PART OF INDICATOR ONE
OUT WE ARE REALLY LOOKING AT
APPLE THE TESTING COMPONENT AS
YOU ALLUDED TO THAT TESTING
PIECE IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE JEFF CONTACT TRACING PEAS
I'M A CONTRACTOR. USERS OF
WRITING A DIFFERENT LINES OF
OUR FOR PRICE TO REALLY BE ABLE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE PULL AT
SCALE ARE APPROACHING THINKING
ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH WE ARE
REALLY BELT OUT THE WORK FORCE
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND THAT IS GOING TO
BE. REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
BEGIN TO LEFT OR MODIFY THE
STAY AT HOME WORKER BECAUSE I
ALMOST I USE THE ANALOGY OF A
WILDFIRE OUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO DO REALLY IS TO- AND
MITIGATE OR SOME CRACKS A BUNCH
OF LITTLE FIRES SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A MASSIVE FIRE ONCE
WE'D YOU- GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE'RE LISTING THAT. THE STATE
I'M ORDER ANOTHER ONE WHAT YOU
TRY TO DO WHAT CONTACT TRACING
IS. IDENTIFYING INDIVIDUAL. I
YOU KNOW FOR US TO BE TO ICE.
AND SUPPRESS THE SPREAD OF
VIRUS SO THAT THE- DOES BECOME.
A DEAL I SO ON THE CONTACT.
PART THERE'S A FEW LINES AFRICA
WE ARE WORKING ON THE FIRST
LINE OF EFFORT IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE TRAINING
COMPONENT. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO TO TRAIN MORE PEOPLE
AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE IN
THE WORK FORCE RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE REALLY. PASSAGE YOU I
REALLY DRAFT DIFFERENT ABOUT
HOW WE CAN CONTACT TRACING AND
SO WE ARE WORKING ACTIVELY
WITH- FULL ARE IN HI IRENE
STATE PARTNERS ESPECIALLY THE
UC SYSTEM'S ACTOR BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT TRAINING
CURRICULUM THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE CDC
AROUND THEIR TRAINING
CURRICULUM AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING OUT AND WE'VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN MASSACHUSETTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE A FEW WEEKS
OUT AHEAD OF US AND SO THEY'VE
ALREADY STARTED SOME OF THIS
CONTRACT TRACING WORK SO THAT
WE CAN LEARN FROM THEIR LESSONS
LEARNED. SO REALLY TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE BUILD
THEIR TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
BACK ALLOWS US TO QUICKLY MORE
INDIVIDUALS ONLINE SO THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY X. RAISING THE
OTHER ASPECT IS REALLY THINKING.
ABOUT THE WORK FORCE AND THIS
IS REALLY WHERE. ARE WE HAVE TO
CLOSE PART WITH OUR CALL. I IN
A EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WITH
REGARD TO MAKE IT A ONE
ALTHOUGH THE TRAINING COMPONENT
AND WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY WE
HAVE TO PARTNER WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES. BUT WITH REGARDS TO
THE WORK FORCE BEAST REALLY
ASSESSING AND THINKING ABOUT.
WIPED OUT CAPABILITIES TO OUR
COUNTY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOW HOW
DO WE- MAN OUT BY REDIRECTING
INDIVIDUALS FROM OTHER AREAS OF
COUNTY GOVERNMENT I WE ARE
COMING FROM STATE GOVERNMENT-
AND WE DIRECT FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO EAT FIVE PARKER
PASSED CITY IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TO DO CONTACT TRACING AND SO
WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
THAT WE ACTUALLY. ISSUED MAY
ALL OUR LOCAL HEALTH JURISTIC
STATE A BETTER AND- OF WHAT THE
SCOPE OR THE GAP REALLY LOOKS
LIKE AND- WE'LL HAVE SOME MORE
INFORMATION IN THE COMING DAYS.
AROUND WHAT HAVE GAP WERE
REALLY TRYING TO FILL IN HOW WE
CAN BE SUPPORT IT TO OUR LOCAL
COLLEAGUES. AROUND CONTACT
TRACING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT I
AT AT THE STATE LEVEL AND THEN
THE THIRD PIECE REALLY IS
AROUND TECHNOLOGY AND I'M SURE
YOU'LL HAVE PROBABLY BEEN BEEN
INUNDATED JUST AS- YEAH. AROUND
HAVE PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANIES
IN TECHNOLOGY FIRMS THAT ARE
COMING FORWARD SAYING THEY HAVE
VARIOUS TOOLS AVAILABLE FOR
CONTACT TRACING. AND THE WAY I
THINK ABOUT THIS- WHEN WHERE
WERE PRIORITY ENTICING OUR WORK
IS INTO POCKETS WITH REGARDS TO
TECHNOLOGY ONE IS THINKING
ABOUT. I'M WE HELP AFFECT CRIME
TRACER THE CONTACT INVESTIGATOR
REALLY GET THE MOST INFORMATION
IN ONE PLACE IN ORDER FOR THEM
TO MORE RAPIDLY. CONTACT
INDIVIDUALS. I IN ORDER. I A
LADY I SET THAT WE SPREAD STOP
SPREAD OF THE SO WHAT ARE
THINGS WE CAN PUT TECHNOLOGY
SOME. THAT KIND TRADE ARE IN
ORDER FOR THEM BE ABLE TO DO
THAT MORE. AND THEN THE SECOND
PIECE IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY IS
REALLY LOOKING AT SIX. SYMPTOM
CHECK SO IN TV YOUR MEASLES A
CONTACT TRACER WILL CONTACT YOU
ONCE OR TWICE A DAY TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT I YOU HAD ANY
SYMPTOMS AND RATHER THAN USING
A CONTACT TRACER TO DO THAT.
COULD WE PERHAPS THINK ABOUT
THAT TECHNOLOGY OUT WHETHER
THAT'S A TEXT MESSAGE OR AN APP
WHERE YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TELL. THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR
CONTACT TREE SERVICE WHETHER OR
NOT YOU HAD SYMPTOMS OR NOT IF
YOU HAVE THAT NOT THAT WOULD
TRIGGER. ALL PERSONS ALL UP
IBM'S CON. CALL OR BE A SO
THAT'S OF HOW WE ARE LABOR
WORKING ABOUT THAT NOW. I WOULD
REGARDS TO COME. TRAY AND WE'RE
DOING THAT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS BECAUSE IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT AS WE
LACK TAKE THE STICKING
TECHNOLOGICAL ASPECTS THAT THE
LINK OUT NOT DUPLICATE THE
EFFORTS ON THE GROUND. AND
EQUALLY IMPORTANT IT'S IT IS
THAT THEY ALIGN WITH OUR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS. AT THE
STATE AND COUNTY LEVELS SO THAT
THOSE THINGS HAPPEN EQUALITY TO
INTEGRATE AND TALK TO EACH
OTHER SO THAT I WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SURVEY. AND DETECT-
THE OUTBREAK OR THE VIRUS I
ONCE WE DO LAUGHTER MODIFY AND
THE STATE ORDER I HOPE THAT.
ARE HELPFUL. THANK YOU IS A
BLOOM WAS I'M JUST GONNA-
INTERRUPT ONE SECOND BRING YOU
BACK OF MR GRAY HAD ONE
QUESTION MANY OF THE LEAVE SO
IF I COULD HAVE BEEN DAHLE ASK
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE. FOR ONE
FOUR STAR BUT THE- THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO MY- FROM
MONICA ACTUAL FOR UP ON A
QUESTION HE RAISED IN RESPECT
PREVENTION AND EARLIER I
MENTIONED- THE LEGISLATION I'VE
WORKED ON. OUR AND HIS GLUCOSE
MONITORS AND YOU KNOW FOR THREE
YEARS RUNNING I INTRODUCED THAT
LEGISLATION- AND FOR THREE
YEARS RUNNING DEPARTMENT
FINANCE SENT A LOT OF
OPPOSITION. AND GIVEN THAT WE
KNOW SEE GM'S REDUCE DIABETES
RELATED HOSPITALIZATION BY. AS
MUCH AS SEVEN FIVE PERCENT. AND
GIVEN THAT DURING THE SURGE-
AND COVERT NINETEEN WE'VE SEEN
DIABETES RELATED
HOSPITALIZATIONS ACCOUNT FOR AS
MUCH AS THIRTY PERCENT. OF THE
PROBLEM. IS IT FAIR TO SAY THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WAS SHORT
SIGHTED- IN ITS OPPOSITION TO
MY LEGISLATION. ALL ONE OF OUR
GREAT. ALL THIS IS ADAM DORSEY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- YOU
KNOW I THINK THE WAY THAT I
WOULD LOOK AT THIS ISSUE- IS
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE A VALUE WAITED FOR A
COUPLE YEARS NOW AND IT'S PART
OF THE OVERALL CONTEXT OF ALL
THE RESOURCE DECISIONS THAT ARE
MADE AND SO- BUT WHILE WE AGREE
THERE IS. YOU KNOW AT AT AT
LEAST FOR CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS AND A BENEFIT TO YOU
PATIENTS- THERE'S ALSO A COST
ASSOCIATED WITH IT AND IT HAS
TO BE PRIORITIZED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL THE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MAKING AND SO. I
THINK THAT'S JUST THE LANDS IN
THE APPROACH THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE WITH THE WITH NOT ONLY
THAT BUT WITH WHAT ALL. CAPTION
AND YOU KNOW AT YOU EXPAND. ITS
THERE IS A COST THERE'S ALSO
BENEFIT AND SO. I'M HAVING TO
CONSTANTLY WEIGH THESE WITH ALL
OF THE OTHER. YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL EXPANSIONS THAT'S
THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO DO. I'LL GO AHEAD AND PUT
THAT DOWN AS A YES AND- DOUBLE
DOWN ON MY- YOU KNOW. SUPPORT
FOR. MY COLLEGE POINT WHICH IS
PREVENTION IS EXPENSIVE ON THE
FRONT END BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
AND WE'RE SEEING THE VERY REAL
WORLD CONSEQUENCES. OF THAT
ACTIVITY RIGHT NOW I ALSO WANNA
JUST REAL QUICKLY TOUCH ON SOME
ANSWERS YOU PROVIDE RECALLING
FROM SANTA BARBARA IN RESPECT
TO FEDERAL MONEY. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS NOT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES POSITION
THAT WERE. WAITING FOR THE
CAVALRY TO ARRIVE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THE
CAVALRY TO ARRIVE INFEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES. AND
UNDER BOTH. DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS WE-
ADDITIONAL THAT. SLOT
ACCREDITATION NURSING. IT HAS
BEEN A CALL FINANCER. AND SO I
HOPE ALTHOUGH I REALIZE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PRIORITIZE THESE
DOLLARS DURING. A CRISIS LIKE
THIS DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
IT IS NEVER BEEN. MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO. EXACTLY
THAT AND I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
WITH A QUESTION FOUR. OH YES
AND FINANCE WE RAISE THIS LAST
WEEK IN THIS COMMITTEE. THAT
THE EIGHT TO NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN KERR'S ACT FUNDING
THAT DID NOT GO DIRECTLY TO
LARGE COUNTIES OF FIVE ONE
THOUSAND MORE- I KNOW THE
POSITION IS LAST WEEK OR NOT
SURE HOW TO SPEND THAT I WANT
TO REITERATE. THAT I BELIEVE
THE- CALPERS AFTER SYSTEM
SECTION BE AMENDED TO COVER AS
MUCH AS ONE HUNDRED PERCENT-
FOR THE SMALL COUNTIES SO THAT
THAT FLEXIBLE PART OF MONEY. IS
AVAILABLE TO DEAL WITH THESE
NEAR TERM ISSUES AND AGAIN I
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNOR- AND FINANCED ELSE IS
PAYING INTO THE- TERM SMITH ON.
THESE OTHER HELP ISSUES. THANK
YOU GOODBYE BLOOM. THANK
PASSING A NOTE TO MIKE DOWN THE
OF. AT THANK YOU FOR THAT. COM
OF MR GRAY I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT IF THE- WE DID A
BETTER JOB OF UP PREVENTION
AND- ONE WOULD HOPE THAT FEWER
PEOPLE WOULD NEED THOSE
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS
BUT- I TAKE YOUR POINT. JUST
RETURNING VERY QUICKLY TO
CONTACT TRACING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT A VERY THOROUGH
DISCUSSION- AND I- WOULD ONLY
EMPHASIZE THAT WE NEED THAT
KIND OF- THOUGHTFUL DELIVERED
EVAN SCIENCE BASED APPROACH.
BOB TO- TO THIS ENTIRE ISSUE-
OF TESTING WHETHER- IT'S BLOOD
TESTING OR SEROLOGY TESTS OR-
THE CONTACT TRACING- WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT APPROACH LAID OUT AND
VERY CLEAR AND WE NEED TO GET
STARTED ON IT RIGHT AWAY
BECAUSE WE REALLY CANNOT- OPEN
UP THE ECONOMY. UNTIL WE HAVE
THOSE THINGS IN PLACE I THINK
THAT MUCH HAS BEEN- A VERY WELL
ESTABLISHED AND- IN LITERATURE
OUT THERE AND THE FOLKS WHO
ARE- OUT THERE FIGURING OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET A PLACE%
WHERE WE CAN RETURN TO GOOD
ECONOMY THE WHAT. THE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THERE BY EIGHT
JUST ARBITRARILY YOU KNOW
OPENING UP THE BEACH IS LIKE-
SOME COMMUNITIES TO LAST TO.
LAST WEEK AND JOB OUT WE NEED
TO HAVE MORE PLANNING AND MORE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND THE- IN IN
IN THE WAY WE DO THIS. AND I
HOPE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET
THERE SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
I UP. COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS.
ABOUT CITIES AND UP AND ABOUT
TRANSIT. HI I TRANSIT IS BEING
VERY VERY HARD HIT AS IS EVERY
OTHER SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY-
AND- WE'RE NOT IT WOULD IF THE
ABILITY TO GET FROM PLACE TO
PLACE DOESN'T EXIST FOR THE
WORK FORCE WHEN PEOPLE NEED TO
COME BACK TO WORK. OF A WE HAVE
AN UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM THAT TO- IS- IS GOING
TO BE A DRAG ON THE ECONOMY SO
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO PAY PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO-
AGAIN CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
BEING AS HARD HIT AS- AS THE AS
THE STATUS IN SOME CASES ARE
EVEN WORSE. AND I WANT TO URGE
THE- ADMINISTRATION TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS- WE TALK ABOUT ONE
ISSUE- LAST WEEK WITH THE- A
SALES TAX REBATE FOR BUSINESSES
IS A VERY WELL GROUNDED TO AND
A GOOD IDEA AND IT'S GONNA BE
VERY HELPFUL TO BUSINESS BUT IT
HASN'T UNINTENDED IMPACT ON. ON
ON LOCAL OMMUNITIES- AND THAT
WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
THE ORIGINAL DECISION WAS
MAKING OUT WITH MADE OF US A
SIMILARLY I THINK THE- ARE THE
FOR SENIORS. IS IN A GREAT
PROGRAM- BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT TO A- ON THE OUR
PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO BE
ADMINISTERED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND- I
WOULD URGE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO GIVE THOUGHT TO- HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO DO THAT. AT A
TIME WHEN THEY ARE- IN VERY
DEEP FINANCIAL DISTRESS
THEMSELVES AND- OR IF YOU WANT
TO RESPOND TO THAT BUT- IT IT
COULD BE JUST LEFT AS A
COMMENT- AT AT THIS POINT IF
THAT'S PREFERRED. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE WILL DEFINITELY IT
TAKE YOUR- FEEDBACK BACK I
THINK THE ONE THING WILL SAY
ON- THAT SUBJECT TO THE SENIOR
MALES IS THAT OUR EXPECTATION
IS THAT THAT THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE PAID
FOR BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
REGINA AND THE STATE WILL ALSO
BE- PROVIDING SOME
REIMBURSEMENT SO WHILE LOCALS
WILL- HAVE SOME EXPENDITURE. IT
WILL BE A SMALL PART OF THE
OVERALL COST. OKAY WELL ON
WORK- ANXIOUSLY AWAIT TO HEAR A
MORE DETAILS ON THAT- WHEN IT
COMES TO US SETTING GOALS I
THINK ONE OF OUR GOALS OUGHT TO
BE. THAT WE OF- NOT ALLOW THIS
PANDEMIC TO BE. THE END OF THE
MOM AND POP ECONOMY- WRIT LARGE
WHETHER IT'S RESTAURANTS AND TO
A SMALL MARKETS- OF A RETAIL
OUTLETS- LANDLORDS WITH THE-
WITH SMALL BUILDING SMALL.
BUSINESS START UPS OF ACROSS
THE BOARD. OF THE THAT IS BAD
ROCK CALIFORNIA'S ITS- BEDROCK
CUT. AMERICA AND WE REALLY
CANNOT ALLOW THAT TO DISAPPEAR
SO THAT SHE- DOES SOMETHING A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO. I'M FINE I
WANT TO THERE THERE WERE SOME
COME ABOUT. OF THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT REGULATIONS AT NEVER
BEEN CONSTRUCTED WITH INTENT TO
STYMIE BUSINESS GROW CAL BROKE
GROWTH. OF CALIFORNIA HAS
REALLY BEEN AT THE LEAD OF
SHOWING HOW OU CAN DEVELOP
PUBLIC HEALTH REGULATIONS THAT
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AND STILL
GROW THE CONOMY ALL WE HAVE TO
DO IS LOOK AT THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AGO HERE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT AND SO THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES TO HAVE A
CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. OF WE CANNOT
ALLOW PUBLIC HEALTH TO TEND TO.
NOT BE THE PRIMARY
CONSIDERATION IN THE OVERALL
APPROACH TO KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTHY AB AND
THRIVING ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE- THE MOST BURDEN TO THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES I
BEGAN BY- A SPEAKING ABOUT. A
WHO ARE BURDENED BY POLLUTION-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A-
INDULGING ME FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
AND THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
BLOOM- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
DOCTOR WHAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- JUST- JUST A
COUPLE POINTS- I THINK EARLIER-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROKE BROUGHT
UP THE CONCEPT OF UNIVERSAL
PROTECTIONS AND- I MIGHT CHANGE
THE PHRASE OF THAT A LITTLE BIT
AND BECAUSE OF MY PROFESSION WE
CALL UNIVERSAL PRECAUTIONS AND
SO WE TREAT EVERYBODY AS IF
THEY ARE POTENTIALLY INFECTIOUS
REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER. AND
THAT REALLY BEGAN- NGUYEN WITH
THE ONSET OF THE HIV CRISIS AND
SO WE ARE VERY CUSTOM TO
TREATING EVERYBODY AS IF THEY
ARE INFECTED BY WHO KNOWS WHAT
AND SO I THINK- I THINK WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS THERE
GOING TO BE SOME GUIDANCE ON
WHAT UNIVERSAL PRECAUTIONS
MIGHT BE LIKE FOR DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY- BASED
ON UPON THE RISK SO. AND YOU
KNOW I'M JUST I JUST A LITTLE
GOOGLE SEARCH HERE WITH REGARDS
TO MISTER GRAY AND KING
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS I
THINK THEY COST ACCORDING WOULD
GO. BETWEEN ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS APIECE- THAT IS
A- VERY VERY SMALL PRICE WHEN
YOU CONSIDER WHAT IT COSTS FOR
AN EMERGENCY ROOM VISIT- AND SO
THAT'S WHEN WE TO ASK WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PREVENTION. YOU
KNOW EMERGENCY ROOM BUSINESS
COULD BE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS-
FOR SOMEONE WHO MIGHT GOING TO
HAVE A CRISIS AND- AND THAT
COULD BE IT ALL SORTS OF
COMPLICATIONS AROUND AROUND
DIABETES SO WE HAVE A VERY VERY
RICH. OF PHARMACEUTICALS FOR
MEDI CAL POPULATION- RICHER
THAN MANY COMMERCIAL PLANTS AND
SO- IT IS A LITTLE BIT- MIND
BOGGLING THAT ON THIS DEVICE
WHICH IS MEDICARE COVERED AS
WELL- WE CAN'T GET THIS WILL
CROSS THE LINE SO ANYONE. THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS. OKAY THING
I'M NOT I WAS GONNA GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE ONE ONE
PERSON FOR PUBLIC IN PERSON
COMMENT THAT WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN-
JOHN LEVEL REPRESENTING A
NUMBER OF CLIENTS I'D USE UP MY
MINUTE IF I WENT THROUGH THE
MOBILE EVERYONE WAS CONCERNED-
I WANTED TO. HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS AT THIS HEARING THAT
I THINK DESERVE. EXTRAORDINARY
ATTENTION- DOCTOR WOODS SENSE
OF URGENCY ON PPVS- I THINK
SHOULD BE EMBRACED BY EVERYONE
BECAUSE IT IS REALLY A MARRIAGE
OF SMART. ECONOMY DEVELOPMENT
AGAIN- AND ALSO HEALTH CARE-
THE FACT IS THAT HIS DOCTOR
WOULD SAID THERE'S A WHOLE HOST
OF PROFESSIONS THAT DEPEND ON
PPVS AND THAT URGENCY IS GROWN-
AND- ITHINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE.
SHOULD FOCUS ON- TOWARD
REBUILDING THE ECONOMY AND-
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THAT-
REBUILDING- SO THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED TO FOCUS ON I WOULD ALSO
CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE BLUE
NEED NEW DEAL- COMMENTS OF
MISTER GRAY I THINK THOSE ARE
WORTHY OF- FOR THE- HIM BRACING
AS WELL GREAT HEARING AGAIN
JUST UNDER. FAMILIES AND OF
OURS AND USED TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN FULL TIME
LIVE YOU EXEMPLIFIED TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
CALLERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING. FIRST CALLER. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS REMINDER IF
YOU HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT WE
NEED YOU TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WOULD PRESS ONE THEN IT ZERO
WE'LL GO TO DARBY KERN AND FOR
THE FIRST. COMMENTS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU STARTED
RUNNINGWITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
TODAY'S FOCUS ON HOW TO RESTART
THE ECONOMY IS IMPORTANT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU UNDERSTAND THE
ROLE CALIFORNIA COUNTIES PLAY
IN THE ECONOMY. EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES EMPLOYED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL WHO SERVED
IN MANY DIFFERENT ROLE. COUNTY
PROVIDE THE CORE SERVICES ALL
YOUR CONSTITUENTS DEPEND UPON.
HEY WELL OVER THIRTY POINT SIX
BILLION IN WAGES WHAT'S MORE
THAN TEN BILLION IN RETIREMENT
AND HEALTH CONTRIBUTION. A
MAJORITY OF OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
UNION EMPLOYEES. MY POINT WITH
THIS INFORMATION IS THAT
COUNTIES ARE AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE- AND THAT IS WHY IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION IN FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUND DESIGNATED FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES. GET ALLOCATED
TO ALL COUNTY THE UNIT POSSIBLE
THE COUNTY CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THOSE CRITICAL
SERVICES. AND MY FINAL POINT IS
THAT ANY ECONOMIC RECOVERY HAVE
INCLUDES COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CALLER
APPLE A PUBLIC COMMENT FROM GM
LATE STREAMLINED OF OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT THE
THIRD HERE'S ACT- FEDERAL
STIMULUS CERTAINLY HELP BART
BRIDGE THE OPERATING LOSSES FOR
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR HOWEVER
WITH THE 60% FAREBOX RECOVERY
HISTORICALLY WE EXPECT A
GRADUAL RE OPENING TO LEAD TO
VERY GRADUAL RIDERSHIP GROWTH
IN ANTICIPATE FUTURE STIMULUS.
NEEDING TO BE PROVIDED TO
TRANSIT AGENCIES GOING FORWARD
TO MEET OUR OWN OBLIGATIONS AND
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- IN THEIR BAY AREA
COMMUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE COMMENT
FROM WHERE AT TOP THE LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH WE WERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- LIKE
MOST TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES OF
WE'VE HEARD OF PTSD NO
ADDUCTION OF MORE THAN 70% IN
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. 90% PARA
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. AND UP FOR
US AS WELL THE FEDERAL
OCCASION- INSTANTLY HOPEFUL BUT
WHAT WE'RE MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT- IT'S A LONG TERM EFFECT
OF THE LAS SALES TAX REVENUE.
WHICH MAKES UP THE BULK OF HOW
WE PAY FOR OUR TRANSIT AND
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. BUT
YOU KNOW TO PUT THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY SUPPORT
SIGNIFICANT HIGHWAYS
CONSTRUCTION JOB. WE WERE THAT
WITH THAT WITH THE DUCK
REDUCTION IN TAX REVENUES. THAT
MAY HINDER OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER PROJECTS AND LASTLY
WE'VE IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
ZERO COST RELIEF MEASURES.
WOULD HELP TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES DURING THE TOP TYPICAL
PRIME. THERE ARE INEVITABLY A
HAD WILL LIKE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT MEASURE CAN LOOK
FOR TO WORKING. WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE COMMENT NEAR
INGRAM FILLING IS A- WHICH HOW
MY ANGER MAY STILL CAL. CAL
STIMULUS EFFORT SHOULD BE
DESIGNED TO ENCOMPASS THE GREAT
DIVERSITY OF OUR FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS YEAH THE ANALYZE
WHICH RESIDENTS WERE EXCLUDED
FROM THE FROM BUT FEDERAL AID
WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS
SLAPPED ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
BEHIND AND HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
REMEDIES THESE PROBLEMS. YEAH
BUT ANY RESPONSE ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMIC ECONOMIC DISPARITIES
IN OUR STATE INCLUDING
DISPARITIES THAT RESULT FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL CITIZENSHIP STATUS
RACIAL OR ETHNIC. GENDER A
GENDER. ORIENTATION STATUS
DISABILITY STATUS OR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT YEAH BUT
STIMULUS IS INCLUSIVE IN THE
BROAD RANGE OF OUR WORK FORCES
EMPLOYMENT TYPE AND THE FACT
THAT SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND MARGINALIZE
INDIVIDUALS ENGAGED IN
DANGEROUS WORK TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY AND HAVE A TURNING
ECONOMIC STABILITY TOWARDS
STATE UNITS INCLUDING THEM IN
STIMULUS PLANTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS WE OF COMMENT
FROM JULIA JORDAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JULIA GARNER THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY- THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS IN WHICH THE
CURRENT CRISIS BROUGHT TO LIGHT
I'M EXISTING INEQUITIES THAT
IMPACT COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK
WITH THE THAT LOOKING IN
EASTERN GOOD SHOW ALWAYS- I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE LONG FOR HER COMMENTS. ARE
NOT LEADING IN AREAS OF THE
STATE WITH A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE HELPFUL JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW MORE THE NEEDS
THAT WE'RE FEEDING INCLUDING-
RENTAL MARKET IN UTILITY
ASSISTANCE- DOUBLING DOWN
EFFORT TO PROVIDE SAFE. HOUSING
TENANTS BASED EDUCATION THE
WITH THE- PROVIDING PP AIM
WHICH IS OFTEN MENTIONED TODAY
IN THE PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS
AND LONG TERM EXPANSION OF
BENEFITS THAT INCLUDE.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. WOMEN
EXPANDED PAVE THE HELPED ACT
AND SOCIAL SAFETY NET ALSO.
STRENGTHEN OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL SAYS. SWITCHING
INCREASE LONG TERM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY IN AGRICULTURE
PRIORITIZING PROCUREMENT
COMPATIBLE SMALL SCALE FARMS
AND FARMERS OF COLOR. AND
ENSURING LONG TERM GOOD ACTORS
IN ADDITION TO EMERGENCY FOOD
SECURITY- EXPANDING MOBILE HOT
SPOTS IN BROADBAND BOTH THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
TO CONNECTIVITY FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH NOTIFICATIONS EDUCATION
AND THE ECONOMY. AND REALLY
MAKING HER OR NOT REMAINS
ACTIVE ARE MIDDLE REGULATIONS
THE PROTECTION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- HEY WE HAVE COMMENT FROM
TERRY BRENNAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A GERMAN TANK THE MEMBER
PLANNING. CAPTION AT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF THE FEW
OF US WHO'S BEEN AROUND LONG
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER. HEONE
PROBABLY FROM THE THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT AND I THINK- S.
CI USE CONCERNED THAT WE- IN
THIS RECOVERY NOT REPEAT PAST
HISTORY BUT LEARN FROM IT OUR
EXPERIENCE FROM THAT. ACTIVITY
WAS THAT- WE DID THAT CUT.
PRIMARILY TO THE SAFETY NET.
HEY I'M TO HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION AREAS THAT WE'VE
STILL YOU STILL NOT FULLY
RECOVERED FROM- AND THAT THE-
THE BULK OF THE BENEFIT
ACTUALLY EXACERBATED THE-
INCOME INEQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND INCREASED PROPERTY SO BE
MINDFUL AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
REMEMBER WHO'S- FUELING THIS
RECOVERY. THERE'S NOT EVEN
THOUGH THE LAST RECOVERY
BENEFITTED. DISPROPORTIONATELY
THE WEALTHY MILLIONAIRE. WE
CAN'T IGNORE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S NOT ONE MILLION THERE
HELPING. BAYLESS OUT ON THE
HEALTHCARE WORLD THERE'S NOBODY
ON MINOR OP. WE HAVE GOT A
COMMENT FROM MICHAEL PIMENTEL
MICHAEL PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
RIDERSHIP IN REVENUE LOSSES
EXPERIENCED BY PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES DURING THE PANDEMIC
FORCE THEM BECAUSE THE BAND OR
DRAMATICALLY CURTAIL SERVICE.
FORTUNATELY THE WORK THE CUTS
THE ONES THAT WERE ON THE RIGHT
THEN THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THAT
WOULD HAVE DEALT DEVASTATING
BLOW TO REGIONAL CONNIE'S WERE
AVOIDED BUT THE PASSAGE OF THE
FEDERAL TERROR ATTACK. BUT MAKE
NO MISTAKE THE CARD THAT
PROVIDES ONLY SHORT TERM
FUNDING TO STOP THE BLEEDING
AND TO ENSURE TRANSIT AGENCIES
CAN CONTINUE TO KERRY ESSENTIAL
WORKER. IN MAY SOON BECOME
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE
REPORT TRANSIT AGENCIES FURTHER
WITH THE DEFAULT FUNKY TRANSIT
AGENCIES RUNNING BOOK ACCORDING
OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE OF
COURSE HAVE YOUR STAND THAT
THERE ARE THEORIES AND
COMPETING NEED FOR LIMITED
STATE RECORDED HOWEVER AS YOU
CONSIDER HOW DO AND BETH EACH
RESOURCES. LIKE THE ECONOMY
PLEASE CONSIDER THAT PUBLIC
TRANSIT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE INVESTMENT
IT CREATES GOOD PAYING CAREER
PLANNING JOB INCLUDING INTO.
MANUFACTURING. AND TRADE.
ORTEGA ENVIRONMENTAL IN THEIR
CALL GOAL. AND IT BUILDS MORE
EQUITABLE HELLO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDER. THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO JULIE SCHNEIDER PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LATER GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE SAME
BURKE INSTITUTE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY- IN
PARTICULAR TO HIGHLIGHT COPE
ITS IMPACT ON BOARDING CARE
HOMES AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE FIELD- THIS VITAL PIECE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SPECTRUM
PROVIDES AN AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE MEDICATION ASSISTANCE AND
OTHER CARE FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESSES.
OVER THE PAST DECADE INCREASING
NUMBER OF BOARDING CARE SOME
CLOSE DUE TO RISING COSTS AN
AGING PROVIDER POPULATION NOW
THE COSTS OF COMPLYING WITH
HOPE IT RELATED DIRECTIVES TO
HAVE FURTHER INCREASE THE
FINANCIAL PRESSURES AND THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING THIS
CRUCIAL HOUSING OPTION FOR
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESSES SH- WELL LONG WITH
ALLIES WE SUGGESTED OPTIONS TO
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR DRAWING
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS. TO COVER A
PORTION OF BOARDING CARE CODE
RELATED COSTS WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE- TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
MOVE THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO BLANCA CASTRO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE A STATEMENT ON WANT TO
CASTRO WITH A RP CALIFORNIA AND
WE REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE. JUST
WANTED TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION AND HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL FOLLOW UP ON
THIS GOOD ON APRIL TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY APARTMENT A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE- GUIDELINES
TO ALL HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
HOSPITALS IN PARTICULAR TITLED
HOT HEALTH CARE. SEARCH CRISIS
CARE GUIDELINES AND- WHAT'S
MOST TROUBLING AND WHAT WAS
MOST TROUBLING ABOUT THIS TO A.
R. P IS FAT IN THIS OP
GUIDANCE THE- THERE IS A
DIRECTION THAT THEY IT THAT IN
THE EVENT THERE IS A SURGE IN
CASES- IN HOSPITALS. WHERE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH VENTILATORS
ARE NOT ENOUGH GOAL. FIVE THERE
HOSPITAL USE H. AS A
DETERMINING IN HERE IS A
STATEMENT DIRECTLY FROM A
LETTER THAT WE SUGGEST
LIFECYCLE CONSIDERATIONS SHOULD
BE USED AS A TIE BREAKER IF
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE ALL PATIENTS WITHIN
A PRIORITY GROUP WITH PRIORITY
GOING TO YOUNGER PATIENTS OKAY
YEAH NOT ONLY IS THIS. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE GO NEXT TO MARK
WHAT MARK GOING IS OPEN. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
CHARGING AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
TENOR OF THIS HEARING THAT YOU
HAVE UNDER WAY AND WE THANK YOU
FOR FOCUSING IN NOW ON
POTENTIAL FUTURE RECOVERY AND
ECONOMIC STIMULUS. I REPRESENT
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WHICH
THE COALITION OF TRANSPORTATION
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY LABOR AND
MATERNAL PROVIDERS. OUR
INDUSTRY ALONG WITH OUR ALLIES
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE DEPARTMENT
UNDER THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
SERVICE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
WE ARE ALL ANXIOUSLY AWAITING
THE STATE UPDATED ESTIMATES OF
ACTOR TRAFFIC VOLUMES AND
THEREFORE WHAT THE VERY DIRECT
IMPACT OF THE LESSON VOLUMES
ARE GOING TO HAVE ON THE
UNDERLYING READ THE RESOURCES.
HAVE FUN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS IN MAINTENANCE AND
IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES. OUR
BOARD OF OUR ORGANIZATION IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE RECENT
CALL AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL BI
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. FUNDING
ASSISTANCE THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO MEET THE REVENUE
LOSSES THAT WE ANTICIPATE MAN
HAVE RECOGNIZED. HOW WE DO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT HE CARES ACT
PROVIDED PRESIDENTIAL CATCH UP
OPPORTUNITY. THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS EXPLAINED BY THEY CAN
TELL. YOU THAT IT THANK YOU. WE
DON'T TO KELLY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIAASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR FOCUS TODAY ON THE AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THIS CRISIS
I KEY ECONOMIC DRIVER IN TERMS
OF COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
EMPLOYMENT REST IN THE TWENTY
ONE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THERE NINETY
ONE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES OTHER
FRONTLINE WORKERS FOR CARE
FIRST IT'S MOST VULNERABLE CODE
NINETEEN PATIENTS WE CANNOT
REOPEN THE ECONOMY IF WE DON'T
HAVE A FUNCTIONING HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM TO KEEP PEOPLE
HEALTHY AND EMPLOYED AT THE
CRACK OF HAVE PUT A STRAIN ON
PUBLIC HOSPITALS WOOD BURKE
AGREED AND TALENT EVEN BEFORE-THE PANDEMIC. NOW COST
PRESSURES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
EVEN KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
COLLECTIVELY ESTIMATE OCCURRING
ROUGHLY THREE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS IN COSTA LOTS
REVENUE DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE. BETWEEN MARCH AND
AUGUST OF THIS YEAR. A PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AND ONLY
GOING TO GROW. THEY ALREADY.
HEALTH CARE 240% OF THE STATE'S
UNINSURED AND 35% OF MEDI CAL
PATIENTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
GIVEN THAT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS DUE TO CORONAVIRUS
TO BE EXPECT THESE NUMBERS TO
INCREASE. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
PLEASE CONSIDER THE IMPORTANCE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THE KEY ELEMENT IN THE STATE'S
PHYSICAL AND ECONOMIC WELL
BEING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE COMMENT FROM. ROME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE VICTORIA ROME
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. LATER TODAY
WILL BE SENDING A COALITION
LETTER SIGNED BY MORE THAN
THREE DOZEN ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND CLEAN ECONOMY
ORGANIZATION. OUTLINING
PATHWAYS FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REBUILD THE ECONOMY IN A WAY
THAT IMPROVE THEIR RESILIENCE
AND ADVANCES OUR STATE
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE CHANGE
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES AND WORKERS AND
MORE. EASILY THE PATHWAYS
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER INCLUDE
FIRST EXAMPLE THE PROGRAM BUT
SHOULD RECEIVE STIMULUS. TO
IMPROVE HEALTH RESILIENCE AND
CREATE JOBS. SECOND SECURITIZED
ONGOING REVENUE STREAMS TO
INCREASE THE IMPACT AND
LONGEVITY OF THOSE DOLLARS ONE
EXAMPLE BEING THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION BOND. AND THIRD
MATCH DIRECT EXPENDITURES WITH
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE TO INVEST IN
ADDITIONAL RESILIENT RECOVERY
MEASURES THE LETTER INCLUDES
SEVERAL EXAMPLES AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ITH YOU AND
OTHER STATE LEADERS TO INSURE
GREEN AND RESULT RECOVERY THANK
pYOU. AND COMMENT FROM TYLER
TRENTON PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS TRIED ON
BEHALF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IT IS CRITICAL THE SPEAK
CONTINUE TO FUND THE CONVERSION
OF DIRTY NEEDLE TRUCKS TO
ELECTRIC AND YOU'RE A MISSION
VEHICLE THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE AND KIND OF
PROGRAM THAT CAR. WITH A FOCUS
CURRENTLY ON HOW RESTORE
ILLNESS YOU GOT TO RETELL DOG
COMES WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING CAUSE HEALTH IMPACT.
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES ARE A MAJOR
SOURCE OF LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CURRENTLY LEAPING 35% OF
STATEWIDE NITROGEN OXIDES AND
25% STATE WIDE LEGAL PARTICULAR
MATTER MISSION. DESPITE MAKING
IT JUST 7% OF VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. OF THE CALIFORNIA'S DIE
EACH YEAR TO TRANSPORTATION
COALITION AIR POLLUTION CAUCUS
HEART DISEASE DIABETES AND LUNG
DISEASE IN PEOPLE SUFFERING
FROM THE THESE ARE GREATER
RISK. FOR ILLNESS RECOVER
NINETEEN FOR THESE REASONS TO
PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH.
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
REQUEST THAT YOU FIND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE IN A PROGRAM A
CARD. WITH AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO READ
IT WAS ONE OF LAST YEAR. AND WE
ALSO REQUEST THAT YOU CONSIDER
PETER STIMULATE ACTION THAT YOU
THINK ABOUT USING THE NON
REPAIR FUND TO PLAY HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE CHARGING A- THE CHARTER
TROUBLE READY THANK YOU
ANCHORAGE OUT QUICKLY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND COMMENT FROM
MARVIN PINEDA PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEDICARE MEMBERS BOB MARTIN BE
THEY'LL BE HAVE A PRIDE IN THE
STREET A FIVE ONE TWO THREE I'M
NONPROFIT WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING A WAIVER FROM THE
CALIFORNIANS REQUIREMENT IT
FIVE A ONE TO THE NONPROFIT
REMEMBER THE STATE FROM
COMPLAINING CHARGES. WHEN THOSE
CHARGES ARE FOR COLIN NINETEEN
WITH A ON A PRIVATE PLANE MANY
NONPROFIT EMPLOYEES HAVE
VOLUNTARILY FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT OR FROM BEEN FACT
CHECKED DOWN FROM NONPROFIT
CAN'T SURVIVE WITHOUT THE-
STATE I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBER THE MALL CRAWL HER
SUPPORT AND LEADERSHIP- IN AT.
ALL NONPROFIT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
COMMENT. FROM JEREMY SMITH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE CAN
GERMAN. WE GOT THE BUILDING
TRUST TRADE CAN AND ARE FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBERS. SIXTY
THOUSAND. WE HEAR TO ADD YOU
THAT YOU FIND A WAY TO REVIVED
ON THE IN MOST THE STRUCK
STRAIGHT OVER THE OF A MY.
REALLY LATEST QUAKE WHAT THE
ECONOMY BE TO LOOK. YOU'RE
QUITE ONE THAT OF LOCAL COLLAR.
THESE WORKERS SPEND ABOUT YOUR
YOUR THAT MONEY LOCALLY
BOOSTING INCOMES CAL WHAT AND
THAT. WE BACKING IN A SPENDING
ONE OF PROJECT. THAT GETS LOCAL
BACK IN THE ALL HELPED STATE
AND LOCAL I THAT CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS BY LAKE DO NOT HAVE TO
BACK ON A BUDGET. BUT THE
HEALTH INCOME. OUR TO HELP
ECONOMY WALKER BODY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I'LL GO TO OUR A
FIELD AND SALAS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER THANK YOU FOR THAT VERY
ROBUST DISCUSSION ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTHORITY WE WOULD LIKE TO
IMPLORE. YOU TO NOT INHIBIT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BY UNDER
FUNDING THE EIGHT LEGAL AND
MORAL OBLIGATION. REGION WE
APPRECIATE THINGS ARE DIRE AT
THE RESULT THE PANDEMIC THE
THING HAVE BEEN DIRE AND HE'S
PROP TWENTY. AND CHRONIC. TO
TALK TO THAT ALL BY THE
COLLAPSES PROBABLY MADE THE
PENDANT MUCH MORE AND REGION.
CONTROL THE ROCKS WHICH WILL
FROM THE RIVER INTO THE FROM
THE- OR BETTER YOU HOW ENABLE
TO CREATE OF A- MAY CONTROL
TALK THAT THAT THE MEASURE. OUR
ARE ABOUT IN ECONOMIC RECOVERY
WOULD HELP THE YOU WILL HOLD ON
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO.
ATRIA JEFFREY GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS. BUT YOU NEED TO LOOK AND
SEE TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT
THREE YEARS FROM NOW AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT IS THE BEST
INVESTMENTS YOU ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE NOW WHENYOUR NEXT
YEAR PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE
HOUSE OF THE- TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET. SO PLEASE MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS BUT PLEASE ALSO
SUPPORT THESE AREAS OF HEALTH.
THE AREA OF THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING YEP THOSE THINGS FUNDED
SO WE KNOW WHAT IN THE WORLD IS
GOING ON WE SEE THE
DISPARITIES. LET US SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO BEST WAY TO CORRECT THEM
IN TO DO THE BEST INVESTING NOW
EXPECTING THAT IT MAY BE THREE
YEARS BEFORE WE WILL BE BACK
TO. WHAT WE WERE LIKE LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU. AND WE GO TO A
LENDER TO NARROW IT A LINDA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY-
WE JUST LIKE TO SHED LIGHT AT
THE END WITH THE CALIFORNIA CAN
I THINK HEALTH NETWORK- AND WE
JUST LIKE TO SHED LIGHT ON THE
FACT THAT DISPARITIES HAVE
EXISTED- FOR A LONG TIME-
BEFORE CORBETT. AND CORBETT HAS
ONLY EXACERBATED YOU KNOW IN
ALREADY VERY BAD SITUATION- SO
WE JUST ASK THAT FOR ANY- PLANS
ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT WILL
REALLY ENGAGING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION- FOLKS AT THE
GRASSROOTS LEVEL TO CONSULT
THEM ABOUT WHAT. RECOVERY
REALLY LOOKS LIKE- FOR THAT- WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND FOR HOLDING
THE STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE COMMENT FROM TROPICAL
ABORTION THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON FAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BILL FULL BORE HOT BUT
PRESIDING SACRAMENTO BEE
TRANSIT. FACULTY BECOME MUCH
MORE THAN JUST TRANSIT AGENCY
THE PEN WE PRIDE THE HELP THAT
SOCIAL PAR. WITH EXPAND SERVICE
AT THE PORT FOOD DELIVERY FOR
SENIOR THAT WOULD BE NAME
TRANSFER FOR HOME WITH AT RISK
POPULATION. PARTNERED WITH US
AND EVEN TURNER BUSES INTO WHY
BIBLE HOT SPOT TO HELP TO FIX
LEARN AND DAY TO DAY WE ADAPT
ARE OFTEN IS ORDER A DIFFERENT
MEANING. I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER FALL SUPPORT
TRANSIT AGENCY THEY REPORTED A
PUBLIC TRANSIT INCLUDING
OFFICIAL WORK IT PARAMOUNT THE
REPUBLIC CAL. AND PUBLIC
TRACKED EIGHTY PEOPLE FACTORED
BY ANY PART IN A RIVER THE
EIGHT ECONOMY. WE DON'T DO
PAMELA WE PROVIDE STOP WELL
BEFORE SMALL BUSINESS THE
REPORT AND BARBARA BOTH AND
PROVIDE DEL HAPPY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO. IN ORDER TO I
MEAN GO AHEAD I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF THERE ARE NO MORE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES WEEDING FOR
COMMENT IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
NOT COMMENT I THINK YOU'VE MADE
YOUR POINT THANK YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO SHARE AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL COOK ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES CLEAN
TECH INCUBATOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IS ACCELERATOR FOR THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE CREATION
OF AN INCLUSIVE GREEN ECONOMY-
IN TERMS OF REBUILDING THE
ECONOMY FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAVE
IDENTIFIED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN SHOVEL READY NEAR
SHOVEL READY PILOT PROJECT ONE
B. I. SEVEN TEN FREEWAY THE
INLAND EMPIRE ACROSS THE
GREATER LA REGION IN NEED OF
FUNDING THAT COULD EMPLOYEE-
UNDER AN UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIA.
AT LEVI'S DRAWING ON THAT
EXPERIENCE MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO REBUILD
THE ECONOMY WHICH WILL BECOME
MORE IN OUR WRITTEN COMMENTS A
HIGH LEVEL RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE BETHNAL BUT THE
CASE INFRASTRUCTURE UP WALL
CLOCK THE VEHICLE AND BUILDING
MORE RELIABLE ELECTRIC GRID-
WILL RECOMMENDING THAT WE THE
STATE USE REGIONAL LOCAL
PROCUREMENT INCENTIVES WALK
BETTER ON SENTENCE INCREASED
MORE EVEY DESIGNED ASSEMBLY
MANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE IN
BATON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
CLEAN TECH JOB TRAINING. IN
MANUFACTURING I WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CREATE A NEW ZERO
EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION AND
GOODS MOVEMENT A FORTY FIVE
MINUTE THING THAT'S ALREADY IN
THE ABILITY TO COORDINATE
ACROSS THE AGENCIES AND FINALLY
WE'RE WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE EXTENDED
INCREASE CURRENT CLEAN TECH
ECOSYSTEM SUPPORT CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS FOR ZERO MISSION
ABILITY START UP IN PILOT IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU.
I'LL GO TO THE SAN OUT WHY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AND YOUR CONCERN FOR
HELPING OUR STATE WOULD COVER
MY NAME IS SANDRA WALL AND
AGAIN I LOOK AT BILL YOU WORK
OKAY LAST TWENTY TWO YEARS.
CONNECT PEOPLE THE CHILD CARE
AND HELP THEM TO CONTINUE WITH
THEIR EMPLOYMENT AND ARE
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND HOPES TO
EVENTUALLY ELIMINATE THEIR NEED
FOR A- BECAUSE I WORK WITH
PEOPLE IN AN ONGOING WAY I HE I
HEAR HOW HARD IT IS TO MAKE
PROGRESS AND MOVE FROM NEEDING
HELP TO BEING SELF SUFFICIENT.
IN ORDINARY TIME SURVIVING IN
CALIFORNIAIS ALREADY A
STRUGGLE OUR CLIENTS ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON IT ON THE TABLE AND KEEP A
ROOF OVER THEIR FAMILIES HAS.
NOW THAT THERE OVERWHELMING
I'VE BEEN REASSIGNED FROM CHILD
CARE TO EXPEDITED SERVICE.
HELPING FAMILIES CONNECT THE
CALIBRATION ADEQUATE I HAVE
NEVER IN MY LIFE WITNESS SO
MUCH MEAT AND SO MUCH
DESPERATION EVERY PART OF OUR
SAFETY NET WANT. WE NEVER
REALLY RECOVERED FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT GREAT RECESSION
AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN ONLY WITH
A BIGGER HURDLE IN FRONT OF
THAT. I SEE A MASSIVE NEED
COMING UP IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS AND WE DO NOT HAVE THE
STAFF IN CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH
THOSE. THAT NO LONGER HAVE JOBS
TO GO BACK TO. WE ARE TO
RECOVER WE TO KEEP THE FAMILY.
FOLLOW OFF THE- WE NEED TO. AND
RESTORE TO DO IT. RIGHT THIRTY
CRY YOUR- BUILDING WHICH LONGER
STAY THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT WILL GO TO DAN INJECT SUN OF
DOWN THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VRY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER GROSS TERMINAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FIRST
I MEAN ONE AND NOT ONLY THANK
YOURSELVES BUT- ALSO EVERYBODY
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS A REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME PEOPLE ARE
STEPPING UP. TO IS I THINK
THERE'S LESS YOU CAN LEARN FROM
HISTORY. IN PAST RECESSIONS AND
THE CLIMATE CHANGE. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS IS SLOWER THAN
COVERT NINETEEN. BUT THE IMPACT
AND JUSTICE DEVASTATING. WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON CLEAN ENERGY
AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. IN
ORDER TO HELP US WE FOUND OUT
OF THE RECESSION. AND STAVE OFF
THE WORST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. WILL SUBMIT WRITTEN
COMMENTS AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
COMMENT FROM ALYSSA SO HI
ALYSSA PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALIKE WITH A HOW BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION AND A DISTRICT ON
THE FRONT LINES TO COVER
NINETEEN RESPOND ENSURING THE
DELIVERY OF CRITICAL LOCAL
SERVICES INCLUDING WATER
WASTEWATER FIRE V. PROTECTING
TRANSIT HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
IMPLICIT BONTA AMONG OTHERS. I
DON'T THINK I COULD BE ON THAT
NEEDS INSERTED GAP MAY BE
FACING COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
FIND IF HE IF WE CONSIDER THE
ESSENTIAL ROLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS AN ECONOMIC
DRIVER. THAT'S A DIFFERENT
BRAIN DEFENSELESS PROCESS OF AN
EMPLOYER AND BY PROVIDING A
STABLE ENVIRONMENT FOR COMMERCE
AND LYFT FLORIST TO OPERATING
CRITICAL PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS NOT ONLY
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT THE PRE
REQUISITE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THE CONSEQUENCES
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT RUN THE
SHOP FOR ALL THE REDUCE GOTTEN
SERVICE LEVELS LIVE THE LIFE WE
HAD A COMMUNITY IS MUST BE
CONSIDERATION OF CONTEXT THE
DISCUSSION. WE APPRECIATE HOW
MUCH THE COMMITTEE CAN BRING
IMPACT LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
CONTINUE TO ASK BUT THE
DISTRICT RECEIVE AN EQUITABLE
SHARE OF FINANCIAL RELIEF FROM
FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS. AND
EXPLICITLY INCLUDINGSTATE
BUDGET DETERMINATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I WILL GO AM KING
PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU NUMBER
WITH ADDITION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE REPRESENTING THE
OTHER THING THAT THE AND THE OF
THE STATE HOSPITAL WE ARE
DEEPLY CAN ABOUT AND I TO CARE
AND THE COMMUNITY THEY ARE
DISTRICT ARE RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
MOSTLY CONCERNED WITH KEEPING
OUR GUARD UP AND THEY ARE EAGER
TO BEGIN ELECTIVE AND THAT
PREVENTED IT. IS WITH. AND
PRETTY SOON. SIMILAR THE
COMMENT BY MEMBER AND WOOD AND
GRAY THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
HAVING THE RESOURCES. TO
CONTINUE THE THERMOSTAT IS
MOSTLY. WORK FOR IT AND P. P.
CAN CAN YOU BE. IN A CAR TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ON EFFORT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU OUR NEXT WE
GO TO LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER THE
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M WITH YOU
FELT PEOPLE CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT. AS A FAMILY MEMBER
LEE MON POINTED OUT NONPROFIT
ARE STEPPING UP DURING THIS
CRISIS AS THEY DO IN ANY CRISIS
TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
AND OTHER VITAL PROGRAMS. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIGHLIGHTED
THAT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR IS
THE FOURTH LARGEST EMPLOYER BY
INDUSTRY THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT
OF OVER A MILLION JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT NONPROFIT CAN'T
KEEP STEPPING UP FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND CAN'T KEEP
STAFF ON BOARD WITHOUT
RESOURCES. WITH NEARLY TWELVE
HUNDRED NON PROFITS THAT FIND
OUR LETTER TO STATE LEADERS
WILL BE ITERATING ARE AFTER THE
STATE SUPPORT NON PROFITS BY
ENSURING THAT UP PROFITS
CONTINUE TO GET PAID ON STATE
CONTRACTS AND HAVE CONTRACT
FLEXIBILITY. BY ALLOCATING
EMERGENCY FUNDS THAT ADDRESS
INCREASED COSTS. AND BY
INCLUDING NONPROFITS AND RELIEF
PROGRAMS FOR EMPLOYERS
COMMERCIAL TENANTS IN UTILITY
RATE PAYERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ADD A COMMENT FROM RONALD
COLMAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON RENTAL COMING HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACTORS
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS VERY MUCH
AGREES WITH THE SENTIMENTS FROM
DOCTOR REGULAR THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET PROJECT AND MANY OTHERS
HAVE ABOUT THE NEED TO ENSURE
WE HAVE THE SAFETY NET AND
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM IN PLACE
THAT SUPPORTS RECOVERY FOR ALL
OF OUR STATE VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OVER ONE MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS THAT LACK HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IN OUR STATE THAT
COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR FULL
SCOPE MEDIC OUT THAT WOULD BE
EXPANDED TO ALL ADULTS WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE STATE. IN
CERTAIN THAT ALL RESIDENTS HAVE
ACCESS GOOD NIGHT IN TESTING
AND TREATMENT BUT COMPREHENSIVE
COVERAGE WITH PRIMARY AND
PREVENTIVE CARE TO KEEP
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
UNDOCUMENTED SENIOR TO WE KNOW
IS A HIGH RISK POPULATION DUE
TO AGE WE KNOW THAT MANY YEARS
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
WITHIN IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ALSO OFTEN HAVE HIGH RATES OF
CHRONIC. CONDITIONS LIKE
HYPERTENSION. WHAT'S YOUR
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS THAT CAN%
MAKE INDIVIDUAL SUSCEPTIBLE TO
COMPLICATIONS OR EVEN DEATH
FROM FORGET NINETEEN AS AN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE PROACTIVE IN HELP
UNDOCUMENTED FEARS MANAGED PRE
EXISTING CONDITION NOW BY
EXPANDING POST GO MEDI CAL
RIGHT AWAY TO ENSURE ALL OF OUR
STATE SENIOR CAN ACCESS THE
CARE THEY NEED SIMULTANEOUSLY
WE ALSO NEED TO DO MORE TO MAKE
COVER CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE. BOSTON MAKING THE
STATE FUNDED PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM HARMONY WE SHOULD
LEVERAGES FEDERAL FUNDS IF WE
CAN DO MORE TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
CAN BUY COVERAGE ACCESS THE
CARE. THEY NEED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN A COMMENT FROM IRENE
AGREE PLEASE AHEAD. HE IS THE
CHAIRMAN THE VICE CHAIR YOU CAN
BE MEMBERS MY NAME IS AYE
RINKER. I'M AN APARTMENT
REPRESENTED AT ET DE AND
FEDERAL EMPLOYEE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND A PROUD
MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE PRETTY AND LONG DAY
SOMETIMES THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN
HOURS. SEVEN DAYS A WEEK AT
TIMES IT BEING OR SHORTENING
OUR MARGIN IN OUR BREAKS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OUR WORK
IS THE LIFELINE FOR MILLIONS OF
NEWLY UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIA.
EVEN IN THE BEST OF TIMES WE
START MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE IN EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS A SHATTERING
AND TERRIFYING EXPERIENCE. YOU
LOSE YOUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
FOOD FOR YOUR FAMILY. WE MIGHT
SHELTER FOR THEM. THE OVERALL
COMES CRASHING DOWN MANY ARE
DESPERATE SOME ARE CLOSE TO
SUICIDE. AND NOW IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS PANDEMIC THE WORLD HAD
COME CRASHING DOWN THE MILLIONS
MORE CALIFORNIANS. THIS
PANDEMIC HAPPEN TO WORKERS
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL. MANY
OF THEM HAVE NEVER BEEN
UNEMPLOYED IN THEIR LIVES THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM THEY ARE AFRAID AND
CONFUSED IF DON'T HELP LET.
IT'S OUR JOB TO EXTEND THE LIFE
LINE. TO CONNECT THEM TO THE
INCOME REPLACEMENT THEY HAVE
CURRENT UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
BUT EVEN WITH THE THIRD TO MOVE
PEOPLE TO HELP US DO THIS MARK
WE ARE SHORT HANDED. AND OF
UNEMPLOYMENT CONTINUES AT
RECORD HIGHS INTO THE FUTURE WE
WILL NEED TO INVEST MORE IN OUR
SERVICES. LOOKING FORWARD THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT I SEE THAT
WE NEED TO DO AT THE STATE.
FIRST WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS LIFELINE EXTENDS TO EVERY
EMPLOYED WORKER FOR AS LONG AS
PEOPLE NEED IT. SECOND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DELIVER IT. THERE
WILL BE NO RECOVERY FAMILY
CIRCLE UNDER SO I CAN'T ACCESS
THE HELP THEY NEED THANK YOU.
AND A COMMENT FROM CATHERINE
PHILLIPS PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
CATHERINE PHILLIPS DIRECTOR OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA HERE
CALL CALIFORNIANS AMONG THE
SIGNATORIES TO THE LETTER THAT
VICTORIA RUN NOTED IN OUR
TESTIMONY AND I'M GONNA FOCUS
HERE ON JUST ONE OF THE- MANY
OF THE AREAS NOTED IN THAT
LETTER SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF
NINETEEN CRISIS AND SOME RECENT.
PAPER FLICKING COVERED
MORTALITY WITH AIR POLLUTION
AND JUST UNDERSCORED THE
HEIGHTENED DANGERS PEOPLE
LIVING IN AIR POLLUTED AREAS
SPACE WE NEED TO CLEAN UP THE
AIR IN THE STATE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ONE WAY TO
GET CLEAN YOUR HEIRS TO RAPIDLY
TRANSITION AWAY FROM COMBUSTION
ENGINES THAT RELY ON FOSSIL
FUELS IN OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. FORTUNATELY BEFORE THE
CODE CRISIS CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY WAS MOVING STEADILY
TOWARD BECOMING A BLUE GREEN
ECONOMY WHERE THE CENTER FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE PRODUCTION
AMONG INCLUDING GLASSES TRUCKS
CARS MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS. THROUGH INVESTMENT AND
SENTENCED THE STATE CAN
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THE GROWTH
OF THIS INDUSTRY AND PROMOTE
THE CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF
GOOD JOBS PRODUCING THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN INSTALLING
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HELP CAN. INCLUDE SMALL THE
RAPID TRY FROM ZERO ON VEHICLES
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
JUST. LOOK AT. THE OTHER
ECONOMY TO SHIP ME A IN SAN PRO
AND EFFORTS TO HELP THE JOB
GROWTH THAT ELECTRIC BASS AND
TRUCK INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY PROUD
FINE WE ALSO AND TO ENSURE
PUBLIC TRANSIT REMAINS A VIABLE
IN CLEAN OPTION FROM ABILITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE GO TO
OUR BRANTLEY GARCIA THE LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT- BRANDING ON
THE ON BEHALF OF CAL THERE ARE.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
REGARDING THE TRANSPORTATION
AND AIR QUALITY ONLY A COUPLE
MORE THINGS I'D LIKE TO ADD. A
ONE OF THEM IS THAT FOR THE
CRISIS MORE LET YOU BE ABLE TO
BE MANUFACTURED IN CALIFORNIA
THAN ANY OTHER STATE. BUT THEN%
PLANNING GROWING AT A STEADY
RATE IN THAT INDUSTRY- WE'VE
BEEN HURT HER ARE LIKE MANY
OTHER INDUSTRIES AT THAT PLANT
CLOSURES ABOUT TEMPORARY LOSS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS. OKAY
BECOME PERMANENT WITHOUT SOME
KIND OF STIMULUS. I WOULD BE
THAT THE BENEFITS ARE TWOFOLD
ONE IS THE OBVIOUS AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS AND- YOU KNOW ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF LAW THAT THEY
LEAD TO INCREASED. MORTALITY
OVER A LONG LIFETIME. I WOULD
GIVE IT A REGISTRY PROVIDES
ECONOMIC BENEFITS- FOR EACH
DOLLAR LEVERAGE BY THE DAY WE
GET SICK DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
CAPITAL AND WE HAVE MANY SHOVEL
READY PROJECT THAT ARE LEADING
WITH HIGHER BATTLE HIGH WAGE
JOBS- SO WE THINK THAT OUR
ENTRY. I MET NOT ONLY READY FOR
STIMULUS BUT ALSO READY TO GO
BACK TO WORK WHEN NECESSARY-
DON'T TO THE CHAIR AND OR THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSITION TO
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
ALL THOSE ANYBODY ELSE WHO'S ON
THE PHONE FOR THE SAME. BETTER
WE APPRECIATE THE LETTER WE
HAVE YOUR- WE HAVE YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. A PERSON IN I DON'T
HAVE THEIR NAME IF YOU COULD
ASK THEIR NAME IN THE BILL GIVE
ME YOUR THEIR COMMENT WE HAVE A
LINE OPEN FOR SPANISH. SEE WHAT
HAPPENS BUT IF I WOULD LOVE TO
KNOW. WHAT A PORTABLE THE
SIGNAL SO NOBODY A NECESSITY ON
LOCAL SYSTEM AND THAT IS. THE
NUMBER OF CANADIAN MINISTER.
YEAH US MILLION DOLLAR DEAL SO
JENNIFER COMMON VETERANS BUT
I'LL UPLOAD THAT ARE JUST AND
ALL BUT I LOVE I KNOW YOU LOVE
I LOOKED NEW CONTENT IS WILL
HAND VACATE AND I'LL TELL YOU
THAT MUCH THIS ONE OUT UP ONLY
THAT GET ENOUGH WITHOUT A-
LITTLE ME ON THE FROM BEING BY
THE MOST COMPLEX LOOK I'M IN.
SOME A COUPLE UNBIASED BUT BY
THE WILL GET FROM POINT ONLY
INPUT ON THE MOUNTING CUENTA I
MEAN. IN THE- BOB. WHEN LOOK AT
SOME OF CALM THE LOOK AT HELLO
MY YEAH NOT ABLE KILL NOT UP
THE WILL COME. THE ONE THING
OKAY THANK YOU WILL GO. A
HEARING YOUR MIND OPEN HELLO
ONCE AGAIN JENNIFER DID YOU
WANT TO. IF YOU IF YOU IF YOU
WANT YOU DON'T HAVE TO. OKAY
THAT'S GOOD THANK YOU JENNIFER
THE- GOOD AFTERNOON MR KAREN
MEMBERS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS
AND ARE EIGHT THOUSAND MOSTLY
SMALL AND MID SCALE FARMER
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT
80% OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS ARE
SMALL FARMERS INCLUDING MANY
IMMIGRANT FARMERS AND THEY ARE
SCRAMBLING TO CHANGE THEIR
OPERATIONS WITH CROPS ALREADY
IN THE GROUND. LIKE OTHER THAN
A FOOD CHAIN WHERE VICTIM A LOT
CONTRACTS RESTAURANT CLOSURES
AND STRUGGLING REGIONAL FOOD
HAD THE DISTRIBUTORS WHEN I
HEARD YOU TO WITH THE FAMILY
FARMERS IN THREE WAYS BY ONE
ESTABLISHING A CALIFORNIA FARM
CRISIS CENTER FOCUSED ON SMALL
AND MID SCALE GROWERS HOW THAT
COULD COORDINATE THE NECESSARY
ONE ON ONE SUPPORT TO LOCAL
GROWERS TO CONNECT WITH LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
RESOURCES. TO LAUNCHING A
STATEWIDE PROCUREMENT STRATEGY
AND A CALIFORNIA BY FRESH BY
LOCAL MARKETING EFFORT AND
THREE TO HELP EMERGENCY FOOD
SYSTEM IN SCHOOL THE UTILIZED
LOCAL FOOD THE STATE SHOULD
UTILIZE FEDERAL MONEY FROM THAT
FOOD. MARKETING FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THE FARM FAMILIES
PROGRAM FEMA AND CARE ACT
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION IS SPENT ON
LOCAL FOOD PROCUREMENT THAT
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. END
UP. COMMENT FROM MICHELE GIVEN
THE LINE OPEN. MEMBERS MITCHELL
GIVEN FROM THE COUNTY HEALTH
THE EXECUTIVE A FIFTY CENT
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT BETTER STATE
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO PREVENT
AND RESPOND CO THE NINETEEN IN
OUR COMMUNITY I'M I'D LIKE TO
THINK OF FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM
PREVENTION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTACT SHAPING WHICH IS THE
CORE ROLE PROVIDED BY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND TESTING
IN ANY EFFORT TO REOPEN OUR
COMMUNITY I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT IN THE LAST ECONOMIC
RECESSION PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SIGNIFICANT CUTS TO
OUR STAFFING IN PROGRAM DUE TO
THE CLIENT AND FEDERAL AND
STATE. AND NINETY ONE RELY. AND
SENT THEN LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. HAVE NEVER RECOVER
BACK TO PRE RECESSION LEVELS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
REPEAT THESE BLESSED THAT. WELL
WE UNDERSTAND THAT MANY
DIFFERENT FACTORS AND COMMUNITY
HAVE BEEN ADVERSELY IMPACTED WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IF LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES GOING FURTHER.
AT THE RISK OF FURTHER DOCUMENT
YOUR COMMUNITIES WILL REMAIN
HIGH AND FURTHER DOCUMENTS IN
THE ECONOMY ONLY ACT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE WITH
INVESTMENT INTO LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE
CAN PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE QUESTION OR A COMMENT AND
THREE OF FROM CHIANA TO DO THAT
JOHN OF THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TING IN
MEMBERS KIANA CITY ON BEHALF OF
THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM. A COALITION OF THE
LARGEST MULTI STATE IN MULTI
STATE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN
THE COUNTRY. EASY EASY MEMBERS
HAVE OVER SIX THOUSAND
LOCATIONS IN FORTY EIGHT STATES
COLLECTIVELY STARVING OVER ONE
MILLION CHILDREN AND EMPLOYING
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND EARLY EDUCATORS. IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE EASY EASY
MEMBERS OPERATE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED HIGH QUALITY
CHILDCARE CENTERS. LIKE MANY
OTHER BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY CHILD CARE CENTERS HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE CURRENT
A VIRUS CRISIS. 75% OF CHILD
CARE CENTERS HAVE BEEN CLOSED
ACROSS THE NATION AND DO YOU
HAVE PROJECTIONS THAT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WILL EXPERIENCE
AND 90% LOSS OF REVENUE BY NAY.
THEY WILL NOT HAVE THE
LIQUIDITY TO SURVIVE HOUSE THE
STATE AND MANY WILL BE FORCED
TO CLOSE REGARD. CHILD CARE AND
YOU KNOW IS A CRUCIAL PART OF
AMERICAN WORK FORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE 65% OF CHILDREN
UNDER SIX. HAVE ALL PARENTS IN
LABOR I'M IN THE LABOR FORCE
ANY FAMILIES COME FROM A WIDE
VARIETY OF. TO US NOT LIKE
BACKGROUND. AT CALIFORNIA
BEGINS OVERCOME THE CRISIS REAL
NIKON ANY AND IF HOW FAMILY GO
BACK WORK CHILD CARE. WILL ONCE
AGAIN BE AT THE HEART OF
PROVIDING IN STATE HEALTHY IN
SECURE ENVIRONMENT. FOR THE
CHILDREN OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE. IF SENATORS DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
PAY RENT RE HIRE STAFF AND
IMPLEMENT SAFETY WERE
MEASUREMENT. THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO REOPEN WHEN THE FULL
FARE SEVERELY IMPACT OUR PATH
TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND A
COMMENT FROM MEGAN SUBER'S MAY
GIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MEGAN TO BREAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION CBCA REPRESENTS
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR ABOUT OVER SEVEN MILLION
PATIENTS THEIR PRIMARY CARE
NEEDS APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS FROM MOST OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY ABOUT
THE- WORKFORCE CHALLENGES THAT
OUR HEALTH SYSTEM AS A WHOLE IS
GOING TO FACE. ACCESS TO PRIME
CARE- I WANTED TO TOUCH ON THE
POINT THAT I THINK WE WERE
BLOOM BROUGHT UP ABOUT THE-
CONTACT TRACING AND TESTING
ABILITIES FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS. WE HAVE HOPE INTEREST
RIGHT NOW WHO WHEN THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE. ARE
PROVIDING TESTING AND ART IS
SITUATED IN THE STATE SUCH WAY
ISN'T REPRESENTED IN EVERY
COUNTY RURAL AND URBAN AREAS
THAT THEY WOULD BE PERFECTLY.
POSITIONED TO CARRY OUT MARCUS
TESTING IN CONTRACT CONTACT
TREATING AND WANT TO BE HELPFUL
FOR THE STATE AS LONG AS THEY
HAVE REPORT IS AVAILABLE SO
JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION MORE AS THINGS
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO ANTI ANTI
WONDER IS NEXT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THE
AND YOU WONDER ON BEHALF OF THE
TWO TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS ARE BUSINESS
LEADERS THAT ADVOCATE POLICIES
THAT ARE GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY
COULD THE ENVIRONMENT. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT ADDRESSING THIS
CRISIS CAN BE SOLVED WHILE ON
CRISIS IMPACTING THE COURSE ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
POLICY LEADERSHIP WILL DRIVE
LONG TERM RESILIENCY AND
POSITION THE STATE FOR STRONG
RECOVERY. YOU TO CLEAN JOBS
REPORT SHOWS THAT OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
WORKING RENEWABLE ENERGY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY GREEN VEHICLES ARE
RECENTLY RELEASED REPORT ALSO
SHOWS THE IMPACT OF KOBE TO THE
INDUSTRY IN MARCH ALONE TWENTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA CLEAN
ENERGY EMPLOYEES WERE LAID OFF
AND THE NUMBERS ARE GROWING
DAILY. THANK YOU CRAP
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY PASSPORT
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THIS
CRITICAL INDUSTRY IN
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ELECTRIC
FACTORY WORKERS AND OTHER
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK IN THIS IN
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY IF WE
EXECUTE OUR CODE NINETEEN
RESPONSE PROPERLY CLEAN ENERGY
INDUSTRY WILL RECOVER EXPAND.
SERVING AS AN ECONOMIC ENGINE
OF JOB GROWTH DRIVING
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THERE'S PRECEDENT
FOR THE INDUSTRY RECOVERABLE
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION NO
PART OF THE AMERICAN RECOVERY
AND REINVESTMENT ACT AS MORE
SUCCESSFUL INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
ENERGY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND OTHER
POLICY MAKERS TO HELP ADVANCE.
ACROSS THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I WILL GO TO LOOK. ALL THE
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN THANK BECOME MAIL ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COMMITTED TO GO THERE BY. AT
THE COACHELLA VALLEY WERE
ALREADY FACING A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND WE HAVE TO STATE THE
CONTINUED COMMITMENT AND
INVESTMENT IN RESPONDING TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. HEALTH CRISIS TO
ABATE THE HEALTH RISK AND-
SORRY GONNA MAKE AND DINNER
LATE- OUR ECONOMY BY YOUR
CLIENT WITH- MAKE SO AND WE
HAVE A RIVER THAT FLOWS NORTH
THAT IS. THAT CONTAINS-
DANGEROUS PATHOGENS AND ALSO
CARRIES OUT VIRUSES- WE ASK
THAT THE STATE COULD MAINTAIN
ITS PHYSICAL COMMITMENT TO THE
NEW RIVER. AND THAT A BAIT.
THAT MAKE THRIVING CONDITION
AND IT'S A SHOVEL READY STATUS
WHICH WILL CREATE JOBS. AND
RESULT IN ECONOMIC BENEFIT.
THANK OF THE MINIMUM DETAILED
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. AN
ALTERNATE BACK TO OUR SPEAKER
THANK YOU. GREAT I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING ONE ALSO JUST
THINK THAT THANK THE MEMBERS
AND JUST AGAIN- I SHOT OUT TO
ALL THE STAFF TO PUT IN
NUMEROUS HOURS TO PUT ON THIS
HEARING AND THEN HEARING FROM
LAST WEEK REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE PANELISTS- FROM EARLIER
TODAY I THOUGHT THE GIVE GREAT
PRESENTATIONS ARE WE KNOW THAT
A VERY TOUGH ROAD IS AHEAD OF
US WE APPRECIATE EVERYBODY FOR
STAYING HOME IS STAYING SAFE
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE HERE- DOING
OUR JOB TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE
EVERYONE'S LIFE BETTER. I THINK
YOU ALSO APARTMENT A FINANCE IN
LA FOR JOINING US AND STICKING
WITH OUR HEARING. E VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE TOMORROW ON MISTER
THE PARTY'S GONNA BE BACK WITH
THE BUDGET SUB TO. SO WITH THAT
WE ARE ADJOURNED.